This is the 99% Invisible Breakdown of The Power Broker. I'm Roman Mars. And I'm Elliot Kalin. Today is the day, my friends. We are finishing the book. If you want to get precise, we're covering chapters 47 through 50, pages 1,082 through 1,162. Now, we said last episode that we were not going to cover the notes section after the end of the book, but I guess you're just gonna have to stick around to find out if I can keep that promise. And later in this episode, our special guest is none other than Robert Caro himself.
这是《99% Invisible》对《权力掮客》的深度解析。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我是埃利奥特·卡林。朋友们，今天就是这一天了。我们要读完这本书。如果说得精确点，我们要讲的是第47章到第50章，第1082页到第1162页。上一集我们说过不会讲书后的注释部分，但我猜你得留下来听听我是否能信守承诺。在本集的后半部分，我们的特别嘉宾正是罗伯特·卡罗本人。
As we close the book and this series, we wanted to visit him again to get his perspective on the ending and the book's legacy. So on the last Power Broker breakdown, we learned that Robert Moses tried to put a parking lot in the Tavern in the Green, on the Tavern in the Green, in the Tavern on the Green. I'm not sure. One of those.
随着我们合上这本书并结束这个系列，我们想再次拜访他，听听他对结局和这本书遗产的看法。在上一期《权力掮客》解析中，我们了解到罗伯特·摩西试图在绿茵酒馆（Tavern on the Green）里建一个停车场。我不确定是“在”还是“关于”，反正就是那个地方。
Choose your own preposition. And ran against some moms who did not want it there. And it was kind of his first big New York newspaper defeat, which was a big deal, even though the crime itself was probably not as big a deal. And it sort of tarnished Moses' reputation for infallibility and incorruptibility. The New York papers finally got off their doves and started reporting on corruption
介词随你选。他对抗了一些反对在那儿建停车场的妈妈们。这算是他在纽约报界遭遇的第一次重大失败，虽然这件事本身可能没那么严重，但意义重大。它在某种程度上玷污了摩西“绝不犯错、绝不腐败”的名声。纽约的报纸终于不再装聋作哑，开始报道摩西公共住房项目中的腐败问题。
in Moses' public housing projects. One of Moses' aides, The Mustache, tries to pick a fight or does pick a fight with Joe Papp over allowing free Shakespeare in the park. This is another one of these just terrible fumbles that damages Moses' reputation as the champion of the people. The news media discovers some fairly small-ball scandals that are unfair to Moses as Caro freely admits,
摩西的一名助手，“胡子男”，试图找乔·帕普的麻烦，或者说确实找了他的麻烦，因为帕普允许在公园里免费表演莎士比亚戏剧。这是摩西又一次极其糟糕的失误，损害了他作为“人民捍卫者”的声誉。新闻媒体发现了一些相当琐碎的丑闻，正如卡罗坦率承认的那样，这对摩西来说是不公平的，
but they do actually stick to him for the first time. It encourages unfair to Moses, as Caro sort of freely admits, but they do actually kind of stick to him for the first time. And it encourages him to drop housing as one of the things he covers and resign his city jobs in order to become president of the 1964 World's Fair. And then, after he's lost those city jobs or resigned from those city jobs, the new governor, Nelson Rockefeller, calls Moses' bluff. They have a little bit of a fight. Moses decides to pull his old trick,
但这些丑闻确实第一次让他陷入了困境。这促使他放弃了住房项目，辞去了城市职务，转而担任1964年世界博览会的主席。然后，在他失去或辞去那些城市职务后，新任州长纳尔逊·洛克菲勒看穿了摩西的虚张声势。他们发生了一点冲突。摩西决定故技重施，
threatens to resign from all of his state appointments, and Rockefeller calls his bluff, and he accepts the resignation for his state jobs. And this is enormous self-own. That would be the true beginning of the end of Moses. And so this is the last section that we will cover. I cannot believe it. We'll be covering pages 1082 to 1162,
威胁要辞去他所有的州政府职务，结果洛克菲勒看穿了他的虚张声势，直接接受了他的辞呈。这简直是自掘坟墓。那将是摩西走向终结的真正开始。这就是我们要讲的最后一部分。我简直不敢相信。我们将涵盖第1082页到第1162页，
the final section of the book. How are you feeling, Elliot Kaelin? I'm feeling both good and also, I can't quite believe it. Doing this show, reading this book has been such a part of my life for so long now, this year, that I kind of don't believe there are any other books. It's hard for me to imagine ever reading another book
书的最后一部分。你感觉如何，埃利奥特·卡林？我感觉既好，又有点不敢相信。做这个节目、读这本书已经成为我生活的一部分太久了，这一年来，我甚至觉得好像没有别的书了。我很难想象自己还会去读另一本书，
that's not this book. Totally. I feel the same way. Maybe we'll talk at the end, maybe not about, what a dream this has been and how much this has been such a wonderful thing to be a part of and I'm so excited about it. But I don't know, we're not done yet.
而不是这本书。完全同意。我也一样。也许最后我们会聊聊，也许不会，聊聊这段经历是多么像一场梦，参与其中是多么美妙，我对此感到非常兴奋。但我不知道，我们还没结束呢。
Roma, do you think we're gonna be able to make it through the end? Yeah, we're not done yet. So let's just start with chapter 47, the great fair. What are we talking about here? So that great fair is the aforementioned 1964 World's Fair. So we're not gonna start right at 1964. We're gonna start at 1959,
罗曼，你觉得我们能坚持到最后吗？是的，我们还没结束。那么让我们从第47章“伟大的博览会”开始吧。我们在这里讨论的是什么？那个“伟大的博览会”就是前面提到的1964年世界博览会。我们不会直接从1964年开始。我们要从1959年开始，
which is when he begins running the fair. But first, before we get into the section, I need to make a disclaimer. I am very partial to a specific New York World's Fair. And that fair is, of course, the 1939 World's Fair, the world of tomorrow. Like, what a vision, what a dream of the future, bold, innovative, predictions that came true,
那是他开始筹办博览会的时候。但在进入这一部分之前，我需要做一个免责声明。我对某届纽约世界博览会有特殊的偏爱。那届博览会当然就是1939年的世界博览会，“明日世界”。那样的愿景，那样的未来之梦，大胆、创新，有些预言成真了，
some that didn't. My grandmother attended it as a girl and would tell me stories about it. It's where most people saw television for the first time in the New York area. It's a very major thing. And Robert Caro throughout the book is always taking digs at Grover Whelan, the chairman of that New York World's Fair of 1939, 1940, because Grover Whelan admittedly was kind of like an incompetent dandy,
有些则没有。我祖母小时候参加过，还给我讲过关于它的故事。那是大多数纽约地区的人第一次见到电视的地方。这是一件非常重大的事情。罗伯特·卡罗在整本书中一直在挖苦1939-1940年纽约世界博览会的主席格罗弗·惠伦，因为格罗弗·惠伦公认是个无能的花花公子，
who was just kind of like wasting money and was better known for like wearing a flower in his buttonhole all the time than actually doing things properly. And Carol was constantly talking about what a waste role and what a failure that fair is. And I just want to say that legacy of that fair is so much greater than the 64 World's Fair that Moses can oversee, which is, you know,
他只是在浪费钱，比起真正把事情做好，他更出名的是总是戴着一朵花在扣眼里。卡罗一直在说惠伦是多么浪费，那届博览会是多么失败。我只想说，那届博览会的遗产远比摩西负责的64年世界博览会要伟大得多，后者，你知道，
it has a certain lack of ambition. You're gonna find about it in this chapter. But if I am, I took some heat a number of episodes back for really going after Philly as the potential site of the United Nations, if there's anyone here with a similar feeling about the 1964-65 World's Fair, I apologize. I just do not, it doesn't live up
缺乏某种雄心。你会在这一章里读到。如果我——我在几集前因为抨击费城作为联合国潜在选址而受到了一些批评，如果这里有人对1964-65年世界博览会有类似的感觉，我道歉。我只是觉得，它达不到
to the previous New York World's Fair. I just gotta say it in my mind. I think that's fair. I think that's fair. So this is another one of those things where to tell the whole story, he has to back up a little bit. So Moses is running the fair from 1959 to 1965.
上一届纽约世界博览会的高度。我心里就是这么想的。我觉得这很公平。我觉得这很公平。所以，这是那种为了讲清楚整个故事，他必须稍微倒叙一下的情况。摩西从1959年到1965年负责博览会。
And so this is all during the initial planning stages. And this is when he has the showdown with Rockefeller in 1962. So while the fair is ramping up, but before it opens, Moses is already in decline. He's already lost all of his appointments. Yes, so he has left his city jobs in order to take on the presidency of the fair
所以这一切都发生在最初的规划阶段。也就是他在1962年与洛克菲勒摊牌的时候。所以当博览会筹备起来，但在开幕之前，摩西已经在走下坡路了。他已经失去了所有的任命。是的，他辞去了城市职务，转而担任博览会主席，
because there's so much more money and there's gonna be so much less controversy and this could be a source of power for him as we'll see. But yeah, it's during that period in 1962, the year that Spider-Man first appears, that Rockefeller accepts his resignation. So yeah, this chapter straddles that somewhat. That's right.
因为那里有更多的钱，争议会更少，正如我们将看到的，这可能成为他权力的来源。但确实，就在1962年那个时期，也就是蜘蛛侠首次出现的年份，洛克菲勒接受了他的辞呈。所以，这一章确实跨越了那个阶段。没错。
And the only thing he has left is he has, he is still the head of the Triborough Authority, and he's still the sort of, I can't remember the official title, but the liaison to the Federal Highway Commission. He's the unofficial representative for the city and state on arterial highways. That's right.
他唯一剩下的职位是，他仍然是三区大桥管理局的负责人，而且他仍然是某种——我不记得正式头衔了，但他是联邦公路委员会的联络人。他是城市和州在干线公路方面的非官方代表。没错。
It's always arterial. There's blood on that pavement. So as we'll find out in this chapter, he's initially attracted to this fair because of the idea of the power that could come from it. There's an issue right off the bat though. As Robert Caro is saying, the New York World's Fair of 1964 to 1965, it seems like a big undertaking, but it's simply not large enough in scope to really engage Moses' interest. This is a guy who's used to building things that will potentially last centuries, and now his main job is going to be overseeing a public event with a built-in lifespan of
总是干线公路。路面上沾满了鲜血。正如我们在这一章中会发现的，他最初被这个博览会吸引，是因为他看到了从中可能产生的权力。但一开始就有一个问题。正如罗伯特·卡罗所说，1964年至1965年的纽约世界博览会，看起来像是一个大工程，但它的规模根本不足以真正引起摩西的兴趣。这家伙习惯于建造可能持续几个世纪的东西，而现在他的主要工作是监督一个预设寿命只有
two years. And then once it's over, it's over. It's the point of these World's Fairs. They're temporary. They're transient. So Moses, he's not doing this because he loves fairs. He's not doing this because he just wants a job for a couple of years. Everything with Moses is a step to the thing that Moses has always dreamed of. He has these dreams that come to him when he's young,
两年的公共活动。一旦结束，就结束了。这就是这些世界博览会的特点。它们是临时的。它们是短暂的。所以摩西做这件事不是因为他热爱博览会。他做这件事不是因为他只想找份工作干几年。摩西所做的一切都是为了实现他一直梦想的目标。他年轻时就有这些梦想，
and he's spending decades trying to get them. And in this case, he says, I can use this to finally clear and improve the land for what will one day be known in his mind as Robert Moses Park, this chain of parks going through Queens in the former marshland of Flushing Meadows, Queens, that in his mind will be the biggest public parks, the best public parks ever in the world. And he's been dreaming at this for a long time.
他花了数十年时间试图实现它们。在这种情况下，他说，我可以利用这个机会最终清理并改善土地，为他心目中终有一天会被称为“罗伯特·摩西公园”的地方做准备，这是一串穿过皇后区法拉盛草甸前沼泽地的公园，在他心目中，这将是世界上最伟大的公共公园。他为此梦想了很久。
And this is another one of his things where you have to admire the visionary quality of it a little bit, because when he first starts dreaming about this, Flushing Meadows is literally an enormous garbage and ash dump. There's so many great names in this book, and apparently the contractor running this was named Fish Hooks McCarthy. That's someone who like Batman beats up for information about where the penguin is. But it was this enormous, enormous garbage dump. This is where all of Brooklyn's garbage was taken and burned. And there was a local landmark, which was a hundred foot tall hill of garbage
这是他的另一件事，你不得不佩服他的一点远见，因为当他第一次开始梦想这个时，法拉盛草甸实际上是一个巨大的垃圾和灰烬堆。这本书里有很多很棒的名字，显然经营这个承包商的人叫“鱼钩”麦卡锡。那就像蝙蝠侠为了打听企鹅人在哪儿而痛扁的人。但那是一个巨大的、巨大的垃圾场。这是布鲁克林所有垃圾被运来焚烧的地方。那里有一个当地的地标，是一座一百英尺高的垃圾山，
called Mount Corona, because this was the Corona part of Queens. This is a place that, just to detail, it's so infested with vermin that there's a community of shanty dwellers who live in this dump and make a living trapping the rats and other mammals and selling their fur to the furriers of New York City. And like Fitzgerald describes this in the Great Gatsby, it's just this nightmarish wasteland,
被称为“科罗纳山”，因为这是皇后区的科罗纳地区。这是一个地方，详细来说，它被害虫严重侵扰，有一群棚户区居民住在这个垃圾场里，靠捕捉老鼠和其他哺乳动物，把它们的皮卖给纽约市的皮草商为生。就像菲茨杰拉德在《了不起的盖茨比》中描述的那样，这简直是一个噩梦般的荒原，
this just horrible, the most dystopian city section that you can imagine. But Robert Moses and true Moses style, like he sees what could be the most amazing park in the history of New York. And in fact, it's a bigger area than Central Park. It's 1,346 acres. It is actually in the geographic center of New York, when you include all the boroughs. And it could just be this amazing thing.
这是你能想象到的最可怕、最反乌托邦的城市区域。但罗伯特·摩西，以真正的摩西风格，他看到了这可能成为纽约历史上最令人惊叹的公园。事实上，它的面积比中央公园还大。它有1346英亩。当你把所有行政区都算上时，它实际上位于纽约的地理中心。它本可以成为一件了不起的事情。
And the beginning of the problem with him running the World's Fair is that the World's Fair is trying to exist as this temporary explosion of creativity of the moment of now, maybe a little bit of the future. And it has temporary buildings, it has people coming in just for those two years.
他经营世界博览会的问题在于，世界博览会试图作为一种当下的、也许带有一点未来感的临时创造力爆发而存在。它有临时建筑，有只在那两年里来的人。
He's just so uninterested in that and he wants to create this park that will stand for the ages. And it just is, immediately that's the source of all the problems when it comes to him running the fair. Yes, and this is something that Moses is so fixated on because he's wanted it for many years. And Carol goes into these previous times where it seems like Moses was going to be able to get a little bit closer to building this enormous string of parks.
他对这些毫无兴趣，他想创造一个能流传后世的公园。这立刻就成了他经营博览会时所有问题的根源。是的，这是摩西非常执着的事情，因为他已经渴望多年了。卡罗提到了之前的几次机会，当时摩西似乎能够更接近建造这串巨大的公园。
But each time it doesn't quite work out. The 3940 World's Fair, remember, that's 15 years into Moses being the parks guy. And so he's like, great, we'll put the 39 World's Fair here and we'll clean it up with the profits from the fair that'll make this park. But of course that fair makes no profits. None of them ever do. World's fairs never make money. It's like the Olympics, it never makes money. And then the needs are so big,
但每次都不太顺利。记住，39-40年的世界博览会，那是摩西担任公园负责人的第15年。所以他想，太好了，我们把39年世界博览会放在这里，用博览会的利润清理它，建成这个公园。但当然，那届博览会没有任何利润。从来没有过。世界博览会从不赚钱。就像奥运会一样，它从不赚钱。而且需求太大了，
it's gonna cost so much money. There's a part where Caro was talking about how they need to put in a new drainage system because there are mud waves that will rip apart wooden foundations and pilings that they install into this marshland. Like it's so it's such a terrible place to build anything. But that park is a disaster. Later on, Moses is like, maybe this could be the site for the UN headquarters.
要花很多钱。卡罗提到他们需要安装一个新的排水系统，因为会有泥浪撕裂他们安装在这个沼泽地里的木制地基和桩基。这地方建什么都太糟糕了。但那个公园是个灾难。后来，摩西想，也许这可以作为联合国总部的选址。
Like he's looking for any opportunity to refurbish this land. In 1951, Queens needs a new storm sewer system and Moses gets it put in the area he would need it for his parks to make them. And so by 1959, people are talking about a new World's Fair. He's like, if I'm the president of this World's Fair, I can finally lay the foundation properly for these parks, for Robert Moses Park.
他一直在寻找任何机会来翻新这块土地。1951年，皇后区需要一个新的雨水下水道系统，摩西把它安装在他需要建公园的区域。所以到了1959年，人们在谈论新的世界博览会。他想，如果我是这个世界博览会的主席，我终于可以为这些公园，为罗伯特·摩西公园打下坚实的基础。
And this is something that in a footnote, Carroll points out, he goes, another piece of evidence that Moses was really thinking about the future park and not the fair is that when the transit system is like, hey, can we make a subway extension to go to the fair site and bring more people who can pay for tickets? He goes, no, because he does not want low-income people
卡罗在脚注中指出，这是另一个证据，证明摩西真正考虑的是未来的公园而不是博览会，当交通系统说，嘿，我们能不能修一条地铁延长线到博览会现场，带来更多能买票的人？他说，不，因为他不想让低收入人群
taking the subway to that park, not interested. Truly the Moses way. But Carroll also points out that this is one of those things after the housing debacle and all these sort of little crises that are sort of plaguing Moses, attaching himself to the fair is just a good PR move. Like he's coming back to being the parks guy, all fun. Jones Beach, put in a park in your neighborhood
坐地铁去那个公园，没兴趣。这确实是摩西的作风。但卡罗也指出，在住房惨败和所有这些困扰摩西的小危机之后，将自己与博览会联系起来是一个很好的公关举措。就像他回归做公园负责人一样，很有趣。琼斯海滩，在你的社区建个公园，
and we're gonna put on the fair. And it's just a lot of potential popularity and power. And it also is a lot of money that comes in that he can distribute to contractors and to people like building things that are necessary for the fair, about pavilions and walkways and landscaping, all the types of things that he knows
我们要举办博览会。这有很多潜在的受欢迎程度和权力。而且还有很多钱进来，他可以分配给承包商和那些建造博览会必需品的人，关于展馆、人行道和景观美化，所有他知道
how to spend that kind of money, and he knows all the people that he can give that money to. Yes, and just to give you an idea of how much money he has to throw around, in the fair's first cost estimate, there's a line on that just says, miscellaneous, $55 million. It's like, all right, it's a pretty big bucket, just throw whatever in.
如何花掉这些钱的事情，他也认识所有可以把钱给谁的人。是的，为了让你了解他有多少钱可以挥霍，在博览会的初步成本估算中，有一行写着“杂项，5500万美元”。这就像，好吧，这是一个很大的桶，随便往里扔吧。
But so if you're a politically connected contractor, you will get a contract from Moses, a very generous contract, and you'll have permission to kind of gouge the exhibitors with their high prices. The exhibitors at the fair, they have to get insurance from one specific insurance company that's politically connected and it annoys Mayor Wagner, who's still mayor at the time, because these contracts are going to his political rivals, but he is so obsessed with never asking Moses for a favor because that would give
所以如果你是一个有政治背景的承包商，你会从摩西那里得到一份合同，一份非常慷慨的合同，你将有权以高价敲诈参展商。博览会的参展商必须从一家有政治背景的特定保险公司购买保险，这让当时的市长瓦格纳感到恼火，因为这些合同流向了他的政治对手，但他太执着于从不向摩西求情，因为那会给
Moses leverage over him that he just refuses to ask, hey, can those contracts go to my guys? And Moses is like, all he has to do is ask. All he's got to do is ask me. And Wagner's like, no, never. I'll never give you that inch. And Moses starts to brag and talk about how so much money is coming in from advanced ticket sales, which means that the contractors are like, great, we can charge even more money.
摩西对他施加杠杆作用，所以他拒绝问，嘿，那些合同能给我的人吗？摩西说，他只需要开口。他只需要问我。瓦格纳说，不，永远不会。我永远不会给你那个机会。摩西开始吹嘘，谈论预售票带来了多少钱，这意味着承包商们想，太好了，我们可以收更多的钱。
And Moses, he's just spending so lavishly because he expects this fair to be a huge success. And he's doing very tri-bro type spending things. For security for the fair, he doesn't even have security guards, but he hires this platoon of uniformed Pinkerton agents who wear white gloves and white ascots. And they're like an honor guard at the fair headquarters,
摩西挥霍无度，因为他预计这届博览会会取得巨大成功。他做着非常“三区大桥”式的花钱方式。为了博览会的安保，他甚至没有保安，而是雇佣了一排穿着白手套和白领结的平克顿特工。他们就像博览会总部的仪仗队，
and all of his cronies get great jobs, they all have expense accounts, limousines, chauffeurs, there's chefs for VIP guests. If you know anyone who knows Moses, you get in for free. Again, his whole Yale graduating class gets the royal treatment at the fair, because the fair's gonna pay for it. Moses is like, I'm used to spending a lot of money
他所有的亲信都得到了好工作，他们都有差旅费、豪华轿车、司机，还有为贵宾准备的厨师。如果你认识任何认识摩西的人，你就可以免费进入。同样，他整个耶鲁大学的毕业班在博览会上都受到了皇室般的待遇，因为博览会要为此买单。摩西说，我习惯于花很多钱
at Triborough just to show off, just to win people over. I can do that here too. And so in the first year, the fair's gonna pay for it. Moses is like, I'm used to spending a lot of money at Triborough just to show off, just to win people over. I can do that here too. And so in the first year, the fair corporation ends up spending twice its original budget. Like they're so vastly overspending, it's ridiculous. Yeah, and sort of confusing because up to that point in his career, he hasn't really had a tendency to spend money he didn't have.
在三区大桥只是为了炫耀，只是为了赢得人心。我在这里也能做到。所以第一年，博览会公司最终花费了其原始预算的两倍。他们挥霍得太厉害了，简直荒谬。是的，这有点令人困惑，因为在他职业生涯的那个阶段，他并没有花掉他没有的钱的倾向。
Like, you know, it just was pouring in to such an extent that he could spend money and do these lavish things, but then, you know, but the nickels and dimes were coming at such an extent that it didn't really matter. It just kind of reminds me of just like, of, you know, just being a rich kid, not knowing the value of money potentially, you know, because he's gotten so much pouring in all the time.
你知道，钱源源不断地涌入，以至于他可以花钱做这些奢华的事情，但那些零钱进来的程度使得这并不重要。这让我想起了一个富家子弟，可能不知道钱的价值，你知道，因为他一直有那么多钱涌入。
But at this point, you know, he's spending money that he doesn't have yet. And it's really something. It's sort of a new turn for him. I think the rich kid analogy is a good one because he's just so used to being at the head of a massively successful money-making organization that he doesn't quite see yet
但在这一点上，你知道，他花的钱是他还没有赚到的。这真的很特别。这对他来说是一个新的转折。我认为富家子弟的类比很好，因为他太习惯于成为一个极其成功的赚钱组织的负责人，以至于他还没有完全意识到
that it's not that he has the golden touch. And something Carol will get to later in the chapter is talking about how a road or a bridge is something people have to take. Like they need to use it to get where they're going. Whereas a fair, you don't need to go to a fair. Like that is an entertainment choice. And so Moses, I think, is used to building something
并不是他有“点石成金”的魔力。卡罗在这一章后面会谈到，道路或桥梁是人们必须使用的东西。他们需要用它来到达目的地。而博览会，你不需要去博览会。那是一种娱乐选择。所以我认为摩西习惯于建造某样东西，
and having people need to pay him for it, whether they like it or not. And so I think he's just like, I'm making this thing. Whatever I make, makes a ton of money. This is going to make a ton of money. Let's spend that money. It's going to be fine. Let's do it. And as Carol says, he says the World's Fair gave Robert Moses a billion dollars to spend on power and he got his money's worth. And this power means that he can have the city pouring money in too. And eventually the city sinks over $60 million into the fair. And this is means that he can have the city pouring money in too, and eventually the city sinks over $60 million into the fair.
并让人们无论喜不喜欢都必须为之付费。所以我认为他只是想，我正在制造这个东西。无论我制造什么，都能赚大钱。这会赚大钱。让我们花掉那些钱。没问题的。让我们做吧。正如卡罗所说，他说世界博览会给了罗伯特·摩西十亿美元来挥霍权力，他物有所值。这种权力意味着他可以让城市也投入资金。最终，城市向博览会投入了超过6000万美元。这意味着他可以让城市也投入资金，最终城市向博览会投入了超过6000万美元。
And this is a fair that was designed to bring money into the city. And the city is spending tens of millions of dollars on it. But the good thing, Roman, at least this fair is gonna make him popular again, right? But it doesn't. I mean, it sort of ruined his reputation even more. And it's basically his fault.
这是一届旨在为城市带来资金的博览会。而城市却在上面花费了数千万美元。但好消息是，罗曼，至少这届博览会会让他重新受欢迎，对吧？但并没有。我的意思是，它甚至进一步毁了他的名声。这基本上是他的错。
Like he does not run the fair very well. And, and Caro sort of supposes that this is kind of similar to when the first park expansion happened in the cities when he was really going gangbusters. Like he just was pulled in too many directions. And even though, I mean, we've talked about, like this is the time where he's straddled having estate jobs and then leaving estate jobs.
他经营博览会的方式并不好。卡罗推测这类似于当城市第一次进行公园扩张时，他当时确实势不可挡。他被拉向了太多方向。即使，我的意思是，我们谈过，这是他跨越拥有州政府工作然后离开州政府工作的时期。
During the ramp up to the fair, he was building that dam that nobody cares about. He was- No one wants to hear about ever. Don't even tell me about it, yeah. You know, he was doing all these state jobs and he did not have the expertise to know like how, what would be appealing to people.
在博览会筹备期间，他正在建造那个没人关心的水坝。他正在——没人想听那个。别跟我提那个，是的。你知道，他正在做所有这些州政府的工作，他没有专业知识来了解什么对人们有吸引力。
He did not have the finesse when it comes to getting those buy-in from the international community to sort of buy into these pavilions and sponsor them. He didn't have a lot of sponsors from companies. I mean, it ended up not being a very international World's Fair. It didn't seem mostly devoted to Ford, I guess. I mean, the main legacy of the fair is the, I think, great moments with Mr. Lincoln, the attraction at Disneyland that Walt Disney designed for this fair.
他在获得国际社会支持以购买和赞助这些展馆方面没有技巧。他没有很多来自公司的赞助商。我的意思是，它最终并没有成为一个非常国际化的世界博览会。它似乎主要致力于福特，我想。我的意思是，博览会的主要遗产是，我认为，沃尔特·迪士尼为这届博览会设计的迪士尼乐园景点“林肯先生的伟大时刻”。
But you're right, he's doing all these jobs that normally would be a one huge job for a person. And he's still overseeing the dam, he's still overseeing state park expansion, he's still trying to get the Fire Island highway expressway built, and he just doesn't know much about fares. And he's so tied to his group of people, his cronies, that he knows will say yes to him, that he hires them and they don't know anything about fares either. And Carol just talks about, partly Moses just didn't care that much. Like the fare is a means to an end for him and That end is contradictory to the fair
但你是对的，他正在做所有这些通常是一个人的一项巨大工作。他仍然在监督水坝，他仍然在监督州立公园的扩张，他仍然在试图建造火岛高速公路，他只是对博览会了解不多。他太依赖他那群他知道会对他说是的人，他的亲信，他雇佣了他们，他们对博览会也一无所知。卡罗只是谈到，部分原因是摩西根本不在乎。博览会对他来说是一种手段，而那个目的与博览会是矛盾的。
So it'll be better for the park if everything's built cheaply so you can tear it down It's better for the park if you can charge higher rents so that you can have that money later for building the park But it but it scares off exhibitors He doesn't want to have like a big master plan for the fair because it might get in the way of his later plans for The park and like you're, he's used to being arrogant in his little pond of the New York state area and now he's being arrogant on the world stage. And like other, he off the Bureau of International Expositions, which is a real organization, and they tell their members, don't do this fair.
所以如果一切都建得很便宜，以后拆除时对公园更好。如果你能收取更高的租金，以便以后有钱建公园，这对公园更好。但这吓跑了参展商。他不想为博览会制定一个宏大的总体规划，因为它可能会妨碍他以后对公园的计划。他习惯于在纽约州这个小池塘里傲慢，现在他在世界舞台上傲慢。他得罪了国际展览局，这是一个真正的组织，他们告诉成员，不要参加这个博览会。
So it means Britain, Italy, France, big name countries are not gonna be there. And of those Western European powers, only Spain is like, no, we're gonna be in this fair. So like they have Franco's Spain, I guess, represented at the fair, but not a lot of the rest of the world. And Carol says, basically only six major nations appeared at this so-called World's Fair,
所以这意味着英国、意大利、法国等大国都不会参加。在那些西欧大国中，只有西班牙说，不，我们要参加这届博览会。所以我想博览会有佛朗哥的西班牙代表，但世界上其他大部分地区都没有。卡罗说，基本上只有六个主要国家出现在这个所谓的“世界博览会”上，
Indonesia, Egypt, India, Japan, Mexico, and Pakistan, which are great countries. Those are all great countries. I'd like to go to all of them, but you want a World's Fair to have a lot more of the world. More of the world represented. I mean, and this idea of his just sort of being so against
印度尼西亚、埃及、印度、日本、墨西哥和巴基斯坦，这些都是伟大的国家。这些都是伟大的国家。我想去所有这些国家，但你希望世界博览会有更多的世界参与。有更多的世界代表。我的意思是，这种他如此反对
these temporary pavilions and only interested in things that he could repurpose later. temporary pavilions and only interested in things that he could repurpose later. And the thing is, when it comes to fairs like this, the only equivalent I've ever been to is the Venice Biennale. The exhibits, I was not all that wowed by when I saw it. But, yes.
临时展馆，只对以后可以重新利用的东西感兴趣的想法。临时展馆，只对以后可以重新利用的东西感兴趣。问题是，当谈到这样的博览会时，我唯一去过的等同物是威尼斯双年展。我看到的时候，展品并没有让我感到惊叹。但是，是的。
Wow. Take that Venice shots fired. Now all the Venetians have to come after Roman. I'm just saying, but the pavilions were amazing. Like these buildings that were, just like the United States and Hungary and all these places had their own buildings that they would fill every two years with a new exhibit
哇。威尼斯中枪了。现在所有的威尼斯人都要来找罗曼了。我只是说，但展馆太棒了。就像美国、匈牙利和所有这些地方都有自己的建筑，他们每两年用新的展品填满它们，
related to architecture and design. And the buildings themselves were so stunning. Like this is a real like missed opportunity because you could have had an amazing set of pavilions that outlasted the fair potentially. Anyway, I love the pavilions at the Venice Biennale. I mean, yeah, someday I hope to go, someday hope to see it.
与建筑和设计有关。建筑本身非常令人惊叹。这是一个真正的错失良机，因为你本可以拥有一套令人惊叹的展馆，可能比博览会本身更长久。无论如何，我喜欢威尼斯双年展的展馆。我的意思是，是的，希望有一天能去，希望有一天能看到。
I mean, I wonder if the people of Rome are at all offended that you're going on and on about Venice and your name is literally Roman and you're not talking about them. But there are some structures left from this 64 World's Fair in that part, the Unisphere, as seen in Man in Black, the movie, like that's from there.
我的意思是，我不知道罗马人民是否会因为你一直在谈论威尼斯而感到被冒犯，你的名字叫罗曼，你却不谈论他们。但从这届64年世界博览会中确实留下了一些结构，那个“大地球仪”，正如在电影《黑衣人》中看到的那样，那是从那里来的。
But when you walk around that area, at least when I did years ago, when I still live in New York, it feels like you are in a place of ruins, like stuff that are, I mean, they've cleaned it up. The park is nicely cleaned up and there's still some things left, and there's some neat museum stuff there.
但当你走在那个区域时，至少我几年前还在纽约住的时候，感觉就像在一个废墟之地，就像那些东西，我的意思是，他们清理干净了。公园清理得很漂亮，还有一些东西留下来，那里还有一些整洁的博物馆东西。
But you do feel like the things that are left over mostly from that fair have not been, were not necessarily meant to stay and have not been kept up particularly amazingly. And we're not built with an eye towards, this will last for a long time. And the funny thing about fairs is like, I think that when it comes to these types of events,
但你确实觉得从那届博览会留下的东西大多不是为了留下来，也没有被特别好地维护。而且建造时并没有考虑到“这会持续很长时间”。关于博览会的一件有趣的事情是，我认为当谈到这些类型的活动时，
this is the type of thing where I think people in the press are kind of looking for a disaster, you know what I mean? They have this sort of, they have a little bit, there's like blood in the water and you can feel it when people aren't excited about a thing. And so the press, who has already started, he started to lose with the previous fights that we've talked about, they're really picking on him
这是那种我认为媒体正在寻找灾难的事情，你明白我的意思吗？他们有这种，他们有一点，当人们对某件事不兴奋时，你能感觉到那种“血腥味”。所以媒体，他已经开始在之前我们谈过的战斗中失败了，他们真的在挑他的刺，
during this time period. And he is just not used to this. No, and he takes the bait every time. Instead of just letting the bad press roll over him, he always gets mad and attacks them again. And this is when the press is, they're ready to go after him. Even the New York Times is criticizing his work
在这段时间里。他根本不习惯这样。不，他每次都上钩。他没有让负面新闻随风而去，而是总是生气并再次攻击他们。这就是媒体准备好对付他的时候。甚至《纽约时报》也在批评他的工作，
at this point. And they've stopped automatically printing every letter he writes them, which he's very insulted by. But he writes this, an article for the Sunday Times magazine about the press. And there's, I just just I love reading his writing So I just want to read you it extra purposes There is a notable tendency in the press to cut officials to one size and a sort of bed of pro crusties
在这一点上。他们已经停止自动刊登他写的每一封信，这让他感到非常受辱。但他为《星期日泰晤士报》杂志写了一篇关于媒体的文章。我只是，我喜欢读他的文字，所以我只想读给你听，为了额外的目的：“媒体有一种显著的倾向，把官员削减到一个尺寸，一种普罗克拉斯提斯的床，穿上带钉的鞋子和防滑钉，当受害者倒下时像暴徒一样跳上去，当一位老去的冠军被殴打和废黜时，发出如此幸灾乐祸的喊叫。还有一小群潜在的豺狼和秃鹫，在边缘徘徊，盘旋在麻烦点上，发现伤口或血液，然后靠近或俯冲下来进行杀戮。”这就像，这不会为你赢得媒体。媒体不会被这个所赢得。然后媒体就像，哦，你在攻击我？我们会攻击你。就像，这真的是一种“去你的，去你的”。所以他们通过揭露他在博览会运作方面撒谎的事情来做到这一点。特别是这个叫乔·卡恩的邮报记者，
To put on spiked shoes and cleats and to jump on victims when they are down like a mob at the fights Shouting with such glee when an aging champion is beaten up and dethroned There's also a potent minority of jackals and vultures who hang around the outskirts and hover over trouble spots to discover a wound or blood and then close in or swoop down for the kill." It's like, this is not going to win you the press. The press is not going to be won over by this. And then the press is like, oh, you're attacking me? We'll attack you. Like, it's a real, you know, oh, F me, F you. And so they do this by revealing things he's lying about about the fair's operations. Especially this post reporter named Joe Kahn,
他开始报道说，有那种他在公园里做过的“甜心供应商交易”。然后他真的开始与被宣布参与博览会的国家和组织核实，看看他们是否真的在做。我喜欢卡罗引用的这句话，
he starts reporting about how there's like sweetheart vendor deals of the types that he had done in his parks before. And then he literally starts checking with countries and organizations that have been announced as being involved in the fair to see if they're actually doing it. And I love this quote from him that that Kara has,
他说：“没有一个神志正常的人会指派我做这样的事。这花了太多时间。所以我是在做我常规任务的同时，自己一个人做的。我全是自己做的。天哪，我现在想起来了。我从来没告诉任何人我在做什么。”
he goes, nobody in his right mind would assign me to a thing like this. It took too much time. So I was doing it all on my own at the same time that I was doing my regular assignments. I was doing it all myself. God, I remember now. I never told anyone what I was doing.
一份糟糕透顶的工作。就像，他真的只是在给国家打电话，问：“你们要在世界博览会上展示什么吗？我该找谁谈谈？哦，你们不参加？谢谢。”就像给大使馆打电话。“瑞士，你们要在世界博览会上展示什么吗？你们不参加？好的，谢谢。”这样他就可以有这些关于博览会撒谎谁会参加的故事。他们宣传了所有这些参展商，实际上他们根本不会在那里展示任何东西。摩西，他有一场糟糕的新闻发布会，
A terrible, awful job. And like, he's literally just calling states and being like, are you gonna have something to World's Fair? Who do I talk to about that? Oh, you're not? Thank you. Like calling up embassies. Switzerland, are you going to have something at the World's Fair? You're not? Okay, thank you. So that he can have these stories about the fairs lying about who's going to be at the fair. They advertised all these exhibitors who are actually not going to have something there. And Moses, he has this bad press conference
他在那里对记者发火。他举办了一场与《泰晤士报》编辑的午餐会，旨在澄清事实。然后他走出了午餐会。他走出了他举办的晚宴，无论博览会发生了什么失败，媒体都会猛扑过去批评。媒体理想情况下应该支持这届博览会。他们对此有兴趣。他们希望纽约市看起来不错。
where he gets angry at the reporters. He has a luncheon with the editors of the Times that he hosts that is meant to clear the air. And then he walks out of it. He walks out of the dinner that he's hosting and just whatever's going on that could be a failing of the fair, the press pounces on criticized. And the press ideally would be supporting this fair. They have an interest in it. They want New York City to look good.
如果这届博览会有广告费要花，它会花在报纸上。但他们对摩西太生气了。他们对摩西气得发疯，准备把他拉下来。摩西对此的反应开始赶走博览会的潜在投资者。有些地方摩西不必上钩。争议开始了，他没有让它自行解决或转移它，而是直接正面迎击，一次又一次地升级事情。事情只会变得
If there's advertising dollars to be spent on this fair, it'll be spent at newspapers. But they're just so mad at Moses. They're just barking mad at Moses that they're ready to take him down. And Moses' reactions to this start turning away potential investors to the fair. There's these places where Moses does not have to take the bait. A controversy starts and instead of letting it play itself out or deflecting it, he just goes head-on at it and escalates things over and over again. Things just keep getting
越来越糟。对，对。然后博览会真的开幕了，那就是事情真正开始的时候，轮子真的开始脱落了，因为事实证明，如果你不关注博览会，没人真的想去。是的，这是一件大事。我认为有一个，好吧，问题的一部分是，在宣传博览会时，他们主要宣传了罗伯特·摩西对博览会的参与，在某种程度上。
worse and worse. Right, right. And then the fair actually launches and that's when the things really start to come, the wheels really start to come off because it turns out that if you don't pay attention to a fair, no one really wants to go to it. Yes, that's a big thing. I think there's a, well, part of the issue is that also in advertising the fair, they've mostly advertised Robert Moses' involvement in the fair to a certain extent.
就像，你知道它会很好，罗伯特·摩西在做，但这并不意味着它曾经意味着什么。对。但他们没有这届博览会的总体规划。它有点乱，有点草率。而且有一些有趣的事情。卡罗有一个很好的描述，他说：“在法拉盛草甸，两年前还是一片平坦、贫瘠、几乎没有装饰的土地，现在形成了一平方英里的过去的形式，比如非洲部落小屋的茅草复制品，里面有树屋餐厅，未来形式，比如美国馆的庞大体量，以及传统的游乐场装饰，
Like, you know it's gonna be good, Robert Moses is doing it and that doesn't mean quite what it once did. Right. But they don't have a master plan for this fair. It's kind of messy and it's kind of sloppy. And there are fun things about it. There's a nice description that Kara Hasry goes, out of the flushing meadows and expanse of flat barren, almost unadorned land not two years before, there took shape now a square mile of forms out of the past, like the thatched replicas of African tribal huts, housing tree house restaurants, of forms out of the past, like the thatched replicas of African tribal huts housing treehouse restaurants, of forms out of the future like the hulking massiveness of the United States Pavilion, and of traditional fairground adornments
比如科学馆弯曲、隐约的深色墙壁，头顶上成排摇曳的小型彩色缆车，以及散布在场地各处的白色气球，标志着黄铜栏杆的热狗摊。”他提到，这是一个可能没有挑逗纽约知识分子精致品味，但会令公众感到兴奋的场景。这可能是一个带孩子去玩的好地方，但你所知道的只是这个刻薄的人在经营它，这个刻薄、愤怒的老人。所以就像你说的，人们没有开始出现在博览会上，他们
such as the curving, looming dark walls of the Hall of Science, the little brightly colored cable cars swinging in procession overhead, and the clusters of white balloons that marked the brass rail hot dog stands, scattered throughout the grounds." And he mentions, this is a scene that may not have titillated the sophisticated taste of New York intelligentsia, but that would have thrilled the general public. Like this probably would be a fun place to take your kids, but all you know about it is this mean man is running it, this mean angry old man. And so like you're saying, people don't start showing up to the fair and they
需要我们达到一定的出勤水平。他们借了太多的钱。他们付了太多的钱，以至于博览会每天必须带来22万名付费顾客。几乎每天两年，两个季节。摩西说，我们会有很多四分之一百万人的日子。我们会有很多。但那并没有发生。开幕当天，1964年4月22日，出勤率。49,642人出现。这很糟糕。这非常糟糕。摩西说天气不好。
need us to hit a certain attendance level. They've borrowed so much money. They've paid so much money that the fair has to bring in 220,000 paying customers every day. And most every single day for two years, for two seasons. And Moses like, we'll have plenty of quarter million days. We'll have plenty of them. But that's not what happens. Attendance, attendance on the opening day is April 22nd, 1964. 49,642 people show up. Like that's bad. That's very bad. And most is like the weather was bad.
天气好转时会更好。第二天，天气好了一点。出勤率是88,130。他说，等到五月天气变暖。五月没有哪天达到那么高。等到七月学校放假。七月来了。他们仍然无法获得足够的人。而参加博览会的实际人数比他们到七月底收支平衡所需的人数少了1000万。
It'll be better when the weather clears up. The next day, weather's a little better. Attendance is 88,130. It goes, wait until May when it gets warmer. No days in May when it gets as high. Wait till July when the schools let out. July comes. They still can't get enough people. And the actual number of people that attend the fair is 10 million less than they need to have attending it to break even by the end of that July.
博览会不仅没有赚到他预期的利润。它甚至没有收支平衡。但摩西，这就是身边有唯唯诺诺的人的好处之一。有人告诉摩西博览会做得不好吗？不，他们什么都没告诉他。事实上，所以他并没有完全意识到他在财务上处于多么可怕的境地。
The fair is not just not making the profit he expected. It's not even breaking even. But Moses, here's one of the great things about having yes men all around you. Do people tell Moses that the fair is not doing well? No, they don't tell him anything about it. In fact, so he's not really fully aware of the dire straits he's in financially.
博览会不仅没有达到他预期的利润，甚至连收支平衡都做不到。但是摩西，这就是身边全是唯唯诺诺之人的好处之一。有人告诉摩西博览会经营不善吗？没有，他们什么都没告诉他。事实上，他并没有完全意识到自己正处于严重的财务困境中。
And so he ends up bringing Triborough's comptroller, Erwin Witt, to be the fair's comptroller so he can sort of get a handle on this. And one of the things about him is because he's so used to the endless stream of money pouring in as the comptroller of Tri-Burow like I don't know if he's ever balanced the books because he doesn't ever have to it seems like his job is to be Like things are going great. Mr. Moses things are going great RM Like he doesn't he doesn't seem to know how to do these things that he makes this big mistake where?
于是他最终把三区大桥管理局的财务总监欧文·威特（Erwin Witt）请来担任世博会的财务总监，这样他就能多少掌控一下局面。关于此人，有一点是，由于他作为三区大桥管理局的财务总监，早已习惯了源源不断的资金涌入，我不知道他是否曾经平衡过账目，因为他似乎从来不需要这样做，他的工作似乎就是表现得像“一切都很顺利，摩西先生，一切都很顺利”。他似乎不知道该如何处理这些事情，以至于他犯了一个大错，在哪里呢？
the fair has all these advanced ticket sales and Some of them are for the first year some are there for the second year He makes this big mistake where the fair has all these advanced ticket sales, and some of them are for the first year, some are there for the second year, but he just puts all that money and credits it to the first year of the fair, which means that for the second year of the fair, they're going to have millions and millions of, accounting-wise, unpaid attendees. So not only do they need a certain number of people, now they need even more people, because there's this gap in this money. The attendance is just not going to be high enough to cover that.
世博会有很多预售票，有些是第一年的，有些是第二年的。他犯了一个大错，世博会有很多预售票，有些是第一年的，有些是第二年的，但他只是把所有的钱都记在了世博会的第一年，这意味着对于世博会的第二年，从会计角度来看，他们将会有数以百万计的未付费入场者。所以，他们不仅需要一定数量的人，现在他们需要更多的人，因为这笔钱存在缺口。入场人数根本不足以弥补这个缺口。
And everyone's afraid of telling Moses this. The only one who'll do it is his longtime aide, George Spargo, who you may remember from the last episode, eating a bowl of soup while talking to reporters. That's right. It's really offending them that he couldn't even stop his soup for a moment. And he's been working for Moses for 30 years.
每个人都害怕告诉摩西这件事。唯一敢这么做的是他长期的助手乔治·斯帕戈（George Spargo），你可能还记得上一集里他一边吃着汤一边和记者说话。没错。他甚至连喝汤的片刻都停不下来，这真的冒犯了他们。他为摩西工作了30年。
And he even goes on double dates with Moses, which I think is a very funny detail. And Spargo tells him the truth, the fair is not making money, we're losing money, and Moses fires him. And Moses yells at Erwin with the comptroller for three hours with such ferocity that a few days later he has a heart attack
他甚至和摩西一起进行双重约会，我觉得这是一个非常有趣的细节。斯帕戈告诉他真相：世博会没有赚钱，我们在亏钱，于是摩西解雇了他。摩西对财务总监欧文大吼大叫了三个小时，凶猛异常，以至于几天后他心脏病发作了。
and eventually dies from heart trouble. So Moses has run this fair so poorly that at least one person has died as a consequence of, I don't know, the management of it. And Moses is trying, he goes, "'Okay, we gotta try to cut spending, "'we gotta save money.' "'But he signed these contracts,
并最终死于心脏病。所以摩西把这次世博会办得如此糟糕，以至于至少有一个人因为它的管理不善而死亡。摩西在努力，他说：“好吧，我们得设法削减开支，我们得省钱。”但他签署了这些合同，
"'they're just way too generous, "'they can't be renegotiated, "'the fair keeps owing money.' "'Moses tries to inflate the attendance and sales figures "'to the public to make it seem better, "'and his employees are just too scared to tell him "'really what the situation is. "'But this is real money.
“它们实在太慷慨了，无法重新谈判，世博会一直在欠钱。”摩西试图向公众夸大入场人数和销售数据，让情况看起来好一些，而他的员工太害怕了，不敢告诉他真实的情况。但这可是真金白银。
It's not play money. So there has to be a reckoning and that reckoning comes in December of that year. So there's a finance committee that has like bank presidents on it for the fair and they're like things don't seem like they're going that well with the fair. We don't really trust the books. They bring in an outside auditor who is a Chase Bank Rockefeller guy. He's a guy from that world and he discovers that rather than the surplus of 12 million dollars that Moses said they had, the fair has a deficit of 14 million dollars.
这不是儿戏。所以必须有一个清算，而这个清算在那一年的12月到来了。世博会有一个由银行行长组成的财务委员会，他们觉得世博会的情况似乎不太好。我们真的不相信这些账目。他们请来了一位外部审计师，他是大通银行洛克菲勒的人。他来自那个圈子，他发现摩西所说的1200万美元盈余根本不存在，世博会实际上有1400万美元的赤字。
So that's a 26 million dollar difference in 1964 and Moses is like, hey, you know what? Let me charm you. I'll pour on the old RM charm. That doesn't work. So then he tries to intimidate him. Hey, if you want this job, you got to stick around. And he's one of his intimidation things that I think is great is he says, you can't show up at the fair employee Christmas party, or maybe it's the tri-barrow employee Christmas party, but it's such a petty thing. And this auditor, he says, no, this fair is insolvent.
所以在1964年，这可是2600万美元的差额，摩西说，嘿，你知道吗？让我来迷住你。我要施展一下老摩西的魅力。那招不管用。于是他试图恐吓他。嘿，如果你想要这份工作，你就得留下来。他恐吓人的手段之一，我觉得很棒，他说，你不能出现在世博会员工的圣诞派对上，或者可能是三区大桥管理局的员工圣诞派对，但这太小家子气了。而这位审计师说，不，这家世博会已经资不抵债了。
And he stands by his report, he sends it to one of the bankers on the finance committee, and the bankers are aghast at how sloppy the bookkeeping is, they're aghast at Moses' attitude, and they leave the committee, and now they're publicly commenting on the fair's lack of money. And there's a lot of reporters who have been just looking
他坚持自己的报告，把它发给了财务委员会的一位银行家，银行家们对账目的草率感到震惊，对摩西的态度感到震惊，他们退出了委员会，现在他们公开评论世博会资金匮乏的问题。有很多记者一直在寻找
to get back at the guy who's been calling them jackals and vultures, and they pounce on it, saying the fair is in money trouble. That's right. Moses goes into action. That's right, so he begins to start trying to make the 1965 season better, you know, by getting a Gutenberg Bible, which would be, I would like to see that.
机会去回击那个一直称他们为豺狼和秃鹫的人，他们抓住了这个机会，说世博会陷入了资金困境。没错。摩西开始行动了。没错，所以他开始尝试让1965年的赛季变得更好，你知道，通过弄到一本古腾堡圣经，那会是，我很想看看那个。
Yeah. The Pope's coronation tiara. And Caro says he gets a lot of good stuff for the fair. But he also, my favorite thing is he loosens the restrictions they had on adult material at the fair. And it means that, so, says, no longer were he and constable screening out tawdry shows and auditioning the ones allowed in to make certain that female dancers did not display belly buttons or cleavage. In 1965, there would be nine discotecs
是的。教皇的加冕皇冠。卡罗说他为世博会弄到了很多好东西。但他还，我最喜欢的一点是，他放宽了世博会对成人内容的限制。这意味着，所以，他说，他和警官不再筛选那些低俗的表演，也不再试演那些被允许进入的节目，以确保女舞者不会露出肚脐或乳沟。在1965年，将会有九家迪斯科舞厅
featuring go-go dancers, and their bras were creeping further down nightly. In 1964, Moses had insisted that bras be put on Les Poupées de Paris, and that sexy posters be taken off the front doors of that show. In 1965, the girl taking tickets outside was spilling out of her bikini, quote, to make the show's point perfectly clear.
以戈戈舞者为特色，她们的胸罩每晚都在往下移。在1964年，摩西曾坚持要求《巴黎玩偶》（Les Poupées de Paris）里的玩偶穿上胸罩，并要求把那个节目大门上性感的海报撤掉。到了1965年，在外面收票的女孩几乎从比基尼里溢了出来，“为了让节目的重点变得非常清晰，”
Its promoter explained. And this is, Le Poupet de Paris is a kind of risque puppet show. That's what got the Croft brothers, Sid and Marty Croft, that's what made them into real big names. And they would go on to make all the Saturday morning cartoons that kids in the 70s grew up with. But he's like, before he was like, this is a class fair. It's going to be very classy. And then by 65, he's like, do the puppets have to wear bras? Like, is it possible that everyone can be in bikinis?
她的推广人解释道。这就是，《巴黎玩偶》是一种有点风险的木偶戏。这就是让克罗夫特兄弟（Sid and Marty Croft）成名的地方。他们后来制作了所有70年代孩子们长大的周六早间动画片。但他之前就像是，这是一个高雅的世博会。它会非常高雅。然后到了65年，他就像是，木偶一定要穿胸罩吗？每个人都穿比基尼行不行？
And what's getting clear here is that, you know, people are starting to get nervous about this. The lack of attendance is not just a story of failure to be what it in the papers. People have invested in this, and they're starting to cotton onto the idea that they are not going to get their money back. And that's when things really, the wheels really come off,
这里变得很清楚的是，你知道，人们开始对此感到紧张。入场人数不足不仅仅是报纸上报道的失败故事。人们已经投资了，他们开始意识到他们拿不回自己的钱了。就在那时，事情真的，轮子真的掉了，
because when the money people don't want Moses around, he has to begin hiding more, he has to sort of figure out ways to sort of convince them that he's the right person for the job. And at this point, they kind of want his head. He is facing accountability in a way that he has never ever really faced before in one of these organizations
因为当金主们不想要摩西在场时，他必须开始更多地隐藏，他必须想办法说服他们他是这份工作的合适人选。而此时，他们有点想要他的命。他正面临着一种他以前在这些组织中从未真正面对过的问责，
because his power is built on those two pillars mainly of, or three pillars, let's say, of popularity with the public, money that he can spread around, and the fact that he can write the laws. So he kind of knows the ins and outs and details of laws in the way that nobody else does. But in this case, he's not very popular anymore. He doesn't have that money to spread around, and there's no... It's a lawless land, World's Fairs.
因为他的权力主要建立在那两大支柱上，或者说是三大支柱，即公众的欢迎度、他可以散布的资金，以及他可以制定法律的事实。所以他有点了解法律的来龙去脉和细节，这是其他人所不具备的。但在这种情况下，他不再那么受欢迎了。他没有钱可以散布，而且……这是一个无法无天的地带，世博会。
You know, there's no like hidden legislation he can use to get his way. And it means that by a certain point, people are getting the feeling that he is hiding money and maybe even stealing money because they find out about how big his salary is. He's making like $100,000 a year doing this, I think more than that. And that was part of the attraction was he needs money to support his family and this will pay him money. But there's this feeling that the fair is losing money, the city is losing money, the city is losing money, the investors are losing money, and Moses is not. And for the first time, people start to think of him as greedy.
你知道，没有那种他可以用来达到目的的隐藏立法。这意味着到了一定程度，人们开始觉得他在藏钱，甚至可能在偷钱，因为他们发现了他的薪水有多高。我想他做这个一年赚10万美元，甚至更多。而这也是吸引力的一部分，他需要钱来养家糊口，这会付给他钱。但有一种感觉是，世博会在亏钱，城市在亏钱，城市在亏钱，投资者在亏钱，而摩西没有。这是第一次，人们开始认为他很贪婪。
They start to think that, oh, Moses is not the guy who doesn't care about money. This is the guy who does want money, something that nobody had ever thought about him before. And that's really bad for him. And at this point, people are suggesting that maybe he should resign. The thing that was always such a terrifying prospect when he brought it up is now something that they're suggesting. Kara says, for years he had been threatening to resign from one post or another, confident that no one would take him up on the threat. Now people were asking him to resign. And remember, by this point, it's after he has resigned
他们开始认为，哦，摩西不是那个不在乎钱的人。这家伙确实想要钱，这是以前没人想过的事情。这对他是非常不利的。此时，人们建议他也许应该辞职。那个曾经被他提起时如此可怕的前景，现在成了他们建议的事情。卡罗说，多年来他一直威胁要辞去这个或那个职位，确信没有人会真的让他兑现威胁。现在人们在要求他辞职。记住，到这个时候，是在他辞职之后
from the state posts to no reaction whatsoever for most of the public. So he's gone all the way around now to the guy who, the very thought of him resigning makes people shiver to people saying like, he should leave. Like we shouldn't have him doing this anymore. Yeah, and it's clear like he doesn't really wanna be doing it either, but he just can't resign
从州政府职位辞职，但公众几乎没有任何反应。所以他现在已经完全转变成了一个人，那个曾经让人一想到他辞职就发抖的人，现在变成了人们说，他应该离开。就像我们不应该再让他做这件事了。是的，很明显他自己也不想做，但他就是不能辞职，
just for the sake of, I think, his ego at this point. And he also probably needs to hold on to what little he can so that he is not completely blamed for everything. You know, like, there's a chance, because the IRS enters the scene to audit the fair. The audit never actually goes through, but I think there's a real worry that they will find some illegal stuff in there if he's not in control of things, be able to sort of like guide this investigation.
我想此时仅仅是为了他的自尊心。而且他可能还需要紧紧抓住他所能抓住的一点点东西，这样他就不会被完全归咎于所有事情。你知道，比如，有一个机会，因为国税局介入了对世博会的审计。审计实际上从未完成，但我认为有一个真正的担忧，如果他不控制局面，他们会发现里面有一些非法的东西，无法引导这次调查。
Yeah, and he doesn't wanna leave in disgrace. He always wants to seem like he's leaving in triumph. So he does look for other jobs. There's one point where he's like, hey, I hear you might wanna build a canal in Columbia because the Panama Canal is gonna be handed back to Panama. Like, I could do that, I could do that. And when people vote to try to remove him on the board,
是的，他不想在耻辱中离开。他总是想看起来像是凯旋而归。所以他确实在寻找其他工作。有一次他说，嘿，我听说你们可能想在哥伦比亚建一条运河，因为巴拿马运河要归还给巴拿马了。比如，我可以做那个，我可以做那个。当人们投票试图在董事会上罢免他时，
he has his blackmail files that he can use to sway people into supporting him. Like, he still has power over this turf and he doesn't wanna let go of it unless either it looks like he's doing it voluntarily just because he wants to, or unless it's gonna lead him to something more powerful. And he even tries to find ways to use the Triborough money
他有他的勒索档案，他可以用这些档案来左右人们支持他。比如，他仍然对这块地盘有权力，他不想放手，除非看起来像是他自愿这么做的，仅仅因为他想这么做，或者除非这能引导他走向更强大的位置。他甚至试图寻找方法利用三区大桥管理局的钱
to prop up the fair at a certain point. But there's no way to get out of it. The fair is a bust. He can't pay back the city the money that it borrowed. Robert Moses Park is just not gonna happen. This is the worst thing he could be, according to Robert Caro, is he's just like Grover Whelan, the president of the 39 World's Fair.
在某个时候支撑世博会。但没有办法摆脱它。世博会是个烂摊子。他无法偿还城市借出的钱。罗伯特·摩西公园根本不会实现。根据罗伯特·卡罗的说法，这是他能成为的最糟糕的人，他就像1939年世博会主席格罗弗·惠伦（Grover Whelan）。
And they can't even pay to tear down the buildings when the fair is done. When they're done, which would leave him his park to make, which he can't. I mean, he can't even, he can't clear the land, he can't, doesn't have the money to build it up, he didn't create any of that surplus. There are like a couple of like,
当世博会结束时，他们甚至付不起拆除建筑的费用。当他们完成时，这本该留下他的公园让他建造，但他做不到。我的意思是，他甚至不能，他不能清理土地，他不能，没有钱去建设它，他没有创造任何盈余。有几个，
as the fair is winding down, there are a couple of those, you know, two 20 plus days. They start having 500,000 persons. It's like as the fair is ending, the press is like, oh, by the way, the fair's ending. And people start going like, oh, I wanted to see that. And so by the end of the fair,
随着世博会接近尾声，有几个，你知道，两天超过20天。他们开始有50万人次。就像世博会快结束时，媒体说，哦，顺便说一下，世博会要结束了。人们开始说，哦，我想去看看。所以到世博会结束时，
they actually have money on hand. They have some money and they get those big attendance days and it shows you that this would have been possible. Like a different fare potentially, a different way of relating to the press and selling it might have brought in, I still don't know if it would have made any money, but it would have been quite as big a disaster.
他们手头确实有钱。他们有一些钱，他们得到了那些高入场人数的日子，这向你表明这本来是可能的。就像一个不同的世博会，一种与媒体联系和销售它的不同方式可能已经带来了，我仍然不知道它是否会赚到任何钱，但它不会像现在这样是一场巨大的灾难。
And he has this money on hand and he goes, you know what, I'm not gonna pay back any of the investors with it. I'm gonna spend that money on my new park. And the courts are like, you have to at least give some of that money to the investors. You can't all just go to this park dream that you have.
他手头有这笔钱，他说，你知道吗，我不会用它偿还任何投资者。我要把那笔钱花在我的新公园上。法院说，你至少得把一部分钱给投资者。你不能全部都投入到你那个公园梦里。
And he ends up giving them back, it's like, you know, 30 cents on the dollar or something, roughly the same return on investment the 39 fair had given back in 1939. And the rest goes to just cleaning up the site and making it usable for the public. And some of those structures, like I said, are still there. And Moses makes a big deal about it
他最终还给他们，大概是，你知道，30美分对1美元左右，大致和1939年世博会的回报率相同。剩下的钱用于清理场地，使其对公众可用。正如我所说，其中一些结构仍然存在。摩西对此大做文章，
as if this was a huge victory. How, look, we have this beautiful park. This used to be an ash dump. Look, we did it, you know, but it's far from this lavish dream that he had of this park that would make Queens the showpiece of the world. Yeah, and Carrow, he totals up the public money spent by Robert Moses in preparing the site
好像这是一场巨大的胜利。看，我们有这个美丽的公园。这曾经是一个垃圾场。看，我们做到了，你知道，但这远非他梦想中那个会让皇后区成为世界展示品的奢华公园。是的，卡罗，他统计了罗伯特·摩西在准备场地时花费的公共资金
for the 39 and the 64 fairs. And it comes up to about $140 million. And that's so much money to consider. Remember that whole West side improvement that was like $90 million. And it was, and it did everything it was supposed to do. And it like, people use it. This is, it's just supposed to, dreams are expensive. And, um, and there's no notion that this spot in Flushing Meadows should be named after him. This is the end of him being revered in this way. Yes. And Carol, he says, Moses ran this fair at the same way he kind of ran his other projects, but this time he couldn't hide his methods. He couldn't, he had to do it out in the open
用于39年和64年的世博会。总额约为1.4亿美元。这笔钱太值得考虑了。记住那个整个西区改善工程，大约是9000万美元。而且它，它完成了它应该做的一切。而且它，人们使用它。这，它只是应该，梦想是昂贵的。而且，嗯，没有任何理由说法拉盛草原的这个地方应该以他的名字命名。这是他不再以这种方式受到崇敬的终点。是的。卡罗说，摩西经营这次世博会的方式和他经营其他项目的方式一样，但这一次他无法隐藏他的方法。他无法，他必须在公开场合这样做，
because this was a kind of a corporation with investors as opposed to a semi-private, semi-public authority or an official institution. And because of that salary he had, he's just not seen anymore as the guy who doesn't care about money. And Caro says, he was in public disrepute so great that his name had become a symbol
因为这是一种有投资者的公司，而不是半私有、半公共的机构或官方机构。而且因为他那份薪水，他不再被视为那个不在乎钱的人。卡罗说，他处于如此巨大的公众声誉扫地之中，以至于他的名字已经成为了
for things the public hated. Like he is no longer Parks. He is now greed and being mean to people. And Carr says if he were an elected official, he'd be voted out of office. If he was a political appointee, he would be fired by that elected official. But he's still the head of Triborough. He's still the head of a public authority and nobody can remove him at all. It just can't be done. And the chapter ends on a kind of a, every now and then Robert Carroll will be like, oh yeah, and here's something about Robert Moses' family, just to keep you up to do that. And he basically just ends the chapter with a semi unrelated, but chronological kind of description of what's going on with Mary Moses, Robert Moses' wife, who, as you know, in earlier
公众所憎恨事物的象征。就像他不再是公园。他现在是贪婪和对人刻薄。卡罗说，如果他是一名民选官员，他会被投票赶下台。如果他是一名政治任命人员，他会被那位民选官员解雇。但他仍然是三区大桥管理局的负责人。他仍然是一个公共机构的负责人，没有人能罢免他。这根本做不到。这一章以一种，每隔一段时间罗伯特·卡罗就会说，哦对了，这是关于罗伯特·摩西家庭的一些事情，只是为了让你跟上进度。他基本上只是以一种半无关，但按时间顺序描述玛丽·摩西（罗伯特·摩西的妻子）正在发生的事情来结束这一章，正如你所知，在早期的
chapters, she was so necessary to his life. She was the one who kept the day-to-day of his life going so that he could do these big things. And she has deteriorated so much. And by her early 60s, she's having recurring hospitalizations, and she's confined to a wheelchair. And his daughter, Jane, takes up those responsibilities. And Robert Moses seems to start a relationship with someone who people around him call Mary too, whose name is Mary Grady, or maybe it's Mary the second,
章节中，她对他的人生是如此必要。她是那个维持他日常生活的人，这样他才能做这些大事。而她已经恶化得太多了。到了60岁出头，她反复住院，并被限制在轮椅上。他的女儿简承担了这些责任。而罗伯特·摩西似乎开始与一个被身边人称为“玛丽二世”的人建立关系，她的名字是玛丽·格雷迪（Mary Grady），或者可能是玛丽二世，
a secretary who's 28 years younger than Robert Moses, and she starts going with him to parties and vacations. And Moses always kind of courteous, always financially supports his first wife, but they just do not share a life anymore. And their friends believe that Mary's decline began when Moses began facing real public criticism, that she would get so enraged by the criticism and it would kind of burn her out. And she dies in 1966, the year after the fair is over.
一个比罗伯特·摩西小28岁的秘书，她开始陪他去参加派对和度假。摩西总是很客气，总是经济上支持他的第一任妻子，但他们只是不再共享生活了。他们的朋友认为玛丽的衰落始于摩西开始面临真正的公众批评时，她会对这些批评感到非常愤怒，这会让她精疲力竭。她在1966年去世，也就是世博会结束后的第二年。
And less than a month later, Moses, he's 77 years old, and he marries Mary too, Mary Grady, who is 49 years old. So this chapter is such a huge closing of an era for Robert Moses and that his power is so greatly diminished, his reputation is so greatly diminished, and even the woman who made so much of that power possible by allowing his life to proceed that way and by taking care of him is no longer a part of that life.
不到一个月后，摩西，他77岁了，他娶了玛丽二世，玛丽·格雷迪，她49岁。所以这一章是罗伯特·摩西一个时代的巨大终结，他的权力大大减弱，他的声誉大大减弱，甚至那个通过允许他的生活以那种方式进行并照顾他而使这种权力成为可能的女人，也不再是那个生活的一部分了。
She's passed on, you know. And when the book was released and Robert Moses reacted to it by calling Robert Caro a venomous viper, among other things. Which is a little redundant. I would say so. But it does sound like him, you know what I mean?
她去世了，你知道。当这本书出版时，罗伯特·摩西通过称罗伯特·卡罗为毒蛇等来做出反应。这有点多余。我会这么说。但这听起来确实像他，你知道我的意思吗？
Like that's his style of writing. But the first and most vociferous reaction and complaint that he has in this sort of 20 page letter that he releases publicly is about this. Like he takes extreme offense to the notion that he was carrying on a relationship with Mary Grady while Mary the first was still alive. So this is one thing that he greatly disputes,
就像那是他的写作风格。但他在这封他公开发布的20页信件中，第一个也是最激烈的反应和抱怨是关于这个的。就像他极度反感他还在与玛丽一世生活时就与玛丽·格雷迪保持关系的说法。所以这是他极力反驳的一件事，
he took great offense to this. It really is the thing that he leads with and just sort of sticks with through most of the piece. Like the little bits that he complains about, like, oh, this car wasn't worth that much money and that boat wasn't real, that was like a bathtub, it wasn't really an expensive boat or whatever he says. This is the one where you can feel like there's a real,
他对此感到非常冒犯。这确实是他开头提到的事情，并且在文章的大部分内容中都坚持这一点。就像他抱怨的小部分，比如，哦，这辆车不值那么多钱，那艘船不是真的，那就像个浴缸，那不是什么昂贵的船之类的。这是你能感觉到有真正，
I don't know, like just, you know, he could be really mad because Robert Caro is mischaracterizing this. He could be really mad because he's onto something and it's very sensitive. I don't know, but this was, of those 1,200 pages, this seemed to be the thing that Robert Moses objected to the most.
我不知道，就像，你知道，他可能会非常生气，因为罗伯特·卡罗在歪曲事实。他可能会非常生气，因为他发现了什么，而且这非常敏感。我不知道，但在那1200页中，这似乎是罗伯特·摩西最反对的事情。
Yes, and yet there's no real way of knowing exactly whether it's because it's not true or because this is the thing that is most likely to hurt his family, you know, and the other stuff won't. But it's hard when, so much of Moses' attacks and things like that are based on misrepresentation. It's hard to know what the true truth is. And it's not that hard to believe that a powerful guy
是的，然而没有真正的方法知道这究竟是因为它不是真的，还是因为这是最有可能伤害他家人的事情，你知道，而其他事情不会。但很难，当摩西的攻击和类似的事情大多基于歪曲事实时。很难知道真正的真相是什么。而且相信一个有权势的人
would be unfaithful to his wife. You know, it's not a, it would not be an out of the ordinary situation for a big, powerful person. But you're right, there is something about this that particularly offends him and insults him, and that he has to push back on. Because you could take that month between her death and his new marriage two ways.
会对妻子不忠并不难。你知道，这不是一个，对于一个大人物、有权势的人来说，这不会是一个不寻常的情况。但你是对的，关于这件事有一些特别冒犯和侮辱他的地方，他必须反击。因为你可以从两个方面看待她去世和他再婚之间那一个月。
One is that's extremely insensitive, and she just died, and he should have more time. The other is he's 77 years old. Yeah, come on. He doesn't even know what time he has left. And if they weren't having a relationship for something 10 plus years at this Yeah, come on. He doesn't know what time he has lived. And if they weren't having a relationship for something 10 plus years at this point, like you just gotta live life.
一个是那极其不敏感，她刚去世，他应该有更多时间。另一个是他77岁了。是的，得了吧。他甚至不知道他还剩下多少时间。如果他们没有保持关系10多年了，在这个时候，就像你必须过生活。
So there's all kinds of ways to take this, but he took real exception to the characterization that Robert Carrow wrote in this section for sure. Maybe it shows, and maybe I'm reaching too far for a unified theory of Roman and Moses reactions, but I think it shows what a different place we are in in terms of public mores now, that the public activities that Moses is taking
所以有很多种看待方式，但他确实对罗伯特·卡罗在这一节中写的描述表示了极大的异议。也许它显示了，也许我在为罗伯特·摩西的反应寻找一个统一理论，但我认为它显示了我们在公共道德方面处于一个多么不同的位置，摩西正在采取的公共活动
and how he pushes people around, we take such horrific offense at, whereas his personal relationships feel like they are not a thing that is as important to go into or talk about, whereas at the time, I think it would have been very different. It would have been, well, you gotta break a few eggs
以及他如何推搡别人，我们感到如此可怕的冒犯，而他的个人关系感觉不像是一个需要深入探讨或谈论的事情，而在当时，我认为情况会非常不同。那会是，好吧，你得打破几个鸡蛋
to make some omelets. Whereas the idea that he was not faithful to his wife would have been very damaging, most likely. And so I wonder if it's a show of like, he's a man from, remember, Robert Moses was born over 100 years ago. Like he's a man from a different time. A time when driving was just a pleasant leisure activity. You took on a Sunday down a tree-lined boulevard,
才能做煎蛋卷。而他对他妻子不忠的想法很可能会造成极大的破坏。所以我怀疑这是否是一种展示，他是一个来自，记住，罗伯特·摩西出生于100多年前。他是一个来自不同时代的人。一个开车只是一种愉快的休闲活动的时代。你在周日沿着绿树成荫的大道行驶，
you know. So the things that struck him as hurtful were different than probably what we would find now in the same way. That's right. But lest you think that he's really at the end of his rope, the next chapter will show you that there's a little fight left in this old dog. That's chapter 48, old lion, young mare. We'll talk about that one after this. So next chapter is chapter 48, old lion, young mare. Who is the young mare that we're talking about here? The young mare here is John Lindsay.
你知道。所以那些让他感到受伤的事情与我们现在可能发现的不同，以同样的方式。没错。但为了不让你认为他真的走投无路了，下一章会向你展示这只老狗还有一点战斗力。那是第48章，老狮子，小母马。我们会在那之后谈谈那个。所以下一章是第48章，老狮子，小母马。我们在这里谈论的小母马是谁？这里的小母马是约翰·林赛（John Lindsay）。
He was the mayor after Wagner. And the thing I just want to highlight here is how hard Caro disrespects John Lindsay throughout this chapter and the remainder of the book. It's very funny to me. John Lindsay, he's not well remembered for most people now, but at the time he was the young, handsome, liberal Republican mayor. He's not well remembered for most people now, but at the time he was the young, handsome, liberal Republican mayor.
他是瓦格纳之后的市长。我想在这里强调的是卡罗在这一章和本书的其余部分中对约翰·林赛是多么的不尊重。这对我来说非常有趣。约翰·林赛，现在大多数人对他记忆不深，但在当时，他是年轻、英俊、自由派的共和党市长。
He's very handsome. Very handsome. I mean, he was an actor before he was a mayor who went into politics. They'll often say stuff like the striking countenance of Robert Moses and you go, I don't know, what kind of great not a curve here? But you look at John Lindsay, John Lindsay is as handsome as a modern politician,
他非常英俊。非常英俊。我的意思是，他在成为市长之前是一名演员，后来进入了政界。他们经常会说像罗伯特·摩西那惊人的容貌之类的话，你会想，我不知道，这里有什么伟大的曲线吗？但你看看约翰·林赛，约翰·林赛像现代政治家一样英俊，
like a real square jaw, you know, like, yeah. He's got a real Robert Redford type look to him, you know, and he came into New York City saying, this is now, we're gonna make this a modern city, and we're gonna make it, they called it Fun City. This is gonna be a city that people enjoy being in. And it's hard to read parts of this chapter now and not feel some kind of modern parallels of a relatively like a liberal reformer type coming in and being like, well, I know I'm
就像一个真正的方下巴，你知道，就像，是的。他有一种真正的罗伯特·雷德福（Robert Redford）式的外表，你知道，他来到纽约市说，这是现在，我们要把它变成一个现代城市，我们要把它，他们称之为“乐趣之城”（Fun City）。这将是一个人们喜欢居住的城市。现在读这一章的部分内容，很难不感受到某种现代的相似之处，一个相对像自由派改革者类型的人进来，就像，好吧，我知道我是
right and they're wrong. So obviously I will win. And then being crushed repeatedly by the old dinosaurs that still have power and know how the system works. There's a book I read years ago called The Ungovernable City about John Lindsay's term as mayor where it's a little bit fairer to him. It still doesn't say he did a good job,
对的，他们是错的。所以显然我会赢。然后被仍然拥有权力并知道系统如何运作的老恐龙反复碾压。我多年前读过一本书叫《无法治理的城市》（The Ungovernable City），关于约翰·林赛的市长任期，那本书对他稍微公平一点。它仍然没有说他做得很好，
but it's a little fairer with the things he was dealing with. But Caro is just, you can tell, Caro is writing about current events, for the most part, in this chapter, because he is writing without a sense of distance. And these events would have happened while he was writing this book, while he was working on it. This is less than 10 years before the book comes out.
但对于他正在处理的事情，它稍微公平一点。但卡罗只是，你可以看出，卡罗在这一章中主要是在写时事，因为他在写作时没有距离感。这些事件发生在他写这本书的时候，当他在研究它的时候。这距离书出版不到10年。
Within the decade, yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly. Yeah, and so you just feel, there's just this feel of, this guy has no idea what he's doing. Like what, and probably that feeling of, I like the things this guy stands for, but he has no idea what he's doing, and he's gonna wreck it. He's not gonna be able to do this.
十年之内，是的，是的，是的，完全正确。是的，所以你只是感觉到，有一种感觉，这家伙根本不知道自己在做什么。就像什么，可能那种感觉，我喜欢这家伙所代表的东西，但他不知道自己在做什么，他会毁了它。他做不到这一点。
There's just such a, it's very funny to me. We've talked in the past, I think I mentioned in the past about there are points in this book that remind me of the book Eminent Victorians, which is like a satirical book in a way about, it's like a burn book about Victorian society. And there are parts in this chapter
这对我来说非常有趣。我们过去谈过，我想我过去提到过，这本书中有一些地方让我想起《维多利亚名人传》（Eminent Victorians），那是一本关于维多利亚时代讽刺性的书，就像一本关于维多利亚社会的烧书。这一章里有一些部分
where it feels like that, where Carol's just like, can you believe this, like, come on Carol's just like, can you believe this? Come on, guy, like what are you doing? And it just what a dilettante, he thinks, Mayor Lindsay is. But Lindsay and his team are kind of the young hot shots. They think they have, you know, they get elected, they think they have control, they think they know how to like, they can push aside all these old people. They believe the stuff that textbooks tell you, which is you elect the mayor and the mayor governs the city, which is you elect the mayor and the mayor governs the city,
感觉就像那样，卡罗就像，你能相信这个吗，就像，得了吧，卡罗就像，你能相信这个吗？得了吧，伙计，就像你在做什么？他认为林赛市长是一个多么业余的人。但林赛和他的团队是那种年轻的热门人物。他们认为他们有，你知道，他们当选了，他们认为他们有控制权，他们认为他们知道如何，他们可以推开所有这些老人。他们相信教科书告诉你的东西，那就是你选举市长，市长治理城市，
which is not necessarily the case. But they're like, he's the mayor, he's in control, he has the power, he can do whatever he thinks is necessary. And Kara talks about how Robert Moses is like, great, he can say that, I know different. I know who really has power in this relationship. Right, and after the string of mayors between LaGuardia and him,
这不一定是真的。但他们就像，他是市长，他在控制之中，他有权力，他可以做任何他认为必要的事情。卡罗谈到罗伯特·摩西就像是，太好了，他可以这么说，我知道不同。我知道谁在这一关系中真正拥有权力。没错，在拉瓜迪亚（LaGuardia）和他之间的那一连串市长之后，
who don't merit full chapters in the book. He kind of thinks like, I'm the one who would merit a chapter in The Power Broker that he doesn't know exists, but he fashions himself as, or sort of fancies himself as the new LaGuardia. Like he takes LaGuardia's picture out of the main rotunda and puts it into his office, takes his desk or something like that? Like he's LaGuardia's picture out of the main rotunda and puts it into his office, takes his desk or something like that?
他们不值得在书中占满整章。他有点认为，我是那个值得在《权力掮客》（The Power Broker）中占一章的人，但他不知道它的存在，但他把自己塑造成，或者说把自己想象成新的拉瓜迪亚。就像他把拉瓜迪亚的照片从主大厅拿出来放进他的办公室，拿走他的桌子之类的？
Like he's really trying- He takes a LaGuardia desk and then, and Caro uses it as a metaphor where reporters are so eager to take a picture of Lindsay that they climb on top of the desk and it collapses and shatters. Like under the weight of his own publicity, you know, his LaGuardia dreams are breaking.
就像他真的在尝试——他拿了一张拉瓜迪亚的桌子，然后，卡罗把它用作一个隐喻，记者们非常渴望给林赛拍照，以至于他们爬到桌子上，桌子倒塌并破碎了。就像在他自己宣传的重压下，你知道，他的拉瓜迪亚梦想正在破灭。
And the way that Caro talks about him is like he's like a child. And he wants to do the things that Caro has been arguing for throughout the book. He wants to use the tribal authority surplus and use it to improve the subways and mass transit. He wants to raise tolls to disincentivize cars in the cities. But he seems so ignorant to Caro about how to do these things. And Caro says, the ignorance of some of these men concerning the true nature and powers of public authorities would have been ludicrous if it had not been the city's future that that ignorance was jeopardizing. Like I think
卡罗谈论他的方式就像他是个孩子。他想做卡罗在整本书中一直主张的事情。他想利用三区大桥管理局的盈余，并将其用于改善地铁和公共交通。他想提高通行费以抑制城市里的汽车。但他对卡罗来说似乎非常无知，不知道如何做这些事情。卡罗说，这些人对公共机构的本质和权力的无知，如果不是因为这种无知正在危及城市的未来，那将是荒谬的。就像我认为
then maybe that's what makes them really mad is the idea like this is the opportunity. Moses is on the ropes. A tough mayor, a mayor who understood the system could maybe push him out for good or get something out of it. But instead this baby face comes in. I mean, a baby face is just a hero, but this guy who's, this newbie, you know, comes in and gets totally owned by the Moses who has been self-owning himself for the past couple chapters.
那么也许这就是让他们真正生气的原因，这种想法就像这是机会。摩西处于困境中。一位强硬的市长，一位了解系统的市长可能可以永远把他赶走或从中得到一些东西。但相反，这个娃娃脸进来了。我的意思是，娃娃脸只是一个英雄，但这个家伙，这个新手，你知道，进来了，被摩西完全拥有了，而摩西在过去几章里一直在自我拥有。
That's right. And one of the big things that he wants to do, and you mentioned this, but it's like, this is really notable, is this whole thing where, I don't know, many chapters ago, I can't even remember, was to take the surplus from Triborough, feed that into the subway system. You treat this as one big dynamic design system
没错。他想做的重要事情之一，你提到了这一点，但这就像，这真的很值得注意，是整个事情，我不知道，很多章以前，我甚至不记得了，是把三区大桥管理局的盈余拿出来，投入到地铁系统中。你把这当作一个巨大的动态设计系统来对待，
that includes cars and bridges and subways and light rail and treats them as one thing, merging it into this new MTA. This is really what the city needed decades and decades ago. And this is a fight worth having. And Lindsay just thinks that this is like, he could just do it. And this is where this idea of like what,
包括汽车、桥梁、地铁和轻轨，并将它们视为一件事，合并成这个新的MTA。这确实是城市几十年前所需要的。这是一场值得进行的战斗。而林赛只是认为这就像，他可以做到。这就是这个想法，关于什么是
what the tribal authority is and what these bond covenants are all about. Like that there is a, there is a, what the tribal authority is and what these bond covenants are all about. Like that there is a, the tribal authority sells bonds, the public owns those bonds, they control the money and get money back in these certain ways.
三区大桥管理局，以及这些债券契约到底是什么。就像有一个，三区大桥管理局出售债券，公众拥有这些债券，他们控制资金并以这些特定方式收回资金。
And the city government cannot get between that transaction legally. It is the most basic constitutional law going back at that point, what, like 120 years, 178 years? It's either, I don't remember whether if it's McCullough versus Maryland, I don't remember what thing establishes contracts or whatever, but that a contract is legally binding and cannot be interrupted by the government.
而市政府在法律上无法介入该交易。这是最基本的宪法法律，追溯到那时，什么，比如120年，178年？我不记得是麦卡洛克诉马里兰州案（McCullough versus Maryland），我不记得是什么确立了合同之类的，但合同具有法律约束力，不能被政府中断。
And so Lindsay is like, we're going to merge Triborough and the Trans Authority. We're going to use the Triborough money to bail out the subways. And Moses is like, uh-uh, I wrote the law. It says in these sacred bondholder covenants that I wrote like a magic spell into the bonds to make them inviolable, that that money has to go to paying off the bondholders. It cannot go to anything else And he also does a song and dance about how you know only Tarboro has the money and the staff to do these big projects So maybe I just won't do them and maybe the city will lose out all this power Yeah, it's classic classic stuff classic Moses move. He's still got it. He's still doing it and Robert Carroll points out that Lindsay could have cut most his power a little bit by removing him from the arterial representative post.
所以林赛就像，我们要合并三区大桥管理局和交通管理局。我们要用三区大桥管理局的钱来救助地铁。而摩西就像，呃-呃，法律是我写的。它在这些神圣的债券持有人契约中写着，我像魔法咒语一样写进债券里，使它们不可侵犯，那笔钱必须用于偿还债券持有人。它不能用于任何其他事情。而且他还唱了一出戏，关于你知道，只有三区大桥管理局有钱和员工来做这些大项目，所以也许我只是不做它们，也许城市会失去所有这些权力。是的，这是经典的经典东西，经典的摩西举动。他仍然拥有它。他仍然在做，罗伯特·卡罗指出，林赛本可以通过将他从动脉代表职位上撤下来，稍微削减摩西的权力。
It's an informal post. All he has to do is send him a letter saying, I don't want you to do this anymore. And he would not have anymore. But the Lindsay administration does not really understand the power that comes from that and how the two reinforce each other. And they think only the Triborough post matters. So they're so focused on this. And they're like, we can do it.
这是一个非正式职位。他所要做的就是给他发一封信，说，我不想让你再做这个了。他就不会再有了。但林赛政府并不真正理解由此产生的权力以及两者如何相互加强。他们认为只有三区大桥管理局的职位才重要。所以他们如此专注于此。他们就像，我们可以做到。
We're going to get rid of him. Lindsay sends his transportation aid, Arthur E. Palmer, not as great a name as some of the other ones, but I like that he is the middle initial E. He goes, Moses, you're gonna resign. And Moses responds with a series of lectures about how powerful he is. And Carol talks about this slow dawning on Palmer was like, oh, this is not the situation that we thought it was gonna be. And so Lindsay is like, well, okay, we can't fire you, but we'll leave the surpluses alone if you drop your opposition to this merger
我们要摆脱他。林赛派出了他的交通助理亚瑟·E·帕尔默（Arthur E. Palmer），名字没有其他一些那么好，但我喜欢他是中间名E。他说，摩西，你要辞职。摩西回应了一系列关于他有多强大的讲座。卡罗谈到帕尔默身上那种缓慢的觉醒，就像，哦，这不是我们认为会是的情况。所以林赛就像，好吧，我们可以不解雇你，但如果你放弃对这次合并的反对，我们会让盈余保持原样
between Tribor and the Trans Authority. And Moses is like, that's the emptiest of threats. You can't do, you have to leave them alone. Like, it doesn't matter what I do, I can do whatever I want. He has all the power, and he thinks the Lindsay people are so dumb he just thinks they're such idiots for taking this long to realize where the power actually lies and
在三区大桥管理局和交通管理局之间。而摩西就像，那是空洞的威胁。你不能做，你必须让它们保持原样。就像，我做什么并不重要，我可以做任何我想做的事。他拥有所有的权力，他认为林赛的人太蠢了，他只是认为他们是白痴，花了这么长时间才意识到权力实际上在哪里，以及
Ultimately Moses like I'll tell you what we'll merge them together. We'll make a new transportation authority I will run it take it or leave it. That's the only option on the table and Lindsay is Doesn't is not gonna take that option. They don't want to give Moses more power. He's a dinosaur, they wanna get rid of him. They just can't seem to figure out how to, and maybe it's partly the way that Kara was presenting it, I don't know, but it does seem like a group of children trying to knock down a professional wrestler and just not seem to realize that he weighs three times
最终摩西就像，我告诉你，我们会把它们合并在一起。我们会建立一个新的交通管理局，我来管理它，要么接受，要么离开。这是桌面上唯一的选择。而林赛是不打算接受那个选择的。他们不想给摩西更多的权力。他是个恐龙，他们想摆脱他。他们似乎就是想不出怎么做，也许部分原因是卡罗呈现它的方式，我不知道，但这看起来确实像一群孩子试图击倒一个职业摔跤手，却似乎没有意识到他比
all of them put together and they just can't, they're not gonna be able to do it. And so this all comes to a head in Albany, where they sort of make these cases to Governor Rockefeller. And what's clear is when these young punks come in and try to present their case, they're just so outmatched because not only is there Robert Moses there to sort of, to give his side,
他们所有人加起来还要重，他们就是做不到。所以这一切在奥尔巴尼达到了高潮，他们在那里向洛克菲勒州长陈述了这些案件。很明显，当这些年轻的混混进来试图陈述他们的案件时，他们完全被压倒了，因为不仅有罗伯特·摩西在那里，以某种方式，给出他的一面，
former governors are there to like on Moses' side. Everyone is basically on Moses' side. Everyone's there. And it's such a classic trap because the people in Albany are like, Lindsay, why don't you come up and have a casual discussion with us about this bill, about merging the stuff, because it needs state approval anyway.
前任州长们都在那里，就像是站在摩西这一边。基本上每个人都站在摩西这一边。每个人都在那儿。这是一个非常经典的陷阱，因为奥尔巴尼的人会说，林赛，你为什么不来和我们随便讨论一下这个法案，关于合并这些东西，因为无论如何它都需要州政府的批准。
And he goes, yeah, and he has these guys go up, and then they just see the list of speakers when they get there, that are scheduled for the date, and it's like, yeah, Moses, Dewey, Wagner, like all these major players who are gonna testify, and Caro takes such, he takes a couple of pages, he really goes into great depth, just luxuriating in the moment
于是他去了，是的，他派了这些人去，当他们到达那里时，他们看到了预定当天的发言人名单，就像是，是的，摩西、杜威、瓦格纳，所有这些即将作证的重要人物，卡罗花了很多笔墨，他写了好几页，他真的深入挖掘，沉浸在那个时刻。
when Lindsay realizes he's been tricked, just luxuriating in the moment when Lindsay realizes he's been tricked and Robert Moses walks into the room and forces Lindsay to shake his hand in front of the reporters and while Lindsay is testifying about how great this bill would be, Moses is literally stifling laughter in the room and then Lindsay rushes out and heads right back to New York City because he doesn't wanna be there
当林赛意识到自己被骗了，沉浸在林赛意识到自己被骗，罗伯特·摩西走进房间，强迫林赛在记者面前与他握手，而当林赛正在作证说这个法案有多棒时，摩西在房间里简直是在强忍笑意，然后林赛冲了出去，直接回到了纽约市，因为他不想待在那里。
as this parade of the power brokers kind of goes on. And they just tear the Lindsay idea to shreds and support Moses. And Carol gets very caddy here, where he's like, it's too bad John Lindsay didn't stick around because he might've been able to finally discover who the power brokers he had been complaining about all this time actually were,
随着这群权力掮客的游行继续进行。他们把林赛的想法撕得粉碎，转而支持摩西。卡罗在这里变得非常刻薄，他说，约翰·林赛没有留下来真是太可惜了，因为他可能终于能发现他一直抱怨的那些权力掮客到底是谁了。
because he had no idea who he was talking about. And then Moses is like, he spends a few more days just kind of like going even overboard, having people attack the mayor's transit merger legislation, and it never makes it out of committee. It's such a total defeat of Lindsay in Carol's Telling, and really the last moment where Moses has that kind of power and that kind of victory in his career.
因为他根本不知道自己在谈论谁。然后摩西又花了几天时间，甚至有点过火，让人攻击市长的交通合并立法，结果它从未走出委员会。在卡罗的叙述中，这是林赛的彻底失败，也是摩西职业生涯中拥有那种权力和那种胜利的最后一个时刻。
That's right. I mean, this is real. This is kind of it. Like, he calls in all of his favors. He's still presented as the Moses kind of before the fair in terms of his sort of character being beyond reproach, that if anything needs to get built, it would be Moses who had built it anyway.
没错。我的意思是，这是真实的。这基本上就是终点了。他动用了他所有的恩情。他仍然被呈现为世博会之前的摩西，就他的性格而言是无可指责的，如果有什么需要建造的东西，无论如何都会是摩西建造的。
But it's just one of those things that he does seem to say, or Caro seems to suggest that if Lindsay were better at this and he was more charismatic and more supportive of people, like maybe this could have happened. And if at this point, if Rockefeller had also gotten on the side, he kind of stays on the fence with this. And just sort of waits for it to play out.
但这只是他似乎说的一件事，或者卡罗似乎暗示，如果林赛在这方面做得更好，他更有魅力，更支持别人，也许这本来是可以实现的。如果此时洛克菲勒也站在这一边，他在这件事上有点骑墙。只是等着看事态如何发展。
He's even putting his thumb on the scales. So no one really takes this moment to push him over. I think they're waiting to see if Lindsay has the juice to do it, and he clearly does not. I wonder, I bet you're my friend, and you have this power struggle going on between Rockefeller and Moses, clearly. And Lindsay is the upstart who thinks that he is also a part of the dynamic, but is not
他甚至在暗中施加影响。所以没有人真的利用这个时刻把他推过去。我想他们是在等看林赛是否有能力做到这一点，而他显然没有。我很好奇，我敢打赌你是我的朋友，而且洛克菲勒和摩西之间显然存在着权力斗争。而林赛是一个自以为也是这种动态一部分的暴发户，但却并不。
necessarily at the same level. And so it's true, if Rockefeller had liked Lindsay's plan, he probably could have thrown his weight behind it and gotten it through. But Lindsay makes the mistake of trotting on Rockefeller's territory. Rockefeller already has a big transit plan for the state. So the idea that Lindsay is like, well, here's my plan. We should do that instead. Like it's just foolish. It's the kind of thing that a good politician knows ahead of time, like what the other politicians want to do. And it's such a, it's the naivete
一定处于同一水平。所以这是真的，如果洛克菲勒喜欢林赛的计划，他可能已经把他的影响力投入其中并使其通过了。但林赛犯了一个错误，那就是闯入了洛克菲勒的地盘。洛克菲勒已经为该州制定了一个宏大的交通计划。所以林赛说，好吧，这是我的计划。我们应该改做那个。这简直是愚蠢。这是一个优秀的政治家预先就知道的事情，比如其他政治家想做什么。这真是太天真了。
of him that I think really gets Caro's goat, where if he has this charisma and he has public support at the moment But he just has no real understanding of who he needs to ally with How he can sway people really other than this kind of childish idea that once you get elected to office People have to do what you say It's honestly it's a little similar in some ways Although in a I think a more positive direction in terms of the desired outcome to when to Trump's first term as president Where he just seemed to kind of think that if you get elected, everyone has to like you and do what you say, which is not the way government works. Government is about forging alliances and sharing goals and sharing motivations, or at least overlapping your needs and my needs so that we can work together or compromising things.
我认为这正是卡罗最看不惯的地方，他有这种魅力，目前也有公众支持，但他对需要与谁结盟毫无真正的理解，除了这种幼稚的想法，即一旦你当选公职，人们就必须听你的，否则他真的不知道如何左右别人。老实说，这在某些方面有点相似，尽管我认为在预期的结果方面更积极一些，就像特朗普的第一任总统任期，他似乎认为只要你当选，每个人都必须喜欢你并听你的，这不是政府运作的方式。政府是关于建立联盟、分享目标和分享动机，或者至少是重叠你的需求和我的需求，以便我们可以一起工作或妥协。
But the version you're taught as a kid is you win an election, and then you make the rules. And it seems like Lindsay is operating under that. So Moses has this, I always think of it as like that what they always call the high watermark of the Confederacy that like one little corner of a fence in Gettysburg, Pennsylvania, that the Confederates broke through for a second, you know, when they charge. And that was the farthest north that the Confederate army ever got. That's what I think about that with this because he has this support. Then in July of that year, 1966,
但你小时候学到的版本是，你赢得了选举，然后你制定规则。林赛似乎就是按照这个逻辑行事的。所以我总是把摩西的这个时刻看作是他们所说的邦联的高水位线，就像宾夕法尼亚州葛底斯堡围栏的一个小角落，邦联军队冲锋时突破了一秒钟，你知道。那是邦联军队到达的最北端。这就是我想到他的原因，因为他有这种支持。然后在1966年那年的7月，
there's a big 30th anniversary celebration for the Triborough Bridge. They bus in 3,500 kids and give them lunch. They have a boxed book called 30 Years of Achievement that they put out. And Moses goes, "'We do have a surplus of money in Triborough, it's going to go to improving our bridges that we own already. And they close the
三区大桥举行了盛大的30周年庆典。他们用巴士运来了3500名孩子，并给了他们午餐。他们发行了一本名为《30年的成就》的盒装书。摩西说：“我们在三区确实有盈余资金，它将用于改善我们已经拥有的桥梁。他们关闭了
bridge for the ceremony to drivers for a half hour and Caro just describes these thousands of drivers sitting in the sun in their cars waiting for the bridge to open back up again. And that really is that high watermark, this last celebration of his power. And at the end of the ceremony, this is really what Moses- I love it. Well, he's saying goodbye to guests. He's saying goodbye to guests. And a letter arrives from the mayor saying,
桥梁进行仪式，对司机关闭了半小时，卡罗描述了这些成千上万的司机坐在阳光下的车里等待桥梁重新开放。那确实是那个高水位线，他权力的最后一次庆祝。在仪式结束时，这正是摩西——我喜欢它。好吧，他在和客人告别。他在和客人告别。一封来自市长的信到了，说，
hey, you've been dismissed as arterial highways representative. You're not gonna do that anymore. And Carol says, that would have been a powerful thing to do earlier. Now it doesn't matter anymore. A couple of months ago, it would have mattered a lot.
嘿，你已经被解雇了，不再担任动脉公路代表了。你以后不会再做那个了。卡罗说，如果早点这样做会很有力。现在已经无关紧要了。几个月前，这会很重要。
Yeah. But it means that Moses now has one job. He just has the Triborough authority presidency. He used to have 12 jobs. This is the only one job he has. And Lindsay puts one of his guys on the Triborough board when a position opens up, but it's still every vote is two to one. Moses and his guy versus this other guy.
是的。但这意味着摩西现在只有一份工作了。他只有三区管理局主席的职位。他曾经有12份工作。这是他唯一剩下的工作。当一个职位空缺时，林赛把他的一个人安插进了三区董事会，但仍然是每项投票二对一。摩西和他的手下对阵这个新人。
And so he wins every vote. And he says, well, even if I don't have that arterial representative posting more, my plans are the only ones that can be used. I have the support of the power brokers and his term as tri-brohead doesn't end until 1970, by which time there may be another mayor anyway. It doesn't matter. He is feeling still. He's been reduced to one post.
所以他赢得了每一次投票。他说，好吧，即使我不再有那个动脉代表的职位，我的计划也是唯一可以使用的。我有权力掮客的支持，他作为三区负责人的任期直到1970年才结束，到那时可能已经有另一位市长了。没关系。他仍然感觉良好。他已经被削减到一个职位了。
The fair was a disaster, but he still feels so arrogant. He does not care what Lindsay tries to do. Lindsay is meaningless to him, but there's someone far more powerful than Mayor Lindsay, who is finally ready to move against Moses. There's someone who has finally had their fill of Moses. Who is that person, Roman? I mean, this is Governor Rockefeller, who's going to come back in to be the person who finally puts Robert Moses out of a job. And that is the main subject of the next chapter. It's called The Last Stand, Chapter 49. And this is where Rockefeller, you know, after letting Mayor Lindsay kind of flounder around a bit, maybe soften up Moses in
世博会是一场灾难，但他仍然感到如此傲慢。他不在乎林赛试图做什么。林赛对他来说毫无意义，但有一个比林赛市长强大得多的人，终于准备对摩西采取行动了。有一个人终于受够了摩西。那个人是谁，罗曼？我的意思是，这是洛克菲勒州长，他将回来成为最终让罗伯特·摩西失业的人。这就是下一章的主要主题。它叫《最后的立场》，第49章。这就是洛克菲勒，你知道，在让林赛市长挣扎了一段时间，也许在某些方面软化了摩西之后，
some ways, I don't know, maybe for his own amusement. I don't know why he didn't step in earlier. But Rockefeller finally steps in. And what he's really trying to do is take over transit. Like he'd already given his brother control of the parks. And now he has this vision of this massive overhaul of transportation. And he knows it's gonna be incredibly expensive. And the person who has all the money, the person who controls the money that he wants to control to do this overhaul of estate transportation
我不知道，也许是为了他自己的娱乐。我不知道他为什么不早点介入。但洛克菲勒终于介入了。他真正想做的是接管交通。就像他已经让他兄弟控制了公园一样。现在他有了这个对交通进行大规模改革的愿景。他知道这将极其昂贵。而那个拥有所有资金的人，那个控制着他想要控制的资金来进行这次州交通改革的人
is Robert Moses. He wants Robert Moses' money. He wants to control it. He wants our Moses money. There's two, it's gonna cost him at least $6.5 billion for the first five years of building this massive transportation system that he wants for the state.
是罗伯特·摩西。他想要罗伯特·摩西的钱。他想控制它。他想要我们的摩西钱。有两家，他想要为他想要为该州建立的这个庞大交通系统的前五年建设至少花费65亿美元。
This integrated system of mass transit and roads. And there's only two organizations that have it. There's the Port Authority and there's Triper Authority. Port Authority is half New Jersey. He doesn't want anything to do with that. He does not want to have to deal with the government of New Jersey. They'd be like, hey, yeah, we can give you that money.
这个公共交通和道路的综合系统。只有两个组织拥有它。一个是港务局，一个是三区管理局。港务局有一半属于新泽西州。他不想和那个有任何关系。他不想处理新泽西州的政府。他们会说，嘿，是的，我们可以给你那笔钱。
You know, maybe, got can give you that money. Maybe, got some nice buildings over in Manhattan. Maybe we could have someone else. He doesn't have to deal with that. This is me. I come from New Jersey. I remember my dad referring to, at one point, the governor of New Jersey and being like, yeah, he's a little slimy, but you got to accept a little bit of that. And it's like, that's the New Jersey way.
你知道，也许，可以给你那笔钱。也许，在曼哈顿有一些漂亮的建筑。也许我们可以有别人。他不必处理那个。这是我。我来自新泽西。我记得我爸爸曾经提到过新泽西州长，说，是的，他有点滑头，但你必须接受一点点。就像，那是新泽西的方式。
Rockefeller's like, Triborough has this money. There's one person standing the way of me getting it, and that is Robert Moses. And Caro sees this as just an inevitable clash of personalities. Rockefeller and Moses are both too arrogant, they're too used to getting their own way, they cannot coexist for long, it's impossible. And in the past, Moses was irremovable.
洛克菲勒说，三区有这笔钱。有一个人挡在我得到它的路上，那就是罗伯特·摩西。卡罗认为这是一场不可避免的性格冲突。洛克菲勒和摩西都太傲慢了，他们太习惯于按自己的方式行事，他们不可能长期共存，这是不可能的。在过去，摩西是不可动摇的。
And Caro reminds us of the reasons. He had all these jobs that interlocked with each other. He had so many sources of money, the staggered term limits, he couldn't be replaced all at once. He had the city-state combined power place, so the mayor couldn't move him because he needed the state's help, and the state couldn't move him because they needed the city. Each of his posts, it was beautifully
卡罗提醒我们原因。他有所有这些相互交织的工作。他有这么多资金来源，交错的任期限制，他不能一次被全部替换。他拥有城市和州结合的权力场所，所以市长不能动他，因为他需要州的帮助，而州不能动他，因为他们需要城市。他的每一个职位，都是精美地
constructed. It was fiendish in its intricacies. But now, as we know, he's resigned or been fired from all but one post. And he has so much less money at hand to fight with as a result of that. Right. He has less money and just like that whole idea of him, cause Carol describes this like resigning from one has all this power to inflict harm, uh, using his authority on other posts. And so it was sort of impossible.
构建的。它的复杂性是魔鬼般的。但现在，正如我们所知，他已经辞职或被解雇了，只剩下一个职位。因此，他手头用来战斗的资金也少得多了。对。他钱少了，就像整个那个想法一样，因为卡罗描述了辞去一个职位就拥有了利用他在其他职位的权力造成伤害的所有权力。所以这在某种程度上是不可能的。
Now, Triamburro happens to be kind of the most powerful one because it has all the money, it has this direct connection with the bond holders. So therefore like the city and state really can't intervene. Like- And they can't oversee any of his actions. His actions are both private and also outside of their immediate flow control.
现在，三区恰好是最强大的一个，因为它拥有所有的钱，它与债券持有人有这种直接联系。因此，城市和州真的无法干预。就像——他们也无法监督他的任何行动。他的行动既是私人的，也超出了他们的直接流程控制。
So it is, if you're gonna be left with one, that's the one. That's the one to be left with. And it's possible he's still building that dam somewhere. Nobody knows, nobody cares, like it's happening off in another world, but that's the one you wanna have. But here's the real thing about the fact
所以，如果你要只剩下一个，那就是这一个。这是唯一剩下的一个。而且他可能还在某个地方建造那个大坝，没人知道，没人关心，就像它发生在另一个世界一样，但那是你想要拥有的一个。但关于事实的真正问题是
that the governor is Nelson Rockefeller, because, I mean, and this is like, this is sort of like, just like fate coming together in a certain way to have this unfold, because it just so happens that Nelson Rockefeller is part of the richest family in the world pretty much, and his brother owns Chase Bank. Now, why that matters is because even though
州长是纳尔逊·洛克菲勒，因为，我的意思是，这就像是命运以某种方式结合在一起，让这一切展开，因为碰巧纳尔逊·洛克菲勒几乎是世界上最富有家族的一员，而他的兄弟拥有大通银行。现在，这之所以重要，是因为即使
you're a bond holder and you have some right to have this relationship with the Tribor authority through their bonds and being paid back. When something goes wrong with that relationship, you don't actually, it's not feasible for you to sue Tribor authority for changing the terms. Really what happens is that you have this entity that represents you as the bond holder. You have the bond holder's trustee who will handle any of these suits for you. Because also if one bondholder sues,
你是债券持有人，并且你有某种权利通过他们的债券并被偿还与三区管理局建立这种关系。当这种关系出现问题时，你实际上并没有，你起诉三区管理局改变条款是不可行的。真正发生的是，你有一个代表你作为债券持有人的实体。你有债券持有人的受托人，他会为你处理任何这些诉讼。因为如果一个债券持有人起诉，
but not everybody sues, that undermines his suit. Exactly. So you need one shared entity that is overseeing the interests of the bondholders. Of the bondholders. And that entity is Chase Bank, who is run by the governor's brother. And the trustee was the Chase Manhattan Bank,
但不是每个人都起诉，这会削弱他的诉讼。没错。所以你需要一个共同的实体来监督债券持有人的利益。债券持有人的。而那个实体就是大通银行，由州长的兄弟经营。受托人是大通曼哈顿银行，
and the Chase Manhattan was the only large bank in the United States still controlled by a single family, the governors. Like this is, it is, we'll get, each time it's like a cosmic conjunction allows this. So here's how it plays out. January 4th, 1967, we've covered a lot of time on the show, it's 1967 all of a sudden.
而大通曼哈顿是美国唯一一家仍由单一家族（州长家族）控制的大型银行。就像这个，它是一个，我们每次都会得到，就像宇宙的结合允许这种情况发生。所以事情是这样发展的。1967年1月4日，我们在节目中涵盖了很多时间，突然间就是1967年了。
Man will be walking on the moon in just a couple of years. And we were talking about a time when people didn't even have cars. And Rockefeller asked the legislature and the voters to approve a $2 billion bond issue for transportation construction. And part of that would be merging all of the city and state transit authorities into one metropolitan commuter transportation authority. Eventually this will turn into the MTA. It will merge together as the MTA, the Metropolitan Transportation Authority. I used to think it was transit, but it's transportation. Under the control
人类在几年内就会在月球上行走。而我们谈论的是一个人们甚至没有汽车的时代。洛克菲勒要求立法机关和选民批准20亿美元的交通建设债券发行。其中一部分将是把所有城市和州的交通当局合并为一个大都会通勤交通管理局。最终这将变成MTA。它将合并为MTA，大都会交通管理局。我过去以为它是交通（transit），但它是交通（transportation）。在他的助手罗南的控制下，
of his aide Ronan, who is a former college professor who, we may have mentioned before, Moses hates him. He doesn't like Paul. Yeah. He thinks he's a sort of like, he's just like an egghead, a dude who knows the academics of transportation, but knows nothing else. And Roman, does that offend you at all since his name is almost, his last name Ronan is almost your first name? No, I'm okay with it. Okay, that's fine.
他是一位前大学教授，我们之前可能提到过，摩西讨厌他。他不喜欢保罗。是的。他认为他是一个书呆子，一个了解交通学术，但对其他一无所知的人。罗南，这冒犯你了吗，因为他的名字几乎，他的姓氏罗南几乎是你的名字？不，我没问题。好的，那很好。
I still have the RM bond with Robert Moses, if I- Yeah, that's true, that's a good point. Oh, you're all over this book, this is amazing, yeah. And it always makes me think of Ronan the Accuser, who is a Marvel villain, who was in the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie. And the other thing is Rockefeller, he has a budget shortfall in his projections for the state. He's already factored in millions of dollars from this bond issue to shore up the budget.
我仍然和罗伯特·摩西有RM的联系，如果我——是的，那是真的，这是一个很好的观点。哦，你对这本书了如指掌，这太棒了，是的。这总是让我想起指控者罗南，他是漫威的反派，出现在第一部《银河护卫队》电影中。另一件事是洛克菲勒，他在该州的预测中出现了预算缺口。他已经把来自这次债券发行的数百万美元计入了预算，以支撑预算。
So if this doesn't pass, he's going to be in a lot of trouble. He's going to have to enact huge tax increases. He plans on running for president in 1968 and being a Republican, at this time Republicans, it was a bigger tent than it is now. You still had these liberal spending Republicans, but it's going to hurt him with the other conservatives when he's running for president, if people see him as a guy who just spends a lot of money and then end taxes. So the legislature approves it. The referendum has to be voted on by the people of the state. And they're getting a little tired of Rockefeller's big spending ways.
所以如果这不能通过，他将会有大麻烦。他将不得不实施巨大的增税。他计划在1968年竞选总统，作为共和党人，在当时，共和党人是一个比现在更大的阵营。你仍然有这些自由派支出型的共和党人，但如果人们看到他是一个只花很多钱然后加税的人，这将在他竞选总统时伤害他与其他保守派的关系。所以立法机关批准了它。公投必须由该州的人民投票决定。他们对洛克菲勒的大手大脚有点厌倦了。
Not everybody in New York State is a Rockefeller, used to spending lots of money. And the unions, they still support Moses as the only guy who can competently build anything in the region. He's brought them so many jobs. He's brought them so much money. And Ronan tells the press, you know what, if we merge everybody into this organization, it's going to lead to this huge surplus in rail and toll revenue. And Moses, he's like, that doesn't seem right to me. And he does some of his figuring on yellow legal pads. The single greatest way to brainstorm or work out any problem is on a yellow legal pad.
并不是纽约州的每个人都是洛克菲勒，习惯于花很多钱。工会仍然支持摩西，认为他是该地区唯一能胜任建造任何东西的人。他为他们带来了这么多工作。他为他们带来了这么多钱。罗南告诉媒体，你知道吗，如果我们把每个人都合并到这个组织中，它将导致铁路和通行费收入的巨大盈余。而摩西，他觉得，这对我来说似乎不对。他在黄色法律便签纸上做了一些计算。头脑风暴或解决任何问题的最好方法是在黄色法律便签纸上。
Robert Moses, this is one of the few places where Robert Moses and I really overlap is our love of working on yellow legal pads. He does the figures and he's smart enough to see that. His mind is still so agile and so comprehensive that he can see these numbers don't add up. This merger is going to lead to huge deficits. It will never save the state from having to cover the subways money problems. It's just the numbers don't add up.
罗伯特·摩西，这是罗伯特·摩西和我真正重叠的少数地方之一，就是我们对在黄色法律便签纸上工作的热爱。他做了计算，他足够聪明，能看出这一点。他的头脑仍然如此敏捷和全面，他能看出这些数字加起来不对。这次合并将导致巨大的赤字。它永远无法挽救该州免于承担地铁的资金问题。数字就是加不起来。
And the Rockefeller authorities, the state authorities, they've been paying off bondholders from state revenues, not their own revenues. So Moses has all this calculation, da da da da, and he shows by 1972 debt service for the state will be five hundred million dollars, which is this huge burden for the taxpayers, and that eventually this big merger plan will cost the state a billion dollars just in interest payments. The interest payments will be so enormous because they have to borrow so much money. And Moses knows if he reveals this truth, it will destroy the governor's plans. It will just wreck them. He will have defeated Rockefeller in this way. But Moses is not a guy who just wants to stomp on his enemies.
而洛克菲勒当局，州当局，他们一直用州收入偿还债券持有人，而不是他们自己的收入。所以摩西有所有的计算，哒哒哒哒，他显示到1972年，该州的债务服务将达到5亿美元，这对纳税人来说是一个巨大的负担，最终这个庞大的合并计划将仅在利息支付上就花费该州10亿美元。利息支付将非常巨大，因为他们必须借这么多钱。摩西知道，如果他揭露这个真相，它将摧毁州长的计划。它只会摧毁它们。他将以这种方式击败洛克菲勒。但摩西不是一个只想践踏敌人的人。
He wants power, you know? He wants power, yeah. And so he sort of presents this and says, well, I won't let anyone else know about this sort of thing if you make me part of this new merged entity. He's gotten to the point where he kind of, he recognizes that his time as a completely independent entity is coming to an end.
他想要权力，你知道吗？他想要权力，是的。所以他有点展示了这一点，并说，好吧，如果你让我成为这个新合并实体的一部分，我就不会让其他人知道这种事情。他已经到了他有点认识到他作为一个完全独立实体的时代即将结束的地步。
And maybe it's because of that leverage from Chase Bank, you know, like, because that's never really, you know, no one really like pulls that lever, you know what I mean, to muscle in on the Chase Bank part of it. You know? I mean, to be honest, I think there's something about it that to a Rockefeller would feel gauche to be that open and that clear on it. Both of these guys come from money backgrounds.
也许是因为来自大通银行的杠杆作用，你知道，因为那从来没有真正，你知道，没有人真正拉动那个杠杆，你知道我的意思吗，去挤进大通银行的那部分。你知道吗？我的意思是，老实说，我认为关于它有一些东西，对洛克菲勒来说，表现得那么开放和清晰会感到笨拙。这两个人都有金钱背景。
Moses from kind of like the upper middle class and Rockefeller is from the richest family in the history of the world. But there's also a certain amount of like, Moses is a brash, loud guy, Rockefeller is not. For lack of better comparative terms, I'm just gonna say one's Jewish and one's Gentile. That's just, you know, that's just for lack
摩西来自中上层阶级，而洛克菲勒来自世界历史上最富有的家族。但也有一定数量的，摩西是一个粗鲁、大声的人，洛克菲勒不是。由于缺乏更好的比较术语，我只想说一个是犹太人，一个是外邦人。这只是，你知道，这只是因为缺乏
of better reasons for why. But they, I think there's probably something in Rockefeller that feels like to pull that lever, to really have that, to show that leverage out would be kind of disgusting, you know, would be kind of slimy. So but Moses is setting up just in case he needs to, his leverage, he tells a reporter, hey, I have some figures to show you. I've got some numbers to show you.
更好的理由。但他们，我认为洛克菲勒可能有一些东西觉得拉动那个杠杆，真正拥有那个，展示出那种杠杆作用会有点令人作呕，你知道，会有点滑头。所以但摩西正在设置，以防他需要，他的杠杆，他告诉记者，嘿，我有一些数字要给你看。我有一些数字要给你看。
And he's already made a public statement saying the merger plan is grotesque and it's absurd. And then on March 9th, 1967, they have a private meeting, Moses and Rockefeller. I think it's one of them and each one of their aides, each of them. And then two days after he said the plan was grotesque and absurd, he goes, I'm fully behind it. It's indispensable.
他已经发表了一份公开声明，称合并计划是怪诞和荒谬的。然后在1967年3月9日，他们进行了一次私人会议，摩西和洛克菲勒。我想是他们中的一个和他们各自的一个助手。在他说了这个计划是怪诞和荒谬的两天后，他说，我完全支持它。它是不可或缺的。
We've got to do this. And it's clear that Rockefeller's promised Moses that he's not gonna be pushed out of this system. And that reporter's like, Moses, you said you had some figures you want to show me? And Moses is like, uh, yeah, yeah, I'll send them to you. I'll send them to you. And he never does. He just never...
我们必须这样做。很明显，洛克菲勒已经向摩西承诺，他不会被挤出这个系统。那个记者说，摩西，你说你有数字要给我看？摩西说，呃，是的，是的，我会发给你的。我会发给你的。但他从来没有。他只是从来没有……
It's accomplished what it needed to do. And it seems that Rockefeller's promised Moses a seat on the transit board in exchange for supporting the plan publicly. And Rockefeller's in public, he's like, we want Moses, we want his abilities on that board. Again, Moses is an old man by this point. He's pushing almost 80, you know,
它已经完成了它需要做的事情。似乎洛克菲勒已经承诺给摩西一个交通董事会的席位，以换取公开支持该计划。洛克菲勒在公开场合说，我们想要摩西，我们想要他在董事会上的能力。同样，摩西此时已经是一位老人了。他快80岁了，你知道，
but they're like, we need him. And it means that the resources of Tribro are put in the service of lobbying for this. They fund this campaign, they lobby, Moses goes out and lobbies hard to the public about these mergers. And he lies that the bondholder covenants, these precious sacred things,
但他们说，我们需要他。这意味着三区的资源被用于游说支持这一点。他们资助了这场运动，他们游说，摩西走出去，向公众大力游说这些合并。他撒谎说债券持有人的契约，这些珍贵的神圣的东西，
he's been holding over everyone's head, that he just held over Lindsay's head in the last chapter. He promises that they will be respected, even though he knows that it won't be. You know, he knows it's not gonna happen. I think he is ready, I think, to sell out the bondholders for this last chance to hold onto power. And partly because of his help, the referendum passes,
他一直悬在每个人头上，他刚刚在上一章悬在林赛头上。他承诺它们会得到尊重，尽管他知道它不会。你知道，他知道它不会发生。我认为他已经准备好，我想，为了这最后一次保持权力的机会而出卖债券持有人。部分因为他的帮助，公投通过了，
and the MTA continues today to do a mediocre at best job of coordinating the New York region's mass transit. But there's still this problem. He said the bondholder covenants would be totally taken care of. Is that the case though? Roman, if I hold some bonds in Triborough, I can just sit back and be rest assured that the money is going to come to me that's owed to me. Is that going to happen? No. I mean, but what's clear is that both sides of this have worked out an understanding so
而MTA今天继续在协调纽约地区的公共交通方面做得充其量是平庸。但仍然存在这个问题。他说债券持有人的契约会得到完全的处理。情况是这样吗？罗曼，如果我持有三区的一些债券，我可以坐下来放心，欠我的钱会给我吗？这会发生吗？不。我的意思是，但很清楚的是，双方都已经达成了一种理解，所以
that they're not really, none of this is sort of vigorously pursued. Just because everyone here is friends. Basically, Chase Bank represents the bondholders. Now the interests of Moses and Rockefeller are aligned. Like no one wants this to work out. And so it ends up being that there's a settlement, but it's all- It's all very shadowy.
他们并没有真正，所有这些都没有被积极追求。只是因为这里的每个人都是朋友。基本上，大通银行代表债券持有人。现在摩西和洛克菲勒的利益是一致的。就像没有人希望这件事出问题。所以最终达成了一个和解，但这一切——这一切都非常阴暗。
Just to lay the stakes out here, there's this one section here where Carol says, two things are clear. One, that in the opinion of almost every legal expert on municipal and public authority bonds, this is already the most exciting sentence in the history of the world. That if the suit had been prosecuted vigorously,
为了在这里摆出赌注，这里有一部分卡罗说，两件事很清楚。第一，在几乎每一位市政和公共当局债券法律专家的意见中，这已经是世界历史上最令人兴奋的句子了。如果诉讼被积极起诉，
because Chase Bank has started bringing suit already, it would have been successful. The merger would have been voided until all its $367,200,000 bonds had been redeemed. The Triborough Bridge and Tunnel Authority would have remained an independent Autonomous agency and if the authority chose not to redeem its bonds It would have remained independent and autonomous indefinitely to that the suit was not prosecuted vigorously Why the suit was not prosecuted vigorously is not known and as you know Robert Carrow hates to say when something's not known
因为大通银行已经开始提起诉讼，它会是成功的。合并将被废除，直到其367,200,000美元的债券全部被赎回。三区大桥和隧道管理局将保持为一个独立的自治机构，如果管理局选择不赎回其债券，它将无限期地保持独立和自治。诉讼没有被积极起诉。为什么诉讼没有被积极起诉尚不清楚，正如你所知，罗伯特·卡罗讨厌说当某事不清楚时
You have to imagine behind that sentence must have been so many hours of trying to find out from people what exactly happened because Chase Bank files suit, its lawyer Thomas Dewey, former governor, my other grandmother's most hated politician in her life, after the referendum passes, Governor Rockefeller and his brother David Rockefeller, president of Chase Bank, they negotiate a settlement at the governor's house in February of 1968 and It's sealed but we seem to know some of the things in it that the bondholders agree The merger is constitutional and legal and the Triborough Board chaired by Robert Moses will be supplanted by the MTA board chaired by Rockefeller's Aid Ronan and with that the suit is over and
你必须想象在那句话背后一定有无数个小时试图从人们那里找出到底发生了什么，因为大通银行提起了诉讼，它的律师托马斯·杜威，前州长，我另一位祖母一生中最讨厌的政治家，在公投通过后，洛克菲勒州长和他的兄弟大卫·洛克菲勒，大通银行行长，他们在1968年2月在州长官邸谈判达成了一项和解，它是密封的，但我们似乎知道其中的一些事情，债券持有人同意合并是宪法和合法的，由罗伯特·摩西担任主席的三区董事会将由洛克菲勒的助手罗南担任主席的MTA董事会取代，诉讼就此结束，
Moses not knowing it, has been defeated. Yeah. Because Moses, one of the reasons he's agreeing with this, one of the reasons he told his in-house lawyer, don't bother with this suit, don't push too hard, is because he has been assured he will be on that MTA board, that he is being pushed up rather than being pushed out. And Carol says, nobody knows what Chase got in return.
摩西不知道，他已经被击败了。是的。因为摩西，他同意这一点的原因之一，他告诉他的内部律师不要管这个诉讼，不要推得太紧的原因之一，是因为他被保证他会进入那个MTA董事会，他被推上去而不是被挤出去。卡罗说，没人知道大通得到了什么回报。
Nobody knows why the bank dropped this suit for the settlement. And though Caro notes that the bank continued to underwrite immensely profitable state bonds from there on, but it's also a fact that the governor's brother runs this bank. And Caro is like, removing Moses takes literally that the governor of New York be the one man beyond the reach of normal politics and that the trustee of Triborough's interest be a bank run by that governor's brother. This is not the way democracy is meant to work.
没人知道银行为什么放弃这个诉讼达成和解。尽管卡罗指出，银行从那时起继续承销极其有利可图的州债券，但这也是一个事实，即州长的兄弟经营着这家银行。卡罗说，移除摩西字面上需要纽约州长成为唯一一个超出正常政治范围的人，并且三区利益的受托人是一家由该州长兄弟经营的银行。这不是民主运作的方式。
No, and it's one of those things that, it's kind of like the resignation that happened in the last episode that we talked about. It's like, you don't really want this to be the style of end. You want it to have a sort of democracy prevailing or something more dramatic. But the fact that this sort of backroom deal
不，这是其中之一，它有点像我们在上一集谈到的辞职。就像，你真的不希望这是结局的风格。你希望它有一种民主盛行或更戏剧性的东西。但这种极其强大和富有的人的幕后交易结束了他的职业生涯的事实是，就像，是的，我很高兴它发生了。这不是你希望事情发生的方式。你知道，就像，这里代表的是一种更令人讨厌的政府形式，你知道吗？是的，我觉得这是我有时在哥斯拉电影结尾得到的酸味。我喜欢哥斯拉电影。
of extremely powerful and wealthy people putting the end to his career is like, yeah, I'm glad it happened. This is not the way you want things to happen. You know, like, it's just like a nastier form of government that's being represented here, you know? Yes, I feel like it is the sour taste that I get sometimes at the end of Godzilla movies. I love Godzilla movies.
但当另一个怪物出现，然后哥斯拉把那个怪物打跑，每个人都说，是的，哥斯拉，暗示是如果那个哥斯拉，一个压碎人的怪物不在那里，那个怪物会杀死所有人。就像，我们不能自己做这件事。就像我们需要一个更大、更可怕的东西来处理那个可怕的东西。对于所谓的民主来说，这是一个非常糟糕的教训，政府的全部意义在于人民可以控制他们的命运并至少控制他们的治理。是的，你需要全国潜在最富有、最强大的人，
But when another monster comes along and then Godzilla fights that monster away and everyone's like, yeah, Godzilla, the implication is if that Godzilla, a monster who crushes people was not there, that other monster would have killed everybody. That like, we can't do this ourselves. Like we need a larger, scarier thing to take care of the scary thing. And that's a really, that's a terrible lesson to have about what's ostensibly a democracy, where the whole point of the government is that the people can control their fates and control at least their governance. Yeah, the idea that you need the richest, most powerful man in the country potentially,
或者至少在该州，去击倒这个从未当选并拥有自己权力基础的家伙，这是非常悲哀的。所以有一部分我读到这里时觉得，是的，你抓到他了。还有另一部分我像，哦，是的，那不是，我希望像人们那样去投票站投票让罗伯特·摩西下台。那只是，它不会那样发生。很清楚的是，或者似乎发生的是
or in the state at least, to knock out this other guy who was never elected and had his own power base is, it's very sad. And so there's part of me that reads this and is like, yeah, you got him. And there's another part of me that's like, oh, yeah, that's not, I wish like the people kind of like then went to the polls and voted Robert Moses out. That's just not, it's not gonna happen that way. And what's clear is that, or what seems to have happened
在某个时候，州长向罗伯特·摩西承诺了这个新MTA董事会的一个关键部分，尽管罗南将成为负责人——他将成为负责人，但摩西认为他会得到什么并不完全清楚，他要么进入董事会，也许可以利用他的权力基础投票超过
was that at some point the governor had promised Robert Moses a key part of this new MTA board, even though Ronan was going to be the head of the- He'll be the head of it, but it's kind of unclear exactly what Moses thinks he's gonna get, that he'll be either on the board and maybe can use his power base to outvote
或挤走罗南，或者他将成为这个新超级三区（将发生在它内部）的主席。并不完全清楚它是什么，但我们知道他被承诺了一些东西。但他没有得到它。他根本没有得到它。卡罗说，洛克菲勒对摩西的承诺很好地达到了目的。它让摩西安静了近一年，说服他不要反对洛克菲勒的交通合并或资助它的公投。
or push out Ronan, or that he will be the president of this new kind of like super tri-bro that will happen inside of it. And it's not really clear exactly what it is, but we know he's been promised something. And he doesn't get it. He doesn't get it at all. And Carol says, Rockefeller's promise to Moses had served its purpose well. It had kept Moses quiet for almost a year, persuaded him not to oppose Rockefeller's transportation merger or the referendum which had funded it.
州长的承诺此外说服摩西撤回了可能使洛克菲勒的交通合并无效的诉讼。它使洛克菲勒能够使用他的名字。现在，使用了他的名字，从他身上得到了他能得到的一切，州长把他扔掉了。”所以摩西现在，当这一切完成时，他已经79岁了，他只是坐在那里等待洛克菲勒提供他的新工作是什么的那一刻，所以摩西现在，当这一切完成时，他已经79岁了，他只是坐在那里等待洛克菲勒提供
The governor's promise had, moreover, persuaded Moses to withdraw the lawsuit which might have invalidated Rockefeller's transportation merger. It had enabled Rockefeller to use his name. And now, having used his name, having gotten everything out of him that he could, the governor threw him away." And so Moses is now, by the time he's all done, he's 79 years old, and he's just sitting around waiting for the moment when Rockefeller offers him what his new job is going to be, So Moses is now, by the time this is all done, he's 79 years old, and he's just sitting around waiting for the moment when Rockefeller offers him
他的新工作是什么，合并截止日期临近，他什么也没听到，截止日期临近，他控制的三区董事会，只是通过投票，我想就是这样。他并不是真的，他不，他不是三区的主席。他只是董事会上的那个人
what his new job is gonna be, and the merger deadline is coming, and he's hearing nothing, and the deadline is approaching when his Triborough board that he controls, just through votes, I guess that's it. He's not really the, he doesn't, he's not the president of Triborough. He's just the guy on the board
谁能控制最多的票数。我想他可能希望他能拥有它的唯一控制权或类似的东西。但无论如何，他控制的那个董事会一旦这个合并发生就会消失。摩西的盟友打电话给州长说你必须给他点什么，必须给他点什么。在合并前一两天，罗南终于打电话给摩西，他说，你觉得MTA顾问的工作怎么样？有25,000美元的薪水，你仍然有一辆豪华轿车和一个秘书
who can control the most votes. And I guess he's hoping maybe that he will have sole control of it or something like that. But anyway, that board that he controls is going to wink out of existence as soon as this merger happens. And Moses allies are calling the governor saying you got to give him something, got to give him something. And a day or two before the merger, Ronan finally calls Moses and he goes, how'd you like the job of consultant to the MTA? There's a $25,000 salary, you still get a limousine and a secretary
而且它没有任何权力。摩西对此感到被侮辱，但没有其他选择。要么接受那个，要么什么都没有，只是被挤出政府。所以他接受了。他没有任何东西可以战斗。他只是接受了。
and there's no power attached to it whatsoever. And Moses is insulted by this, but there's no other option. It's either the take that or have nothing just be pushed out of government. And so he accepts it. He has nothing to fight with. He just accepts.
这部分感觉有点悲伤，但也有点好笑，但我不知道。在合并之前，摩西一直说，我将成为这个MTA董事会的主要参与者。所以我将邀请董事会的其他未来成员到兰德尔岛吃午餐。我们都要聚在一起。我会确立我是谁。我会吸引他们。但当午餐的日期到来时，是在……他在合并前计划的。不，日期是在他们之后。但当午餐的日期到来时，这是他计划在合并前，现在日期是在合并之后。当午餐的日期到来时，他正在招待一群现在经营MTA的人
And this is a part that feels kind of sad, but it's also kind of funny, but I don't know. Before the merger, Moses had been like, I am going to be a major player on this MTA board. So I'm going to invite the other future members of the board to lunch at Randall's Island. We're all going to get together. I'll establish who I am. I'll charm them. But when the date comes for the lunch, which is at... He's planned it before the merger. No, the date is after them. But when the date comes for the lunch, which is he's planned it before the merger, now the date is after the merger. When the date comes for the lunch, he's hosting a bunch of people who now run the MTA
而他与它毫无关系。他失去了权力，罗南，他的克星是，他必须招待他们吃午餐。这个习惯于发泄感情的人，习惯于在讨厌某人时表现出来的人，习惯于对人吼叫的人，他知道如果我还要在这个州参与建设，我就必须亲吻罗南的屁股。
and he has nothing to do with it. And he's out of power, Ronan, his nemesis is, and he's got to host them for lunch. And this guy who is used to venting his feelings, who is used to showing when he hates someone, is used to yelling at people, he knows if I'm ever going to be involved in construction in this state again, I've got to kiss Ronan's ass.
我必须吃下他倒进我嘴里的任何屎，我不能，我就是不能让他知道我的感受。卡罗说，摩西时代结束了，始于1924年4月23日，结束于1968年3月1日。经过44年的权力，权力终于消失了。哇，重击。第49章结束。
I've got to eat whatever shit he pours into my mouth, and I cannot, I just can't show him how I feel. And Carol says, the age of Moses was over, begun on April 23rd, 1924, it had ended on March 1st, 1968. After 44 years of power, the power was gone at last. Whoa, gut punch. The end of chapter 49.
我们还有一章。它是第50章，标题是《老》，在这之后。所以第50章，最后一章，老。这是——从章节标题来看，我假设他会卷土重来。他前面还有整个第三幕，对吧？这只是整本书的下降动作，你知道吗？是的，所以我们处于，摩西大约80岁了。
We have one more chapter. It is chapter 50 titled Old, after this. So chapter 50, the final chapter, old. This is- From the chapter title, I assume he's gonna make a comeback. He's got a whole third act ahead of him, right? And this is just kind of the falling action of the entire book, you know? Yeah, so we're at, Moses is around 80 years old.
他被踢出了MTA。你知道，很难知道公众此时对他是什么态度。我想他基本上被遗忘了。他基本上，他是一个人，我的意思是，我想自从那个，当他辞去州职位而没有人真正回应时，很明显他只是不
He's been kicked out of the MTA. You know, it's hard to know where the public is with him at this point. I think he's just pretty much forgotten. He's pretty much, he's a guy who, I mean, I think ever since that, when he resigned from the state posts and nobody really responded, it's been clear that he is just not
他已经被大都会运输署踢出局了。你知道，很难说公众现在对他是什么态度。我想他基本上已经被遗忘了。他基本上，他是一个，我的意思是，我认为自从那时起，当他辞去州政府职务却无人回应时，就已经很清楚他不再是
in the public imagination, the public consciousness the same way he once was. One of the things that I find fascinating about this chapter is that this is when Robert Caro starts entering the book in a different way because this chapter overlaps with that short period when Moses was giving interviews to Caro and was talking to him. So there are a couple of times in this where Caro talks much more directly about his experience of it. So yeah, he's 80. All of his allies are worried, what is he going to do with himself? He still has this mind and he has nothing to do. And Caro just talks about going to see him not knowing yet about him being pushed out of the MTA consideration. And Caro says, there had been no official announcement that Moses had been utterly removed from power. The visitor did not know there had been so dramatic a
在公众的想象中，在公众的意识里，他不再是曾经的那个他了。这一章让我着迷的一点是，罗伯特·卡罗（Robert Caro）开始以一种不同的方式进入书中，因为这一章与摩西（Moses）接受卡罗采访并与之交谈的那段短暂时期重叠。所以书中好几次卡罗更直接地谈到了他对此的亲身经历。是的，他当时80岁了。他所有的盟友都很担心，他以后该怎么办？他依然拥有这样的头脑，却无事可做。卡罗只是谈到去见他，当时还不知道他已经被排除在MTA（大都会运输署）的考虑之外。卡罗说，当时没有任何官方公告称摩西已被彻底剥夺权力。访客并不知道他的主人地位已经发生了如此剧烈的
change in the status of his host. Of course, he never says I. I'm the visitor. He says the visitor. But he saw it once that there had been a dramatic change in the host. He wrote on his notepad, the eyes are definitely more roomy today. He seems somehow just more shrunken too. And he talks about this experience of like having to give Robert Moses a ride somewhere because Moses' chauffeur had been sent out on an errand. And so, Carol has to like drive him in his car. And I remember reading this the first time being like, oh, so not only did he meet him, but he like he had to drive him somewhere. And he says, as they walk down the steps of the cottage to the author's car, he's the he's he's promoted
变化。当然，他从不说“我”。我是访客。他说“访客”。但他确实看出主人的地位发生了剧烈的变化。他在记事本上写道：“今天的眼神明显更加空洞了。他看起来也显得更加萎缩了。”他谈到了不得不开车送罗伯特·摩西去某处的经历，因为摩西的司机被派去办事了。所以，卡罗不得不开着自己的车送他。我记得第一次读到这里时心想，哦，所以他不仅见到了他，还得开车送他去某处。他说，当他们走下小屋的台阶走向作者的车时，他——他——他已经把自己
himself to the author now from from the visitor. Moses did something that made him feel for an instant that the man walking behind him was not Robert Moses, but Paul, the author had unknown to Robert Moses spent time with his dead brother. Paul Moses had managed to keep his chin up even in discussing the misfortunes of his life, but sometimes drifting into reveries during lulls in the conversation. He had, unconsciously it seemed, uttered a phrase, a sigh, almost a moan, that hinted at the depths of the melancholy within him, a painful,
从“访客”提升为“作者”了。摩西做了一件事，让他瞬间觉得走在他前面的人不是罗伯特·摩西，而是保罗（Paul）。作者在罗伯特·摩西不知情的情况下，曾与他已故的兄弟相处过。保罗·摩西即使在谈论自己生活中的不幸时，也能保持昂扬的斗志，但有时在谈话的间隙会陷入沉思。他似乎无意识地吐出一句短语，一声叹息，几乎是一声呻吟，暗示了他内心深处忧郁的深度，一种痛苦的、
reflective sighing, Oh ho ho ho, oh ho ho ho. The author had speculated that so unusual an expression might be inherited from their father, but in all the times he had previously talked with Robert Moses, the author had never heard him make that sound of discouragement and something close to despair, but he made it now." I find that moment so touching and so beautifully written that Caro is, he's writing like a novelist there. He's tying together his experience with Moses's experience and revealing this, like it's just, it's good, I mean, it's good story writing.
反思性的叹息，“噢，呵，呵，呵，噢，呵，呵，呵。”作者推测这种不同寻常的表达方式可能是从他们父亲那里继承来的，但在他之前与罗伯特·摩西交谈的所有时间里，作者从未听过他发出那种沮丧和近乎绝望的声音，但他现在发出了。”我觉得那一刻非常感人，写得太美了，卡罗在那里写得就像一位小说家。他将自己的经历与摩西的经历联系在一起，揭示了这一点，这真的，我的意思是，这是很好的故事写作。
Where you're like, you know that his relationship with Paul, because we've talked about it, and you know that Paul to Robert Moses is failure to success. Like, for Robert Moses to now sound like Paul Moses is such an indicator of how far he's fallen and how hopeless he is at this moment. I think it's such a beautiful passage. Robert Carrow's a great writer.
你会觉得，你知道他与保罗的关系，因为我们讨论过，而且你知道对罗伯特·摩西来说，保罗代表着从成功走向失败。所以，罗伯特·摩西现在听起来像保罗·摩西，这充分说明了他跌落得有多深，此时的他有多么绝望。我认为这是一个非常优美的段落。罗伯特·卡罗是一位伟大的作家。
I hate to, that's the conclusion I'm coming to at the very end of the book, I wasn't so sure. Now I'm on board with his writing. But what's interesting and maybe what's the source of that melancholy is that he still has these ideas. This is the time period where Robert Carroll visits him. Robert Moses throws a handout, and Aide puts a map in his hand,
我不想，这就是我在书的最后得出的结论，我之前不太确定。现在我完全认可他的写作了。但有趣的是，也许这种忧郁的根源在于他仍然有这些想法。这就是罗伯特·卡罗拜访他的时期。罗伯特·摩西扔出一份讲义，助手把一张地图塞进他手里，
and he starts drawing on it. He still looks at Fire Island and says, "'Shouldn't there be a highway there?' All that sort of stuff. He still had that stuff going, but he's just desperate for Ronan to tap him to do something and no one is calling him up.
他开始在上面画起来。他仍然看着火岛（Fire Island）说：“那里不应该有一条高速公路吗？”诸如此类的事情。他仍然有那些想法在运作，但他只是迫切希望罗南（Ronan）能让他做点什么，可没人给他打电话。
And he has to be so obsequious. His normal bluster, his normal sort of trying to control people with power and money, none of that stuff is there anymore. And he's just lost because he's never had to be, get something from being kind. It's like a foreign language to him. It's been 40 years since he has had, since he's been in a position of needing something from someone and not being able to bully it out of them, basically. And they, and he's,
他不得不表现得如此卑躬屈膝。他平时的虚张声势，他平时那种试图用权力和金钱控制人的方式，这些东西都不复存在了。他只是迷失了，因为他从来不需要通过表现得友善来获得什么。这对他来说就像一门外语。距离他上一次处于需要从别人那里得到什么，却无法通过霸凌手段强行索取的情况，已经过去40年了。而他，他，
I mean, he's experiencing also that I like that this chapter is called old because it's not just like fall of a Titan or something like this. He is experiencing something that all of us will probably experience at some point, just with a greater degree of deservedness maybe. Yeah. That of like he's being cut out of things like the people at the MTA who used to work for him and now don't, they have learned to not tell him what's going on at the MTA because he'll just send Ronan a memo about how he doesn't like it and Ronan will get annoyed. So he is being more and more cut out of even knowing what's going on.
我的意思是，他也在经历——我喜欢这一章被称为“老去”，因为它不仅仅是关于“泰坦的陨落”之类的。他正在经历我们所有人可能在某个时刻都会经历的事情，只是可能应得的程度更高一些。是的。那种被排除在事务之外的感觉，比如那些曾经为他工作、现在不再为他工作的MTA员工，他们已经学会了不告诉他MTA正在发生什么，因为他只会给罗南发备忘录，说他不喜欢这样，而罗南会感到恼火。所以他越来越被排除在了解正在发生的事情之外。
He wants to build that sound crossing bridge, the bridge that got Carol involved in this story in the first place. And it keeps being delayed year after year for various reasons. And it eventually dawns on Moses. Rockefeller does want to build that bridge. He does not want Moses to build it. And they are waiting for him to either shuffle off into retirement or die, but his time is over and there's nothing you do about it.
他想建造那座海峡大桥，就是那座让卡罗最初参与到这个故事中的桥。由于各种原因，它年复一年地被推迟。摩西终于意识到，洛克菲勒（Rockefeller）确实想建那座桥。他只是不想让摩西来建。他们都在等他要么退休，要么死去，但他的时代已经结束了，对此你无能为力。
And he starts pleading with his old power broker allies, like the union leaders, hey, can you get me something? Can you put in a word to tell them to get me something? And the union leaders feel it's pathetic that he's coming to beg them for things. This used to be the guy who commanded and now he's begging. And they're like, all right, we'll try. And they lobby to try to get him control some projects, but it doesn't work. Nobody wants him and nobody needs him because he doesn't have the power.
他开始恳求他那些老权势盟友，比如工会领袖，嘿，你能帮我弄点什么吗？你能帮我说句话，让他们给我安排点事做吗？工会领袖们觉得他来乞求他们做事很可怜。这曾经是一个发号施令的人，现在却在乞求。他们说，好吧，我们会试试。他们游说试图让他控制一些项目，但没用。没人想要他，也没人需要他，因为他没有权力了。
It was not just his ability or his brilliance or his charisma that got him that success. It was his ability to build power. And once he has it, he's easy to dismiss. And he's stuck just kind of publicly praising Ronan whenever he can, trying to get on his good side. And there's this one detail Kara has where when he would launch into monologues at parties,
让他获得成功的不仅仅是他的能力、才华或魅力。而是他建立权力的能力。一旦他失去了权力，他就很容易被解雇。他只能在公开场合尽可能地赞美罗南，试图讨好他。卡罗有一个细节，当他在聚会上发表长篇大论时，
because this is the 60s, even 81 year old people are still going to parties. Like everyone went to parties in the 60s. When he launched into monologues about his accomplishments, people used to sit up and listen because they had to. And now people are bored and they show him that they're bored. They don't want to listen to him anymore.
因为那是60年代，即使是81岁的人也还在参加聚会。就像60年代每个人都去参加聚会一样。当他开始发表关于他成就的长篇大论时，人们过去常常坐直了听，因为他们不得不听。而现在人们感到厌烦，他们表现出他们很厌烦。他们不想再听他说了。
And for a guy who thrilled to building and thrilled to the adulation of others to have both of those taken away from him when he feels he still has so much to offer is really, I mean, you can sympathize with it without feeling it's really, without, well, seeing that it's totally earned and probably better. It's just, yeah, it's just and better for the world
对于一个以建设为乐、以他人的奉承为乐的人来说，当他觉得还有很多东西可以贡献时，这两样东西都被剥夺了，这真的，我的意思是，你可以在不觉得这完全是应得的、甚至可能更好的情况下同情他。这只是，是的，这只是，而且对世界来说更好，
that he not have power, but still, like, you witness it and you're like, you can still empathize with that type of feeling or sympathize at least, maybe not sympathize, maybe empathize, maybe you feel it a little bit. Yeah, empathize without sympathizing, yeah. And he's 81 years old and he spends a lot of his time reading. So at this part of the chapter, I'm like, what a dream.
他不拥有权力，但即便如此，当你目睹这一切时，你仍然可以对那种感觉产生共鸣或同情，也许不是同情，也许是共情，也许你多少能感受到一点。是的，共情而不产生同情，是的。他81岁了，花了很多时间阅读。所以在这章的这一部分，我想，真是个梦想。
Yeah, exactly. Like he's living in paradise, he's just reading three books a day, sounds fantastic. No one needs him for anything. One of the things that Carol gets into here, which I found pretty fascinating, is that the one thing that really, A, he never took to,
是的，没错。就像他生活在天堂里，每天只读三本书，听起来太棒了。没人需要他做任何事。卡罗在这里深入探讨的一件事，我觉得非常迷人，那就是他真正，A，从未涉足，
and B, he was kind of a failure at, was the public housing stuff. And so he comes up to this kind of unified public housing program, where you would, this is extremely genius and novel, why don't you build on land that isn't occupied by a bunch of people and throwing them out.
而且B，他在其中有点失败的事情，就是公共住房项目。所以他提出了这种统一的公共住房计划，你会，这非常有天才和新颖，为什么不在没有被一群人占据的土地上建造，然后把他们赶走呢。
And then you build that and you fill that up and then you take another area where those people have been moved out of or another vacant area and then you fill that up. So you create housing without destroying people's lives. And this is of course is like exhibited as some kind of genius move, but maybe it is for someone who doesn't feel for people. Yeah, well at the very least that he has a plan now,
然后你建造那个，填满它，然后你再找另一个那些人已经被迁出的区域或者另一个空置区域，然后你填满它。所以你创造了住房而没有破坏人们的生活。这当然被展示为某种天才之举，但对于一个不为他人着想的人来说，也许确实如此。是的，至少他现在有一个计划了，
whereas before he was too busy to ever think about it. And Carol points out the flaws in the plan, like there's no consideration of how much the city will have to create the services to support these areas that didn't have housing and that maybe the people that he would be moving in there don't necessarily want to live in the unused kind of distant part to the city.
而在此之前，他太忙了，根本没时间考虑这些。卡罗指出了该计划的缺陷，比如没有考虑到城市将不得不为这些原本没有住房的区域创造服务，而且他要迁入那里的人们未必想住在城市里那种未被利用的、遥远的地方。
But he feels like he has this plan now and he's excited about it, but no one is interested. He still has these dreams of finishing that road along the shore that would have his Fire Island Highway in it. Like he still dreams about this enormous park in Jamaica Bay, like that there's all this land that could still be used up for parks. He has this big map in his office
但他觉得他现在有了这个计划，他对此感到兴奋，但没人感兴趣。他仍然梦想着完成那条沿着海岸的道路，里面会有他的火岛高速公路。就像他仍然梦想着牙买加湾（Jamaica Bay）那个巨大的公园，那里还有那么多土地可以用于公园。他的办公室里有一张大地图，
that's got all the things he built on it, but also all the things he didn't get to build on them. And he just has so many dreams, and no one will ever be able to build them the way he could. Only someone would allow him to build them. For the first time, he needs someone's permission, someone's allowance to do it. And he's frustrated that there's all these problems
上面画着他建造的所有东西，但也画着他没能建造的东西。他有太多的梦想，没有人能像他那样建造它们。只有有人允许他建造。这是他第一次需要别人的许可，别人的允许才能做到。他很沮丧，因为城市里有这么多问题，
in the city, and I'm necessary, I'm the only one who can solve them, and no one's asking me to do it. And he's frustrated that there's all these problems in the city and I'm necessary, I'm the only one who can solve them, no one's asking me to do it, I just don't understand. And any attempt to rebuild his power is blocked by the mayor or the governor and he starts getting angry. And there's one point where he gets offers to write his memoirs and it's like,
而我是必要的，我是唯一能解决它们的人，却没有人要求我去做。他很沮丧，因为城市里有这么多问题，而我是必要的，我是唯一能解决它们的人，却没有人要求我去做，我只是不明白。任何重建他权力的尝试都被市长或州长阻止了，他开始变得愤怒。有一次他收到写回忆录的邀请，他心想，
uh, I can't, my life is built on secrets, like I can't write my memoirs. So he puts out a book called Public Works, a Dangerous Trade, which I think is a very funny title. And it's a 952 page book that mostly collects speeches and articles and letters. Like it's, Kara first of all does a non book. That's brutal.
呃，我不能，我的生活建立在秘密之上，我不能写回忆录。所以他出版了一本名为《公共工程，一项危险的行业》（Public Works, a Dangerous Trade）的书，我觉得这个标题非常有趣。这是一本952页的书，主要收集了演讲、文章和信件。就像它是，卡罗首先做了一本“非书”。这太残酷了。
Kara's book is longer than that book, but it's full of things. It's full of stuff. You know, it's full of actual information, but it's brutal to be like, yeah, he released a non-book, but that title, Public Works, a Dangerous Trade, is really funny. It is so good.
卡罗的书比那本书还长，但它充满了内容。它充满了东西。你知道，它充满了实际的信息，但被称为“他发布了一本非书”太残酷了，但那个标题《公共工程，一项危险的行业》真的很有趣。它太棒了。
And he's so restless. This is the guy whose whole life was about getting things done, and now he is literally incapable of getting things done. And the only trappings of power he still has is the guys who used to work with him, who are still loyal to him, still treat him like a big man. George Spargo, who Moses makes up with, they keep their distance a little bit,
他太不安分了。这是一个一生都在致力于完成事情的人，而现在他实际上无法完成任何事情。他唯一还拥有的权力外衣就是那些曾经与他共事的人，他们仍然忠于他，仍然像对待大人物一样对待他。乔治·斯帕戈（George Spargo），摩西与他重归于好，他们保持了一点距离，
even though he's still around. But at park facilities for a long time, they still treat him like an important person because the people running the parks came up under Moses for a certain amount of time. And there's this one, another one of these Caro-specific scenarios that I really like. When the author drove, let's talk about Moses, when the author drove him down to meet Adam Carp, Moses told him to park in an area marked No Thoreau Fair. After he left, the author was sitting there jotting down notes when a Long Island State Park Commission patrolman loomed in his window.
尽管他还在身边。但在公园设施方面，很长一段时间里，他们仍然把他当作重要人物，因为管理公园的人在摩西手下工作过一段时间。这里有另一个我非常喜欢的卡罗式的场景。当作者开车，我们谈谈摩西，当作者开车送他去见亚当·卡普（Adam Carp）时，摩西告诉他停在一个标有“禁止通行”的区域。他离开后，作者坐在那里记笔记，这时一名长岛州立公园委员会的巡警出现在他的车窗前。
Don't you see the sign? He asked with the usual LISPC arrogance. Well, you see, I drove Mr. Moses down, the author began. Oh, the cop said, straightening, and started to walk away without a word. Then he returned. Thanks for telling me, he said. I'd be out of work and my children would be starving.
“你没看到那个标志吗？”他带着长岛州立公园委员会（LISPC）惯有的傲慢问道。“嗯，你看，我送摩西先生过来，”作者开始解释。“哦，”警察挺直了身子说，一言不发地走开了。然后他又回来了。“谢谢你告诉我，”他说。“不然我就失业了，我的孩子们会挨饿的。”
So there's still this, the one thing that's outlasted him is fear, I guess, which stinks. Yeah, for real. Moses is now the boogeyman you tell Long Island State patrolman, State Parks patrolman, to get them to let you park somewhere. So, let me park here, Moses is gonna come and take your children away.
所以仍然存在这种，唯一比他更持久的东西是恐惧，我想，这真糟糕。是的，真的。摩西现在成了你告诉长岛州立公园巡警的“妖怪”，让他们让你停在某个地方。所以，让我停在这里，摩西会来把你的孩子带走。
That's, it's not a great thing. And during this period of time, after that flurry of being named after things right when he left his state posts, it's kind of gone fallow. There's not a big Robert Moses State Park in Flushing Meadows. There is a dedication because the plaza
这，这可不是什么好事。在这段时间里，在他离开州政府职位后被以各种事物命名的一阵狂热之后，一切都变得荒芜了。法拉盛草原公园（Flushing Meadows）里没有一个巨大的罗伯特·摩西州立公园。有一个落成典礼，因为那个
that he kind of cleared for Fordham gets named after him, but it feels kind of hollow because that's a private institution, you know? That doesn't, it just- It's like a plaza on a college campus. It's not as exciting as like a major park that people are gonna use. I mean, and I don't know when they renamed
他为福特汉姆大学（Fordham）清理出来的广场以他的名字命名，但这感觉有点空洞，因为那是一个私立机构，你知道吗？那并不——这就像大学校园里的一个广场。它不像人们会使用的大型公园那样令人兴奋。我的意思是，我不知道他们什么时候重命名了
Fire Island Robert Moses State Park. That must've been years later, I think. I should have looked that up ahead of time, but I didn't. But you're right, he's a, there's this kind of trickling out of respect for him. Like in the late 60s and early 70s, he's still giving speeches and getting awards. By 1972, nobody really cares about him anymore. And they have a ceremony for the opening of a part of Lincoln Center that he fought for. And he's like not even part of the ceremony. Like there's no
火岛罗伯特·摩西州立公园。我想那一定是多年以后的事了。我本应该提前查一下，但我没查。但你是对的，他是一个，对他的尊重正在一点点流失。比如在60年代末和70年代初，他还在发表演讲和获得奖项。到了1972年，真的没人再关心他了。他们为他争取来的林肯中心（Lincoln Center）的一部分举行了开幕仪式。他甚至没有参加仪式。就像没有
place for him, invited place for him on the dais. Like he feels very insulted. And Lindsay, who's still mayor, is using Moses' name as like this talisman of everything that was wrong with the city before Lindsay became mayor. Often, as Caro points out, because Caro can't help but get a dig in it, Lindsay, using it incorrectly, inaccurately. Like he's blaming Moses for things that were not Moses' problem.
他的位置，没有邀请他在主席台上。他感到非常受侮辱。而仍然担任市长的林赛（Lindsay），正在把摩西的名字当作林赛成为市长之前城市所有问题的“护身符”。正如卡罗指出的那样，因为卡罗忍不住要挖苦一下，林赛使用得不正确、不准确。他把摩西不该负责的事情归咎于摩西。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, which is amazing when you think about this book, you know, pretty much dedicated to blaming Moses for most things, you know? Yeah. But like still, pretty much dedicated to blaming Moses for most things. But still, to his credit, Caro is like, but you can't blame him for the wrong things. You have to get it right. It's not the sort of direction of the sentiment
是的，是的，是的。我的意思是，当你想到这本书时，这很神奇，你知道，几乎致力于把大多数事情归咎于摩西，你知道吗？是的。但即便如此，几乎致力于把大多数事情归咎于摩西。但即便如此，值得称赞的是，卡罗说，但你不能把错误的事情归咎于他。你必须弄清楚。这并不是那种情绪的方向
that he has a problem with when it comes to Lindsay. He just has a problem with its inaccuracy, which is another sort of speaks to how great Robert Caro is. Yeah, he's like, we gotta dislike him for the right reasons. I don't wanna just dislike him. We gotta blame him for the right things. And this is when Moses has this very strange,
他在林赛身上有问题。他只是对它的不准确性有意见，这又说明了罗伯特·卡罗有多伟大。是的，他就像是，我们必须以正确的理由不喜欢他。我不想只是不喜欢他。我们必须把正确的事情归咎于他。这就是摩西有这种非常奇怪的、
brief epilogue to his like, not quite afterlife because he's still alive, but he has nothing to do. And he gets hired by WPIX when I was growing up, they were New York's movie station. Eventually they became part of the, I guess they're part of the CW now. But he briefly hosts a TV discussion show called New York Close-Up, which I think is so strange
短暂的尾声，对他来说，不是完全的来世，因为他还活着，但他无事可做。他被WPIX聘用，我成长过程中，他们是纽约的电影频道。最终他们成为了，我想他们现在是CW的一部分了。但他短暂地主持了一个名为《纽约特写》（New York Close-Up）的电视讨论节目，我觉得这太奇怪了，
that someone was like, 81 year old Robert Moses, you were the lead construction guy in all the city and state. Why don't you host a TV interview, a local TV interview show, but he won't wear his hearing aids so he can't hear his guests to where they're taping and he just lectures at the camera mostly,
有人会说，81岁的罗伯特·摩西，你是城市和州里主要的建筑负责人。为什么不主持一个电视采访，一个本地电视采访节目呢？但他不戴助听器，所以他听不到客人的声音，他们录制的时候，他大多只是对着镜头讲课，
and they cancel after 20 episodes, and I gotta find an episode of this. I think there might be some on YouTube. There's a few on YouTube. I was thinking, I was like, next season on the Power Broker Breakdown, we cover every episode of New York Close-Up. This is the 99% invisible Close-Up on New York Close-Up.
他们在20集后取消了节目，我得找一集来看看。我想YouTube上可能有一些。YouTube上有几集。我当时想，我想，下一季的《权力掮客解析》（Power Broker Breakdown），我们涵盖《纽约特写》的每一集。这是99%隐形（99% Invisible）对《纽约特写》的特写。
We're covering every episode of New York Close-Up, and us watching it. So they're talking about local issues that we don't understand at all. We don't know any of the names they're using. But I love the idea of Robert Moses as like a talk show host. I find that very, it's just a strange thing for him to be doing.
我们要涵盖《纽约特写》的每一集，我们还要看它。所以他们谈论的是我们完全不理解的本地问题。我们不知道他们使用的任何名字。但我喜欢罗伯特·摩西作为脱口秀主持人的想法。我觉得这非常，这对他来说是一件奇怪的事情。
It's amazing to imagine like a more checked out Charlie Rose, you know, kind of. Yes. Just sitting there in a dark room. And he's just looking for things to do with this, with his mind. It's not even the time it's this mind that, and so strangers that he would not have made time before, before they're like, Hey, we have an idea for a project in another country. Will you talk to us? He's like, yeah, sure.
想象一个更心不在焉的查理·罗斯（Charlie Rose），你知道，那种感觉。是的。只是坐在一个黑暗的房间里。他只是在寻找能用他的头脑做的事情。这甚至不是时间，而是这个头脑，所以陌生人，他以前不会花时间，在他们说，嘿，我们有一个在另一个国家的项目想法。你会和我们谈谈吗？他会说，是的，当然。
Of course, of course. And he gets really into it. Rockefeller eventually leaves office to run for president. He doesn't, he doesn't win. He there was no president Rockefeller. And the new governor, he offers Moses a post as a housing advisor, which he turns down. And that's when the Moses men, they're dying of old age around him. It's amazing.
当然，当然。他真的很投入。洛克菲勒最终离职去竞选总统。他没有，他没有赢。没有洛克菲勒总统。新任州长，他提供给摩西一个住房顾问的职位，他拒绝了。那就是摩西的人，他们在他身边因年老而死去。这太神奇了。
Sid Shapiro, he still runs the Long Island State Park Commission. He's still devoted to Moses. He makes sure that Moses is treated with reverence at the facilities that the parks commission patrolmen are still afraid of him. But when he retires, he was placed by someone from the National Park Service who doesn't care about Moses. And Moses loses his corner table at Jones Beach. Guy Lombardo stops introducing him at the Marine Theater and Shapiro dies in 1972.
西德·夏皮罗（Sid Shapiro），他仍然管理着长岛州立公园委员会。他仍然忠于摩西。他确保摩西在设施中受到尊敬，公园委员会的巡警仍然害怕他。但当他退休时，他被国家公园管理局（National Park Service）的人取代，那个人根本不在乎摩西。摩西失去了他在琼斯海滩（Jones Beach）的专属餐桌。盖伊·隆巴多（Guy Lombardo）不再在海洋剧院（Marine Theater）介绍他，夏皮罗于1972年去世。
And Moses' most loyal aide has just gone for good. You know, he's died. And that in the notes later on, Carroll makes it clear that Sid Shapiro had said, don't quote me on any of these things until I die. I don't think realizing that he was going to die before the book came out. So just use it all of it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's amazing. There's just the little last little bit about, you know, the fact that Moses, you know, doesn't have a much of a family legacy, you know, like in a number of he has two daughters. This is a weird thing about Carol here, I don't know,
摩西最忠诚的助手就这样永远离开了。你知道，他去世了。在后来的笔记中，卡罗明确表示，西德·夏皮罗曾说，在我死之前不要引用我的任何话。我想他没意识到他会在书出版前去世。所以就用吧，全部用上。是的。是的。是的。这太神奇了。关于摩西，你知道，没有多少家庭遗产，你知道，比如他有两个女儿。这是卡罗在这里的一个奇怪之处，我不知道，
is that like, he mentions about Moses' grandsons, but he really doesn't get into Moses' granddaughter, or like, it's such a, it feels like an old fashioned thing of like, that there's no one to carry on Moses' kind of like lineage, you know, his line. Yeah, and when I read it, I kind of wonder, is this a window into Carol, a window into the patriarchy as a whole,
是这样的，他提到了摩西的孙子们，但他真的没有深入探讨摩西的孙女，或者说，这感觉像是一种老派的事情，就是没有人来继承摩西的那种血统，你知道，他的后代。是的，当我读到它时，我有点怀疑，这是了解卡罗的一个窗口，了解整个父权制的一个窗口，
or is he putting on the sort of like, these people with his progeny aren't as important to Moses? You know, he's sort of saying that, you know, like it really requires some kind of male heir to be important to Moses. I kind of think it's that, but it is sort of, it's odd,
还是他表现出那种，这些人作为他的后代对摩西来说不那么重要？你知道，他是在说，你知道，这确实需要某种男性继承人对摩西来说才重要。我有点认为就是这样，但这确实有点，很奇怪，
you know, what gets sort of paid attention to and what doesn't here. Well, I think there's also, I think it, yeah, that's true. It would make more sense to me if he was covering all of his grandchildren or none of his grandchildren, but Caro, I think in keeping with this theme of old, kind of like the disappointments of his old age, that Moses has a couple of grandsons. One of them is born with mental disabilities. That's the one who's named for him. He has one who becomes a banker, and Moses just seems to not be interested in him.
你知道，什么得到了关注，什么没有。嗯，我认为还有，我认为它，是的，那是真的。如果他涵盖了他所有的孙辈或者一个都不涵盖，对我来说会更有意义，但卡罗，我认为与“老去”这个主题保持一致，就像他晚年的失望一样，摩西有几个孙子。其中一个出生时有精神障碍。那个是以他的名字命名的。他有一个成为了银行家，摩西似乎对他不感兴趣。
And the third grandson is very charming, but he has bad grades. And Carol compares him to Moses' granddaughter, Caroline, who gets very good grades. And that's the only mention of Caroline that we get. Like it's, I'm like, well, let's hear about her. She seems accomplished. But Moses dotes on this grandson.
第三个孙子非常迷人，但他成绩不好。卡罗把他和摩西的孙女卡罗琳（Caroline）进行了比较，她的成绩非常好。那是我们得到的唯一关于卡罗琳的提及。就像是，我想，好吧，让我们听听关于她的事。她看起来很有成就。但摩西溺爱这个孙子。
And when his grades turn around in college, he's really proud of him that this is maybe the person he's looking to, not even necessarily to continue his tradition of power brokering, but just that brings life to him in his old age. And then very tragically, this grandson dies in 1968 at the age of 21 in a car accident. And Caro, thankfully, is too good a writer to
当他在大学里成绩好转时，他真的为他感到骄傲，这也许是他所期待的人，甚至不一定是继续他的权力掮客传统，只是他在晚年给他带来了生命力。然后非常悲惨的是，这个孙子在1968年以21岁的年纪死于车祸。而卡罗，谢天谢地，是一位太好的作家，没有
make a big deal out of, you know, live by the car, die by the car. You know how ironic it is that that it was a road accident that that took the life of his beloved grandson. But there's this feeling of this... I think he brings it up to really hit home the idea that Moses has done all these things, but in a real way, he is leaving nothing behind him for himself or feels like he has nothing left, you know, and that even the thing that brings him joy in his old age is taken from him just by life, you know. That's my guess anyway. But it's a, it sometimes feels, this is one of the few real criticisms I'll make about Charo in some ways, is that when he is that when he does talk about Moses' family,
大做文章，你知道，死于车祸。你知道他心爱的孙子死于道路事故是多么讽刺。但有一种感觉……我认为他提出这一点是为了真正打动人们的想法，即摩西做了所有这些事情，但在现实中，他没有为自己留下任何东西，或者觉得他一无所有，你知道，甚至他在晚年给他带来快乐的东西也被生活夺走了，你知道。这是我的猜测。但这，有时感觉，这是我将对卡罗提出的一些真正的批评之一，就是当他谈到摩西的家庭时，
if there's not a way to tie it directly to Moses' work, it often feels like a little bit of a appendage that doesn't need to be there. And something that Caro is clearly not as interested in. Yeah, there are often the sections of the family are little end sections of other chapters where you go like the whole chapter's about something else, kind of like the one earlier in this episode where whole chapters about something else
如果没有办法直接把它与摩西的工作联系起来，它通常感觉像是一个不需要在那里的附属品。而且卡罗显然对它不那么感兴趣。是的，家庭的部分通常是其他章节的小结尾部分，你会觉得整章都在讲别的事情，有点像这一集中早些时候的那一章，整章都在讲别的事情，
and the death of Mary is handled in a few pages. That's why the one about Paul, the two brothers chapters stands out so greatly in the book. I think why it's really notable is to spend this whole chapter on the real relationship between these two men in a full fleshed out way. And also why this chapter is also kind of, it has its details about civic life,
而玛丽（Mary）的去世只用了几页纸处理。这就是为什么关于保罗的那两兄弟章节在书中如此突出。我认为为什么它非常值得注意，是因为花整章时间以一种完整的方式探讨这两个男人之间的真实关系。而且为什么这一章也算是，它有关于公民生活的细节，
but mostly it's about the personal sort of, I don't know, this sort of diminishment of the man, Robert Moses, over the course of the last few years. I mean, he's not just a sad sack. He's still mean as hell to his secretaries, his chauffeur. You know, he takes it out on them. The tone of Mayor Lindsey is beginning to sort of catch on in the world,
但主要是关于个人的，我不知道，这种罗伯特·摩西这个人在过去几年里的衰落。我的意思是，他不仅仅是一个悲伤的家伙。他对他的秘书、他的司机依然刻薄得要命。你知道，他把气撒在他们身上。林赛市长的基调开始在世界上流行起来，
and so he's beginning to be thought of as the person who made things bad in New York, and Robert Moses is alive and aware enough to witness some of that turn against him. Yes, he knows, I think, by this point, I mean, certainly does after the book comes out, but he knows, I think, by this point, or has an inkling that this name
所以他开始被认为是那个让纽约变得糟糕的人，而罗伯特·摩西活着并且意识到足以见证一些针对他的转变。是的，我想他到了这个时候，我的意思是，在书出版后肯定知道，但他到了这个时候，或者有一种预感，这个名字
that for so much of his life has meant achievement and power and respect. That name is now going to mean not incompetence exactly, but like cruelty, authoritarian domination, waste. His name is now standing for things that he never thought it was going to. And he's aware enough to know that and he feels it very greatly. And it feels like Carol is suggesting this is what is kind of obsessing him towards the end of his life and the book does not end with his death because this book came out before he died. He would live for another number of years but the very end of the book I think we
在他生命中大部分时间里意味着成就、权力和尊重。那个名字现在意味着，不完全是无能，而是残酷、威权统治、浪费。他的名字现在代表了他从未想过会代表的东西。他意识到这一点，并且感觉非常强烈。感觉卡罗是在暗示这就是他在生命尽头所痴迷的东西，而且这本书并没有以他的死亡结束，因为这本书在他去世前就出版了。他还会再活几年，但书的最后，我想我们
should read because it sums up so much about what's going on and it's so again, it's so beautifully written. He says, in private his conversation dwelt more and more on a single theme, the ingratitude of the public toward great men. And once, invited by the Church to speak at the dedication in Flushing Meadows Park of the Excedra, a huge marble bench for reflection donated by the Roman Catholic Diocese of New York, he gave vent to his feeling in public. Turning to a high Church official who was also an old friend, his voice booming out over the public address system, he said,
应该读一下，因为它总结了正在发生的事情，而且它再次，写得太美了。他说，在私下里，他的谈话越来越多地围绕一个主题，即公众对伟人的忘恩负义。有一次，应教会邀请，在法拉盛草原公园为“埃克塞德拉”（Excedra）落成典礼致辞，这是一个由纽约罗马天主教教区捐赠的巨大的大理石反思长椅，他在公开场合发泄了自己的情绪。转向一位也是老朋友的高级教会官员，他的声音在公共广播系统中轰鸣，他说，
Someday let us sit on this bench and reflect on the gratitude of man. Down in the audience, the ministers of the Empire of Moses glanced at one another and nodded their heads. RM was right as usual, they whispered. Couldn't people see what he had done? Why weren't they grateful? Boom. Boom. Like that, the whole thing, like that his, he has done so much to hurt so many, so many people. And the last thought that Carol leaves us with, this thought that's obsessing him is, or that we're led to believe is, why weren't they grateful? Why don't they see what they've done and understand it? I did so much for you. And now you're going to think of me as the villain, but I was the hero.
“有一天，让我们坐在这张长椅上，反思人类的感恩之心。”在观众席中，摩西帝国的部长们面面相觑，点了点头。RM一如既往地是对的，他们低声说。人们难道看不出他做了什么吗？为什么他们不感恩？轰。轰。就像那样，整件事，就像他的，他做了那么多伤害那么多人的事。而卡罗留给我们的最后一个想法，这个让他痴迷的想法，或者我们被引导去相信的想法是，为什么他们不感恩？为什么他们不明白他们做了什么并理解它？我为你做了那么多。而现在你要把我当作反派，但我才是英雄。
That, that, that fundamental need that all humans have to feel like they are the hero in the story of, I mean, their lives and also, in most cases of New York City, and to know that this is not gonna be the way that he is remembered, most likely. And why not? Didn't I do so much for you? It's such a, what I like is that it's,
那，那，那种所有人类都有的基本需求，即感觉自己是故事中的英雄，我的意思是，他们的人生，在大多数情况下也是纽约市的故事，并且知道这很可能不会是他被记住的方式。为什么不呢？我难道没有为你做那么多吗？这真是，我喜欢的是，它是，
Caro has made me feel bad for Moses all through this chapter, partly because it's a thing we're all gonna go through if we're lucky of getting older and dealing with age. But then at the very end, he puts that in, and I'm like, come on, Moses, come on. Like, this is, like he, that twist at the end of like, without saying it outright, kind of turning you, at least when I'm reading it, turning me around on him
卡罗让我在这一章里一直为摩西感到难过，部分原因是因为如果我们幸运的话，我们所有人都会经历变老和应对年龄的问题。但最后，他加入了这一点，我就想，得了吧，摩西，得了吧。就像这个，就像他，那个结尾的转折，没有直接说出来，有点让你，至少当我读它时，让我对他
all of a sudden again, and it's, I think it's just masterful, but also Roman, what do you think he means by all that? You know, what is he saying? Why aren't they grateful? Why aren't they grateful? I mean, it's sort of, I mean, he sort of states it so well. It's such a great moment where he really just was this man who had no ability to change.
突然又转过弯来，而且，我认为这只是大师级的，但还有罗曼（Roman），你认为他说的这一切是什么意思？你知道，他在说什么？为什么他们不感恩？为什么他们不感恩？我的意思是，这有点，我的意思是，他陈述得太好了。这是一个伟大的时刻，他真的只是这个无法改变的男人。
He had the same arrogance that a lot of people that you witness in today's world. And he mentions, Carol mentions this with Rockefeller, it's like, if I want it, then it is good. That's the basis of the way his mind works. You know what I mean? Coming as an idea from me means that it is good for everyone and they should just be thankful that I'm here in the world
他有着今天世界上许多人所表现出的同样的傲慢。他提到，卡罗提到洛克菲勒，就像是，如果我想要它，那么它就是好的。这就是他思维方式的基础。你知道我的意思吗？作为一个来自我的想法意味着它对每个人都有好处，他们应该只是感激我来到这个世界上
to make it happen, you know? And he can't see the world any other different way. Like he's that subsistic, he's really that arrogant. It's the source of his power, but it's also the source of why this moment is so terrible for him. Like it reminds me, strangely, of the movie Jacob's Ladder. I-
让它发生，你知道吗？他无法以任何其他不同的方式看待世界。就像他是那么的唯我论，他真的那么傲慢。这是他权力的来源，但也是这一刻对他来说如此可怕的来源。就像它奇怪地让我想起了电影《异世浮生》（Jacob's Ladder）。我——
All right, okay, let's unpack this because I'm not seeing it right off the top of my head, yeah? Well, there's this- Tim Robbins, he's going through kind of like a hellish New York, he's going through- He's going through a hellish New York,
好吧，好吧，让我们来剖析一下，因为我没有一眼就看出来，是吗？嗯，有这个——蒂姆·罗宾斯（Tim Robbins），他正在经历一种地狱般的纽约，他正在经历——他正在经历一种地狱般的纽约，
and it turns out, spoiler alert, for Jacob's Ladder, like he died in- This movie's like 35 years old, like you should have seen it 35 years old. He died in Vietnam and his life that's happening afterward is all just A dream that's happening kind of an instant as he's dying. It's your classic occurrence at El Creek Bridge and so one of the things that that is happening is is it so What's his name? The chiropractor. He's a, he's a famous character actor.
结果发现，剧透警告，对于《异世浮生》，就像他死在——这部电影大概有35年了，你应该看过这部35年的电影了。他死在越南，他之后发生的生活都只是一个梦，在他临死时瞬间发生。这是你经典的《鹰溪桥之战》（Occurrence at Owl Creek Bridge），所以正在发生的事情之一是，他叫什么名字？那个脊椎按摩师。他是一个，他是一个著名的性格演员。
I yellow, uh, Danny, I L Danny Aiello. So that's okay. Well, anyway, so I'm trying to remember who's been so long since I saw Jacob's ladder. You got me on this one, Roman. Look, I pretend to know a lot about movies, but I don't remember. He's this sort of alternative care therapist and he's talking to him about the fact that like he started seeing nightmares.
我，呃，丹尼，呃，丹尼·艾洛（Danny Aiello）。所以没关系。好吧，无论如何，所以我正试图记住谁，因为我太久没看《异世浮生》了。你难住我了，罗曼。看，我假装对电影了解很多，但我记不住。他是那种另类护理治疗师，他正在和他谈论他开始看到噩梦的事实。
He's starting to see his world ripped apart because he's dying and he doesn't know it. So anyway, so this is gonna be a long ass aside. I don't know why we're doing it at the end of this. But let me just finish with, but one of the things that Danny Aiello says to him is like when you're trying to hold on and you have these parts of your life ripped away from you, those people ripping away from you are demons
他开始看到他的世界被撕裂，因为他快死了，而他自己不知道。所以无论如何，这会是一个很长的题外话。我不知道为什么我们在最后做这个。但让我以，但丹尼·艾洛对他说的其中一件事是，当你试图坚持，而你生命中的这些部分被从你身边撕裂时，那些从你身边撕裂的人是恶魔，
and they are taking chunks out of who you are. But if you accept that you're moving on, you realize that they're actually angels freeing you from the burden of your life. And it sticks with me, this idea of like, gracefully going, transitioning into a different stage in your life and realizing that having a lot of these things removed from you are actually like,
他们正在从你的本质中夺走碎片。但如果你接受你正在继续前进，你会意识到他们实际上是天使，把你从生活的重担中解放出来。它一直萦绕在我心头，这种想法，比如优雅地离开，过渡到你生命中的不同阶段，并意识到很多这些东西被移除实际上就像，
it's actually good if you just have a different mindset. But like there's nothing about Robert Moses' character that allows him to go gracefully between stages. He is one person, he's been one person the whole time. And so when these things are taken away from him, they just are these demons and enemies, they rip him down, they bring him down to nothing. And that is a prison of his own making.
如果你有不同的心态，这实际上是好的。但罗伯特·摩西的性格中没有任何东西允许他在阶段之间优雅地过渡。他是一个人，他一直是一个人。所以当这些东西被从他身边夺走时，它们只是这些恶魔和敌人，它们撕裂他，把它们带到一无所有。而那是他自己造成的监狱。
Like you don't have to exist that way. Yeah, his life is so built around doing things and getting things done and not about being a person or, you know, existing in a way. Like it's a, he feels like he is someone who has no self other than to be in constant motion. And instead of accepting a state of rest at the end of his life, instead he's like, what am I? What am I if I'm not doing things? What am I? And it speaks to, I think, the questions that he probably put down when he left college.
就像你不必那样存在。是的，他的生活是如此建立在做事情和完成事情上，而不是关于成为一个人，或者，你知道，以某种方式存在。就像它是一个，他觉得他是一个除了不断运动之外没有自我的人。而不是在他生命的尽头接受休息的状态，相反，他就像，我是什么？如果我不做事情，我是什么？我是什么？它说明了，我想，他离开大学时可能写下的问题。
Like, when he was a college poet, I'm sure he was pretty introspective at times about things. And then he left college and he put down those questions and didn't pick them up again for the rest of his life. Well, that is the end of the book. I don't know if it should have ended with a long metaphor with Jacob's Ladder, the 1990s movie by Id, it was the only way it could have ended ramen. I will say, we don't want to end exactly with it,
就像，当他是一名大学诗人时，我相信他有时对事情很内省。然后他离开了大学，放下了那些问题，余生再也没有捡起来。好吧，这就是书的结尾。我不知道它是否应该以一个关于《异世浮生》的长隐喻结束，那部1990年的电影，这是它唯一能结束的方式，罗曼。我会说，我们不想完全以它结束，
I will say we're not going to cover this in detail, but if you have a physical copy of the book, and not this newfangled e-book that I don't know if I trust completely, I like paper myself, then you have his acknowledgements, which he calls debts, and then a section called a note on sources, and then his bibliography note section. And for the dedicated caro file, there's some really interesting stuff in there.
我会说我们不会详细介绍这一点，但如果你有这本书的实体版，而不是我不确定是否完全信任的这种新奇电子书，我个人喜欢纸质书，那么你有他的致谢，他称之为“债务”，然后是一个名为“来源说明”的部分，然后是他的参考书目说明部分。对于忠实的卡罗迷来说，里面有一些非常有趣的东西。
We're not going to go through it in general, but just kind of you get touches of how he actually put this book together. He goes out of his way to thank his wife Ina and his editor Robert Gottlieb, and he mentions that 522 interviews were conducted for this book, some of multiple interviews are the same people, but there's just this, these little hints throughout this section of how he found the things that he found for this, what he and Ina looked through and who they talked to and how hard it was. And he mentions at one point that he went into this secret Trierboro file collection, that he was the first person from the general public ever to see.
我们不会通篇细讲，但你可以从中窥见他是如何构建这本书的。他特意感谢了他的妻子伊娜和编辑罗伯特·戈特利布，并提到为了这本书进行了522次采访，其中有些是针对同一人的多次采访。在这一部分中，处处都有小提示，暗示他是如何找到这些资料的，他和伊娜查阅了什么，采访了谁，以及过程有多艰难。他提到有一次他进入了那个秘密的特里尔伯勒档案库，他是第一个获准进入的普通公众。
And he talks about these other archival sources that seemingly nobody but him and Ina had ever looked in before. They found W. Kingsland Macy's papers in his family's attic. And it's like 40 years of the inner workings of the New York State Republican Party, and no one had ever looked at it, it seems, before them. And one of the things that I find exciting about this book is that it's this enormous book. It's New York in a book, basically, in so many different ways. Not all of New York, but so much of it. But there's this other hidden epic lying underneath the story of this book,
他还谈到了其他一些档案来源，似乎除了他和伊娜，之前没人查阅过。他们在W·金斯兰·梅西家里的阁楼里发现了他的文件。那记录了纽约州共和党40年来的内部运作，似乎在他们之前从未有人看过。这本书让我感到兴奋的一点是，它是一本宏大的著作。从很多方面来看，它基本上就是一本关于纽约的书。虽然不是纽约的全部，但涵盖了很大一部分。然而，在这本书的故事之下，还隐藏着另一段史诗，
which is the story of the discovery of how Robert and Ina Caro learned the things they learned to be able to put this together. And we've talked about how in a paragraph about all the details of going into building a certain bridge or a certain highway overpass, there's so much research that just goes into understanding that and the work of condensing it down and synthesizing. And it feels like there's this incredible, just kind of epic tale of how this book came to be that is just kind of lurking beneath the surface of this book. And as a writer, I find almost in some ways as exciting or as thrilling to think about. And so I really think it's worth,
那就是罗伯特和伊娜·卡罗如何通过学习和探索，才得以将这一切整合在一起的故事。我们之前谈到过，在描述建造某座桥梁或高速公路立交桥的细节段落中，为了理解这些内容并将其浓缩和综合，需要投入大量的研究。感觉在这本书的表面之下，潜藏着一段关于这本书如何诞生的不可思议的史诗。作为一名作家，我发现思考这些过程几乎同样令人兴奋和激动。所以我真的认为，
if you like this book a lot, it's worth just kind of skimming through those note sections to get these little bits and pieces of, these little hints of the process of the making of it. You don't have to sit there and read it page to page. Don't read the bibliography one page after another. That's what a person in Insane Asylum does. But I mean, I did it, but you shouldn't do it. But there's just this, there's something in there that I find very inspiring after this, ugh, this kind of like gut punch ending of this whole book,
如果你非常喜欢这本书，值得去翻阅那些注释部分，从中获取关于创作过程的点滴线索。你不必坐在那里逐页阅读。不要一页接一页地读参考书目。那是精神病院里的人才会做的事。我是说，我确实读了，但你不应该这样做。但在那里，我发现了一些非常鼓舞人心的东西，尤其是在这本书那种令人心碎的结局之后，
this experience we've been in. Something inspiring about seeing the dedication and the work that went into making this thing and the work that went into making this thing and knowing that that's possible. There's another kind of accomplishment besides building a monument out of concrete, and that is building a piece of understanding of reality out of words that can then be shared and live on to anyone who has the interest and the drive to read 1,100 pages of text. Yeah, yeah. The other thing to check out,
我们所经历的这段体验。看到为创作这本书所投入的奉献和努力，并知道这是可能的，这本身就很鼓舞人心。除了用混凝土建造纪念碑，还有另一种成就，那就是用文字构建出对现实的理解，这些理解可以被分享，并留存给任何有兴趣和动力去阅读那1100页文字的人。是的，是的。另一件值得一看的事情，
if that sort of speaks to you, is Robert Carrow's book, Working, which the first chapter or two talks a lot about his combing through the archives and being present and trying to get details and information in places where he is kind, he's allowed into, but he's not welcomed and they make it hard on him and it's a really fun narrative about all that.
如果这引起了你的共鸣，那就是罗伯特·卡罗的书《工作》（Working）。前两章谈到了他如何梳理档案，如何亲临现场，并试图在那些他被允许进入但不受欢迎、对方处处刁难的地方获取细节和信息，那是一个非常有趣的故事。
It's just a really, like this book lives with you. It's so long, you know, like we've had such an incredible year of breaking it down, but I find that I'm like, I still think about it all the time. Like I'm not ready to put it to bed. And if you're inspired, I highly recommend working. I highly recommend the Lyndon Johnson books. I think that they keep going
这本书真的会伴随你。它太长了，你知道，我们花了一整年时间来剖析它，但我发现我仍然一直在思考它。我还没准备好把它放下。如果你受到了启发，我强烈推荐《工作》。我强烈推荐林登·约翰逊系列丛书。我认为它们一直保持着
with the same really careful eye, this really empathic and interesting and humanist of a man who's a reporter. He's just very good at what he does. Robert Carr was a singular entity. So before we go, one of our interviews that we did early on in the season was with Mike Schur, who is the creator of A Good Place and creator of Parks and Rec,
同样敏锐的观察力，展现了一个作为记者的男人那种极具同理心、有趣且人文主义的视角。他非常擅长自己的工作。罗伯特·卡罗是一个独特的存在。那么在结束之前，我们在本季早期采访的嘉宾之一是迈克·舒尔，他是《善地》和《公园与游憩》的创作者，
was a writer on The Office, and was a Power Broker super fan. And part of our conversation with him, he begins to spoil the ending in too great a detail that we wanted to put in. So, so- He didn't realize that he was coming in too early to interview, to talk about the ending of the book.
曾是《办公室》的编剧，也是《权力掮客》的超级粉丝。在我们与他的谈话中，他开始剧透结局，细节多到我们不得不剪掉。所以……他没意识到他太早开始谈论书的结局了。
And he just felt like he had to talk. We couldn't stop him. We couldn't stop him. We just had to hold him back afterwards in edit. So to have one other final thought on the ending of the book and he just felt like he had to talk. We couldn't stop him. We couldn't stop him. We just had to hold him back afterwards in edit. Yeah. So to have one other final thought on the ending of The Power Broker, here's Mike Schor expanding on his thoughts. He felt like he was going to be, you know, Caesar or Nero or whoever. He was going to be a piece of history that would never be displaced, which is why the last line of the book, spoiler alert, is so beautiful.
他就是觉得非说不可。我们拦不住他。我们拦不住他。我们只能在后期剪辑时把他剪掉。所以，为了对这本书的结局有一个最后的思考，他就是觉得非说不可。我们拦不住他。我们拦不住他。我们只能在后期剪辑时把他剪掉。是的。所以，为了对《权力掮客》的结局有一个最后的思考，这里是迈克·舒尔的进一步阐述。他觉得自己会成为，你知道，凯撒或尼禄，或者其他什么人。他会成为一段永远不会被取代的历史，这就是为什么这本书的最后一行，剧透预警，是如此美丽。
After Moses has been drummed out of power and Rockefeller has accepted his resignation, which no one had ever thought to do, which is such a wonderful detail, the last line of the book is basically that Moses is in a very bad mood. The last line of the book is basically that Moses is in a very bad mood. And the last line of the book is, why weren't they grateful? He's baffled about why more people aren't sort of bowing down and like throwing laurels at his feet and thanking him for all of the amazing things that he did. And this is after 1100 pages of how he ruined everyone's life. It's such an incredible portrait of a psychosis that you by the time you get to the end of the book, you just feel like you have the complete picture of a man. It gives me chills thinking about the achievement that Caro pulled off.
在摩西被赶下台、洛克菲勒接受了他的辞职（没人想到会这样做，这是一个多么精彩的细节）之后，书的最后一行基本上是说摩西心情非常糟糕。书的最后一行基本上是说摩西心情非常糟糕。书的最后一行是：“为什么他们不感恩？”他感到困惑，为什么没有更多的人对他顶礼膜拜，向他献上桂冠，感谢他所做的那些了不起的事情。而这还是在1100页讲述他如何毁掉每个人生活的内容之后。这简直是对一种精神病态的绝妙刻画，当你读到书的结尾时，你会觉得你已经完整地了解了这个男人。想到卡罗所取得的成就，我不禁感到战栗。
And as the special guest on this final episode of the Power Broker Breakdown, we're gonna talk to Robert Caro again in studio. I don't often interview people more than once, three times as a truly rare occurrence, but I happily made an exception for Robert Caro. First time was the first episode of the show, and then earlier this fall, Elliot and I recently interviewed Mr. Caro live on stage at the New York Historical Society, which
作为《权力掮客》深度解析最后一集的特别嘉宾，我们将再次在演播室采访罗伯特·卡罗。我不常采访同一个人超过一次，三次确实是非常罕见的情况，但我很高兴为罗伯特·卡罗破例。第一次是在节目的第一集，然后今年秋天早些时候，埃利奥特和我最近在纽约历史学会的舞台上现场采访了卡罗先生，
was celebrating 50 years of the Power Broker with a special exhibit. The exhibit was curated from Mr. Caro's archives and tells the story of the Power Broker from beginning to end. You can hear a little bit more about the exhibit, as well as our conversation with Mr. Caro at the Society, on a recent episode of 99% Invisible. And now for a third time, I wanted him to be our final guest. In my mind, there really was no one else who it could be. You know what I can't believe is it's 50 years since it came out. I just can't believe it. I mean, it seems really, it's corny. It seems like yesterday, you know?
当时他们正在举办一个特别展览，庆祝《权力掮客》出版50周年。展览是从卡罗先生的档案中策划的，讲述了《权力掮客》从始至终的故事。你可以在《99%隐形》最近的一期节目中听到更多关于展览的信息，以及我们与卡罗先生在学会的对话。现在是第三次，我希望他能成为我们的最后一位嘉宾。在我看来，真的没有其他人选了。你知道我无法相信的是，它出版已经50年了。我简直不敢相信。我的意思是，这听起来真的很老套。感觉就像昨天一样，你知道吗？
And that's really frightening. Actually, I wish I could say there's something good about that. It's really frightening. You haven't seen the exhibit here in New York on the Power Broker, have you? When you were here, did you go through? We got to take a quick look at it. Yeah, we got to look at it.
这真的很可怕。实际上，我希望我能说这有什么好的。这真的很可怕。你还没看过纽约那个关于《权力掮客》的展览，对吧？你来的时候，去看了吗？我们快速浏览了一下。是的，我们看了。
And the curator showed us some of the highlights of it. It's really, it's, there was something, it was so, it was very exciting to see all the real work that you did, you know, to see your original papers and things like that, which to you, I'm sure, are just papers that you wrote on at one point. But to us, they're like, you know, it's like we're taking a pilgrimage to Lourdes or something like that, and we're seeing the holy artifacts and things. It was very exciting to see that stuff. You know, I said to the woman who put it together, you really want to tell the story of a book. Nobody's really done that. And she starts off with my letter to him asking for permission to do the book,
策展人向我们展示了一些亮点。这真的很……看到你所做的所有真实工作，看到你的原始手稿和类似的东西，这真的很令人兴奋。对你来说，我敢肯定，那只是你曾经写过的纸张。但对我们来说，就像是去卢尔德朝圣一样，我们看到了神圣的文物。看到那些东西非常令人兴奋。你知道，我对那个策划展览的女士说，你真的想讲述一本书的故事。没人真正做到过这一点。她从我写给他的那封请求授权写书的信开始，
and his letter to me saying basically, fuck off. You know, it goes all the way to the good reviews. Anyway, I'll stop talking and let you guys. Well, thank you again for taking the time and speaking with us. It's just been a real pleasure to be with you and be blessed in this journey of breaking down the power broker.
以及他回给我的那封基本上是让我“滚蛋”的信。你知道，一直到那些好评。总之，我不说了，让你们来。好吧，再次感谢你抽出时间与我们交谈。能和你在一起，并在这段解析《权力掮客》的旅程中受到你的祝福，真是太荣幸了。
Thank you. Having your presence and your semi-authorization for us on this journey has been really wonderful. And we're so thankful for it. When you could have reacted the same way that Mr. Moses did when you got in touch with him, you could have easily said, I want no part of this. No, thank you. My lawyers are getting involved.
谢谢。有你的出席以及你对我们这段旅程的半授权，真是太棒了。我们非常感激。当你当初联系他时，你本可以像摩西先生那样反应，你可以很容易地说，我不想参与其中。不，谢谢。我的律师会介入的。
Yeah. So I just wanted to start with the end. We talked before about how much time you spend on beginning sentences and ending sentences. How long did you know why why weren't they grateful, was going to be your final line? I didn't know it for a long time, and if I hadn't heard it,
是的。所以我想从结尾开始。我们之前谈过你花在开头句和结尾句上的时间。你是什么时候知道“为什么他们不感恩？”会成为你的最后一句的？我很久都不知道，如果我没听到那句话，
I don't know that the book would have turned out so well. I'd finished all my research, it was time to start writing. I couldn't find a way to put this vast mass of research together. There was just too much of it. What was going to be the unifying theme? And I was really stuck. Now at that time, Moses, of course, had long since stopped talking to me. But whenever he made a public appearance, I would go and sit in the audience. And on this particular occasion, when I was really stuck on how to do the book,
我不知道这本书会写得这么好。我完成了所有的研究，是时候开始写作了。我找不到一种方法来整合这海量的研究资料。内容实在太多了。统一的主题会是什么？我真的卡住了。当时，摩西当然早就停止和我说话了。但每当他公开露面时，我都会去坐在观众席里。就在那次我真的卡在如何写这本书的时候，
he was dedicating a memorial bench at sight of the 1964 World's Fair. And he got up to give a speech. And in the first two rows were all the Moses men, his engineers and architects. two rows of gray heads. Everybody was getting old. And the theme of his talk was the ingratitude of the public toward great men. And he said, someday we will sit on this bench and ponder the ingratitude of the public toward great men.
他正在1964年世界博览会的遗址上为一张纪念长椅揭幕。他站起来发表讲话。前两排坐着所有的“摩西人”，他的工程师和建筑师们。两排灰白的头发。每个人都在变老。他演讲的主题是公众对伟人的忘恩负义。他说：“总有一天，我们会坐在长椅上，思考公众对伟人的忘恩负义。”
And I saw all these heads nodding, yes, the commission is right, right as always. And I heard someone whisper, yes, why aren't they grateful? And when I heard that line, it sounds magical, all of a sudden, in that moment, the book came together for me. And I knew what had to be the, what was the theme of the whole book and how to organize it. And I remember I raced back as fast as I could
我看到所有的头都在点头，是的，委员是对的，一如既往地对。我听到有人低声说：“是的，为什么他们不感恩？”当我听到那句话时，它听起来很神奇，突然之间，在那一刻，这本书对我来说整合在一起了。我知道了整本书的主题应该是什么，以及如何组织它。我记得我以最快的速度跑回
before I went out of my mind to my office and started outlining the book. And it proved to be Okay, yeah, it proved to be okay Yeah, so that was a and ever since then Elliott and Roman I learned my lesson. I have to have the last line of the book Before I start writing I have to have the last line of the book before I start writing. I have to know it. Wow.
在发疯之前跑回办公室，开始列出书的提纲。事实证明……好吧，是的，事实证明还可以。是的，所以那是……从那以后，埃利奥特和罗曼，我吸取了教训。我必须在开始写作之前就确定书的最后一行。我必须在开始写作之前就确定书的最后一行。我必须知道它。哇。
As soon as I know it, the book falls into place leading up to it. And each time when you choose that last line, that's the one you stick with? Yes. There aren't times where you're like, eh, I'll change it to something else when I get there. It's just hard and fast. That's it. That's right.
一旦我知道了，书的内容就会顺理成章地引向它。每次你选择那最后一行时，你都会坚持到底吗？是的。有没有什么时候你会想，呃，等我写到那儿再换成别的？它是坚定不移的。就是这样。没错。
Wow. I don't change it. It's deeper than a feeling. You suddenly know how the book should be put together. It's a sort of wonderful thing. Now that I know that it will happen, sometimes you sit and think about that for several weeks, but when you find things just get better. Wow. Wow. As we were reading through the book, so much of the early sections of the book, it feels like you are writing about the past.
哇。我不改变它。这比一种感觉更深刻。你突然知道这本书应该如何构建。这是一种美妙的事情。现在我知道它会发生，有时你会坐下来思考几个星期，但当你找到它时，事情只会变得更好。哇。哇。当我们阅读这本书时，书的早期部分，感觉你是在写过去。
You're writing about things that when you were writing were already history. And there's a certain period where it feels like it transitions into contemporary history. When you're writing about Mayor Lindsay or about the 1964 World's Fair, you're writing about things that you are experiencing. And I couldn't help but wonder if it felt different writing about these periods that you only knew through research and writing through these periods of Moses' life that you were, in many cases, already a working reporter during that time. Did it feel different?
你写的是当你写作时已经成为历史的事情。有一段时间，它似乎过渡到了当代史。当你写到林赛市长或1964年世界博览会时，你写的是你正在经历的事情。我不禁想知道，写这些你只通过研究了解的时期，与写这些摩西生活中的时期（在很多情况下，你当时已经是一名在职记者了），感觉是否不同？
It did feel different. It did feel completely different. When I was writing the section on Mayor Lindsay and his later efforts to build the bridges and all, I felt that I was writing a contemporary, I was, I was writing a contemporary story. And as it became apparent to me that he wasn't going to be, later, that he wasn't going to be restored to power when he had been, while I was writing the book he was removed from power as you know. That's when I started to feel so sorry for him, as if I was thinking, oh, he wants to do all these things, and he has nothing to do.
确实感觉不同。感觉完全不同。当我写到林赛市长和他后来建造桥梁的努力时，我觉得我是在写一部当代史，我是在写一个当代的报道。当我很明显地看出他不会……后来，当他不会恢复权力时，在我写书的时候，他被免职了，你知道的。那时我开始为他感到难过，好像我在想，哦，他想做所有这些事情，但他却无事可做。
And when one of his aides said to me, as I think is quoted near the end of the book, imagine this great mind, it's as great as ever, and he has nothing to do with it and nothing to accomplish with it. I felt so the poignance of old age, you know, and the poignance of whatever he had done, however I had judged it, I didn't change my opinion of it, but I remember feeling sorrow for what was going on, not what I was writing about in the past. JS But there's also a sense in those chapters where I can feel your opinion of Lindsay a little bit and your opinion of the world's fair because you were there to bear witness to it. Could you talk
当他的一位助手对我说，我想书的结尾附近引用了这句话，“想象一下这个伟大的头脑，它依然伟大，但他却无事可做，也无法成就任何事情。”我感受到了老年带来的辛酸，你知道，无论他做了什么，无论我如何评判它，我都没有改变我的看法，但我记得为正在发生的事情感到悲伤，而不是为我所写的过去的事情。JS 但在那些章节中，我也能感觉到你对林赛的一点看法，以及你对世界博览会的看法，因为你当时就在现场见证了这一切。你能谈谈
about like maybe the style in writing to like incorporate a little bit more of that first-hand eyewitness account of these people? That's a terrific question, particularly with relation to Lindsay because Lindsay was the darling of the newspapers, you know, he was the darling of the newspapers. He was the darling of the New York Times. And he had set out, he was going to take Moses's power away from him. And Moses goes up to Albany on another visit for one day. And at the end of that, Lindsay is just basically out of it. And that's why I call that chapter the old line.
关于那种写作风格，比如融入更多第一手目击者的叙述吗？这是一个非常棒的问题，特别是关于林赛，因为林赛是报纸的宠儿，你知道，他是报纸的宠儿。他是《纽约时报》的宠儿。他曾打算夺走摩西的权力。摩西去奥尔巴尼进行了一次为期一天的访问。在那之后，林赛基本上就出局了。这就是为什么我把那一章称为“老派”。
Lindsay was the young, bright, very eloquent, talking, parcel of good government. And the old line comes up to Albany at the end of it. Lindsay is finished with his plans. Yeah. It was a great, unbelievable example of Robert Moses' sheer power. Yeah.
林赛是年轻、聪明、非常雄辩、谈吐不凡的“善政”代表。而“老派”在最后来到了奥尔巴尼。林赛的计划彻底结束了。是的。这是一个关于罗伯特·摩西纯粹权力的伟大、令人难以置信的例子。是的。
I hadn't thought about it until you compared it to your realization of this is where this power comes from. That in reading that chapter, it feels like you are trying to say to Lindsay, come on, like, you don't know what you're doing. You've got to figure out what you're doing. This guy knows so much more than you. You can't, and there's something so powerful in that,
我之前没想过，直到你把它比作你意识到这就是权力来源的地方。在读那一章时，感觉你是在试图对林赛说：“得了吧，你不知道你在做什么。你得弄清楚你在做什么。这家伙比你懂得多得多。”你不能……那里面有一种非常强大的东西，
I think maybe because you're saying to Lindsay, I had to go through this realization, you need to do this, you're the mayor. It feels like if you're getting, there's this frustration with him that is so powerful that I really love in that chapter. It really feels if you're getting, there's this frustration with him that is so powerful that I really love in that chapter. It really feels like you're there watching you get frustrated at this guy
我想也许是因为你在对林赛说：“我必须经历这种认识，你需要这样做，你是市长。”这种对他产生的挫败感非常强烈，我真的很喜欢那一章。真的感觉……这种对他产生的挫败感非常强烈，我真的很喜欢那一章。真的感觉你就在那里看着自己对这家伙感到沮丧，
totally underestimating his opponent. That's right. Because the papers called Lindsay's victory over Moses, you know? I said, no one understands. This guy has just taken the measure of you. It wasn't even hard. What was the quote?
完全低估了他的对手。没错。因为报纸称林赛战胜了摩西，你知道吗？我说，没人明白。这家伙刚刚衡量了你的斤两。这甚至都不难。那句名言是什么？
It's been so long since I wrote it. Someone said something about he was so handsome, he talked so well, and someone said something to Moses that's in the book. I'm sorry, I didn't have it read. We kind of were expecting you to reread the book before the interview. If you haven't, that's okay. But someone said something like, well, you won. It was easy. He said, that's what you get when you have a musical comedy major. I mean, he brushed them off with his left hand. brush them off with his left hand. You know, yeah. That's so funny.
我写它已经很久了。有人说了些关于他长得那么帅，谈吐那么好，然后有人对摩西说了书里的那句话。抱歉，我没读过。我们本来期待你在采访前重读这本书。如果你没读，那也没关系。但有人说类似的话，“好吧，你赢了。这很容易。”他说，“这就是你得到一个音乐喜剧专业学生的结果。”我的意思是，他随手就把他们打发了。随手就把他们打发了。你知道，是的。太搞笑了。
You know, Moses would never, the interesting thing is, till the end of his life, Elia and Roman, would Moses ever have been removed from power if it wasn't for this incredible coincidence that the bank holding the bonds, bonds on which his power rested, the representative of the bondholders by law was the president of the Chase Manhattan Bank, and that was David Rockefeller, the brother of Nelson Rockefeller, the governor. If that concatenation hadn't occurred, would he ever have been lost? Because he rested his power, and it had worked for 44 years, he rested his power on the fact that the bonds could not be changed.
你知道，摩西永远不会……有趣的是，直到他生命的尽头，埃利奥特和罗曼，如果不是因为这个不可思议的巧合，摩西会被免职吗？持有债券的银行，他权力所依赖的债券，法律规定的债券持有人代表是切斯曼哈顿银行的行长，那就是大卫·洛克菲勒，纳尔逊·洛克菲勒州长的兄弟。如果那个连锁反应没有发生，他会失败吗？因为他依靠他的权力，而且这已经奏效了44年，他依靠的是债券不能被更改的事实。
And if anyone tried to change the bonds and reduce his power, then the trustee for the bondholders would sue and would win. And he never anticipated that the trustee might be the brother of the governor and therefore get to do it. And then when I did come to the conclusion after I wrote the book is if that coincidence hadn't occurred, Robert Moses would have gone right on indefinitely. I mean, that's an amazing scene. And actually, I have a question about that scene
如果有人试图更改债券并削弱他的权力，那么债券持有人的受托人就会起诉并获胜。他从未预料到受托人可能是州长的兄弟，从而能够做到这一点。当我写完书后得出的结论是，如果那个巧合没有发生，罗伯特·摩西会无限期地继续下去。我的意思是，那是一个令人惊叹的场景。实际上，我有一个关于那个场景的问题，
because there's a couple instances in the book where there are only one or two people, well, two probably, there are only two people present in a room, and they're the only ones who know what was actually discussed. And this deal was made between Nelson, David, and Bob Moses, and you don't know exactly what was said.
因为书中有几个例子，房间里只有一两个人，好吧，可能是两个，只有两个人，他们是唯一知道实际讨论了什么的人。这笔交易是在纳尔逊、大卫和鲍勃·摩西之间达成的，你不知道确切说了什么。
You have to sort of put the picture together through other means and sort of like form it in negative space around it. Yes. You know, at what point do you realize you're not gonna get a firsthand account and then begin to piece it together, what was said and what was determined?
你必须通过其他方式把画面拼凑起来，并在周围的负空间中形成它。是的。你知道，你在什么时候意识到你不会得到第一手资料，然后开始拼凑说了什么和决定了什么？
In this case, it wasn't as difficult, it's different than every case really. Yeah, sure. In this case, it wasn't that hard for me because Moses had come back and immediately upon his return from the crucial meeting with the governor had talked about it to his aides. I forget which ones.
在这种情况下，这并不困难，它确实与每个案例都不同。是的，当然。在这种情况下，对我来说并不难，因为摩西回来后，在与州长进行关键会晤后，立即向他的助手们谈到了这件事。我忘了是哪几个了。
They're listed in the back of the book. And they all told me Moses' account. And then I followed what was happening to Moses as they took his power away from him, when he thought that disagreement had guaranteed his power. And when he realized step by step that they had taken his power away from him. I was able to watch as Ronan took over for him. Then I would talk to the union leader, Harry Van Oarsdale, and a guy named Brennan of the construction workers. They said, this old guy isn't going to go away.
它们列在书的后面。他们都告诉了我摩西的说法。然后我跟踪了摩西在他们夺走他权力时所发生的事情，当时他认为那次协议保证了他的权力。当他一步步意识到他们夺走了他的权力时。我能够看着罗南接替他的位置。然后我会和工会领袖哈里·范·奥斯代尔以及一个叫布伦南的建筑工人谈话。他们说，这个老家伙不会离开的。
He's going to want to fight back. And then I would come back to them a couple of weeks later and say, well, how's it going? They said, you know, he doesn't have his power anymore. It was a very, as much as I felt one way about Robert Moses, I feel I couldn't, I remember feeling really sad for him. And it's the reason that I entitle my last chapter simply, old. I think if I can be permitted to give you a compliment rather than a question, I think one of the things that makes the book so beautiful and so powerful is that you're bringing so much humanity to the stories of the people that Moses dispossessed, but also to his story as well. And it would be so easy for this book to be about
他会想要反击。然后我会在几周后回到他们那里说，进展如何？他们说，你知道，他不再拥有权力了。这非常……尽管我对罗伯特·摩西有某种看法，但我记得我为他感到非常难过。这就是我把最后一章简单地命名为“老”的原因。我想如果允许我给你一个赞美而不是一个问题，我认为让这本书如此美丽和强大的原因之一是，你为摩西剥夺的人们的故事带来了如此多的人性，也为他自己的故事带来了人性。这本书很容易变成关于
Moses the monster, you know, or something like that. But by those final chapters, I feel like the reader can't help to feel the same way that for all the things he's done that chapters, I feel like the reader can't help to feel the same way that for all the things he's done that the reader might disapprove of, he's still a human being and he still is going through this kind of disappointment and these feelings. I think it's just you accomplish it so beautifully in the book and I think it contributes so much to why people love this book so much that when they finish it, they do have that what feels like a total sense of the person. So anyway, not a question, just a compliment.
摩西这个怪物，你知道，或者类似的东西。但在最后几章中，我觉得读者不禁会有同样的感觉，尽管他做了所有读者可能不赞同的事情，但他仍然是一个人，他仍然在经历这种失望和这些感受。我认为你在书中完成得太美妙了，我认为这在很大程度上促成了为什么人们如此喜爱这本书，以至于当他们读完它时，他们确实有一种对这个人的完整感觉。所以，总之，不是问题，只是一个赞美。
That's a compliment that means so much to me because that's exactly the way I felt. I felt in the last chapters I'm just writing about an old man with a dream and he's coming to grips with the fact that it's not going to be finished. You know, he only, he had two daughters. Both of them were in one way or another great disappointments to him. So his whole family as far as he was concerned, was his grandson Christopher Collins, who was a student at Stanford California College, and he was driving back home, Christmas vacation, and he had an automobile accident and died.
那个赞美对我意义重大，因为那正是我的感受。我觉得在最后几章里，我只是在写一个有梦想的老人，他正在接受这个梦想不会完成的事实。你知道，他只有两个女儿。她们在某种程度上对他来说都是巨大的失望。所以就他而言，他的整个家庭就是他的孙子克里斯托弗·柯林斯，他是加州斯坦福大学的学生，他在圣诞假期开车回家时，发生了车祸去世了。
And you just couldn't help feeling, it's funny to say something like this about Robert Moses, but you just felt terribly sorry for him. Yeah, yeah. When we talked before, you mentioned that you thought no one would really remember Robert Moses today if it weren't for the power broker.
你禁不住感到……对罗伯特·摩西说这样的话很奇怪，但你确实为他感到非常难过。是的，是的。当我们之前谈话时，你提到你认为如果不是因为《权力掮客》，今天没人会真正记得罗伯特·摩西。
Even though all the things he did were so monumental, he would have passed into obscurity because of the nature of his power. And it made me wonder, do you think that there are other power brokers to be written about all kinds of people that we don't know about? That there's a project to be done to examine all these people that shaped our lives that maybe we don't know about and they could be as rich as the power broker is? I mean, all throughout the United States, I'm sure they're exactly what you said. You know, they're people who are unelected, you know, they have unchecked power, you know, and they do things with it.
尽管他所做的一切都是如此宏大，但他会因为他权力的性质而陷入默默无闻。这让我怀疑，你认为还有其他权力掮客值得书写吗？各种我们不知道的人？是否有一个项目可以去审视所有这些塑造了我们生活但我们可能不知道的人，他们可能像《权力掮客》一样丰富？我的意思是，在美国各地，我敢肯定他们正是你所说的那样。你知道，他们是未经选举的人，你知道，他们拥有不受制约的权力，你知道，他们用它做事情。
But none of them are comparable to Robert Moses. I mean, none of them, as far as I know, held power for 44 years. None of them shaped an entire great metropolitan area to the extent that Moses shaped New York City, as we talked about so many times here. Nobody did anything comparable to that. Nobody built anywhere near 620 miles of roads and parkways and publics, you know, this is the greatest city in the Western world, you know, and it's shaped to an extent that no one realized by one man.
但他们中没有一个人能与罗伯特·摩西相比。我的意思是，据我所知，没有一个人掌权44年。没有一个人像摩西塑造纽约市那样塑造了整个大都市区，正如我们在这里谈论过很多次的那样。没有人做过任何与之相比的事情。没有人建造过接近620英里的道路、公园大道和公共设施，你知道，这是西方世界最伟大的城市，你知道，它被一个人塑造到了没人意识到的程度。
But more than that, he did two things that you couldn't really say about anybody else as far as I know. He created this fourth branch of government, the public authority. There were, of course, public authorities before, but nobody had seen the potential of taking a public authority and using it as a vehicle to, number one, stay in power forever. If the governor's brother hadn't happened to be the trustee, he would be in there forever.
但更重要的是，他做了两件事，据我所知，你不能真正对任何人说。他创造了政府的第四个分支，公共当局。当然，之前也有公共当局，但没有人看到过利用公共当局作为工具的潜力，第一，永远保持权力。如果州长的兄弟碰巧不是受托人，他会永远待在那里。
And to fully realize what a public authority could do. Today, there are so many public authorities. But in its modern form, Robert Moses invented it. And Robert Moses also taught highway builders that they didn't have to be afraid of ramming expressways right through cities. Everyone before Moses had said, oh my God, I can't do that. I'm dispossessing 20,000 people or something.
并充分实现公共当局能做什么。今天，有许多公共当局。但在其现代形式中，罗伯特·摩西发明了它。罗伯特·摩西还教导公路建设者，他们不必害怕直接在城市中修建高速公路。摩西之前的所有人都说，哦天哪，我不能那样做。我正在剥夺20,000人或类似的人。
He taught them, just go ahead, what can they do about it? And the very nature of highways, I mean I remember looking at his schedules at Belmont Lake State Parks and the delegations of highway builders from New Orleans, Harley Way builders from this city, from that city, they came out to learn how to build modern highways from this one man. So you really say, while there are other unelected officials with unchecked power who do the same sort of things that Robert Moses did, nobody is even close to being in the same class or having the same impact
他教导他们，尽管去做，他们能做什么？高速公路的本质，我的意思是，我记得查看他在贝尔蒙特湖州立公园的日程安排，来自新奥尔良的公路建设者代表团，来自这个城市、那个城市的公路建设者，他们来到这里向这一个人学习如何建造现代高速公路。所以你真的可以说，虽然还有其他未经选举的官员拥有不受制约的权力，做着罗伯特·摩西所做的同样的事情，但没有人接近他的级别或产生同样的影响
on history as he did. being in the same class or having the same impact on history as he did. So if we did a podcast series on one of those people, it would be like six episodes maybe. We wouldn't do a full year on it. We could get away with just a few months maybe. Well, on the subject of him looming so large, this brings me to another thing I was curious about is that after you finished The Power Broker,
在历史上像他那样。所以如果我们对其中一个人做一系列播客，那可能就是六集。我们不会花一整年时间。我们可能只需要几个月就能搞定。好吧，关于他影响深远的话题，这让我想到了另一件我好奇的事情，那就是在你完成《权力掮客》之后，
you had a mind to do a biography of LaGuardia. And you abandoned that biography because you felt like you kind of already wrote most of it. Yeah. Like, and so, but I was wondering, like, if you were to write the story of LaGuardia from the point of view of LaGuardia, how large a presence would Moses loom in his life?
你曾想写一部拉瓜迪亚的传记。你放弃了那部传记，因为你觉得你好像已经写了大部分。是的。就像，所以，但我很好奇，如果你从拉瓜迪亚的角度写拉瓜迪亚的故事，摩西在他的生活中会占据多大的存在感？
Like, as written in The Power Broker, it seems like he was in his face every day. But maybe that isn't how it was working, you know, like when you were sort of conceiving of the LaGuardia story. Well, LaGuardia has a great story before he ever became mayor, you know? Yeah.
就像在《权力掮客》中写的那样，看起来他每天都在他面前。但也许事实并非如此，你知道，就像你构思拉瓜迪亚故事时那样。好吧，拉瓜迪亚在成为市长之前就有一个伟大的故事，你知道吗？是的。
Robert Moses didn't figure in that part of his life at all. When he is mayor, Robert Moses had a huge presence in his life. So if it's a biography of LaGuardia, and as it happens a friend of mine, Brenda Wineapple, is writing a biography of LaGuardia and as it happens a friend of mine, Brenda Wineapple is writing a biography of LaGuardia right now. If you took his whole life, Robert Moses would have a much smaller presence.
罗伯特·摩西在他生命的那部分里根本没有出现。当他是市长时，罗伯特·摩西在他的生活中有着巨大的存在感。所以如果这是一部拉瓜迪亚的传记，而且碰巧我的一个朋友，布伦达·温阿普尔，正在写一部拉瓜迪亚的传记，而且碰巧我的一个朋友，布伦达·温阿普尔正在写一部拉瓜迪亚的传记。如果你写他的一生，罗伯特·摩西的存在感会小得多。
Can I say, if I can say something very boastful about the book, please. We'll allow it. One of the things that I tried to do was show, let me take not LaGuardia, but Al Smith. You say, what a great man. So I tried to put into The Power Broker enough of Al Smith. So I remember thinking, God, you can either do a history of the rise of the Irish in New York
我能说，如果我能对这本书说一些非常自夸的话，请允许。我们会允许的。我尝试做的事情之一是展示，让我不拿拉瓜迪亚，而是拿阿尔·史密斯举例。你说，多么伟大的人。所以我试图在《权力掮客》中放入足够多的阿尔·史密斯。所以我记得当时想，天哪，你可以写一部纽约爱尔兰人崛起的历史，
or you can do the story of Al Smith. So I tried to get into the book, not just Robert Moses, but the history through which he was moving. I mean, so much of that, I have to say, is among the stuff that had to be cut out of the Power Broker because it was just too long. But I hope enough of it remains in there so you're seeing it's not just a story of Robert Moses. What the book does is it sort of lights up your imagination to want to enjoy those parts, but also to want to learn more about all these people.
或者你可以写阿尔·史密斯的故事。所以我试图写进书里的，不仅仅是罗伯特·摩西，而是他所处的历史。我的意思是，我不得不说，其中很多内容是必须从《权力掮客》中删减的内容，因为它实在太长了。但我希望其中保留了足够多的内容，这样你看到的不仅仅是罗伯特·摩西的故事。这本书的作用是它点燃了你的想象力，让你想要享受那些部分，但也想要更多地了解所有这些人。
It's really an amazing feat to just be reading along and then have 17 pages of a fantastic biography of Al Smith is a really joyful thing to experience. And having read a lot of biographies, it's often very frustrating when you're reading a biography and the author says, but this person's interesting too, and they lose sight of their main focus for a while. And I feel like that does not happen in The Power Broker.
这真是一个了不起的壮举，读着读着，然后有17页关于阿尔·史密斯的精彩传记，这是一种非常快乐的体验。读过很多传记，当你读传记时，作者说“但这个人也很有趣”，然后他们暂时失去了主要焦点，这通常非常令人沮丧。我觉得这在《权力掮客》中没有发生。
Or in your Lyndon Johnson books, in Master of the Senate, when you're like, okay, if you want to understand Lyndon Johnson in the Senate, I'm going to have to tell you the entire history of the Senate. And in another book, in other authors' hands, you might be like, oh boy. But as soon as you, as soon as you launch into something like that, I'm like, okay, great. This is gonna be fantastic. I'm gonna learn some other stuff. This will be great. Well, sometimes, Elliot, they're great moments cause that. I mean, Lyndon Johnson, can I tell you one thing about that? You know?
或者在你的林登·约翰逊书中，在《参议院的主人》中，当你写道，“好吧，如果你想了解参议院的林登·约翰逊，我必须告诉你参议院的全部历史。”而在另一本书中，在其他作者手中，你可能会想，哦天哪。但一旦你，一旦你开始写这样的东西，我就想，好吧，太棒了。这会很精彩。我会学到其他东西。这会很棒。好吧，有时，埃利奥特，它们是伟大的时刻，因为那个。我的意思是，林登·约翰逊，我能告诉你关于那件事的一件事吗？你知道吗？
Please, sure. Please. I'm trying to figure out how to do the Lyndon Johnson book. I've done a lot of the research. But what I've never done is go into the Senate when nobody was there, you know? And I had a friend, Don Richie, who was the historian of the United States Senate, and I asked him to take me down one day when the Senate wasn't
请，当然。请。我正在试图弄清楚如何写林登·约翰逊的书。我已经做了很多研究。但我从未做过的是在没人时进入参议院，你知道吗？我有一个朋友，唐·里奇，他是美国参议院的历史学家，我请他有一天带我下去，当参议院没有
there, when no one was there. And you walk, you know, you walk into the Senate through a door, like the highest tier of seats, and you walk down through the tier of seats and you're standing in the well of the center and you turn around and all of a sudden you are surrounded by these four glowing because their mahogany deaths polished to a glow and there's a glow from the ceiling on them one after the other. And I remember thinking my first, I had a thought right then I said, Webster's hand rested on one of those deaths when he rose to challenge Hayne.
在那里，当没人时。你走，你知道，你通过一扇门走进参议院，就像最高层的座位，你走下座位层，你站在参议院的井里，你转过身，突然你被这些发光的桃花心木桌子包围了，它们被擦得发亮，天花板上的光照在它们上面，一个接一个。我记得我当时想，我的第一个，我当时有一个想法，我说，韦伯斯特在挑战海恩时，他的手放在了其中一张桌子上。
I thought the Senate, the Civil War, you have to do that if you're gonna tell Lyndon Johnson. I don't wanna tell you what my editor might have said about the necessity of cutting that, but it wasn't cut. Well, I just imagine him just flipping through pages after pages of the manuscript, going like, how much, how long is this just trying to figure it out? But it creates such a sense of continuity, such a sense that these things you're writing about
我想参议院，内战，如果你要写林登·约翰逊，你必须这样做。我不想告诉你我的编辑可能对删减它的必要性说了什么，但它没有被删减。好吧，我只是想象他翻阅着一页又一页的手稿，心想，这到底有多长，只是试图弄清楚它。但这创造了一种连续感，一种你所写的事情
exist in a real history, in a real time, as opposed to just in their own little bubbles of reality. It sounds like it was, that part of the thinking of saying, I have to place this person in the world they're in and in the history they're in, rather than plucking them out and isolating them. Yes, sir. For someone to really understand it. Yes, sir.
存在于真实的历史中，在真实的时间里，而不是仅仅存在于他们自己的现实小气泡中。听起来，那种说“我必须把这个人放在他所处的环境和历史中，而不是把他挑出来孤立他”的想法，就是那一部分。是的，先生。为了让某人真正理解它。是的，先生。
I regard the Johnson books as not just a story of Lyndon Johnson, but the story, the history of American politics for about 50 years of American history. You know, today, when I read the newspapers, and you say the Senate may give in to Donald Trump, I want to say to them, don't do that. Don't you know? You are senators of the United States. You know what the Senate used to be?
我把约翰逊的书不仅看作是林登·约翰逊的故事，而且是美国政治约50年历史的故事。你知道，今天，当我读报纸时，你说参议院可能会向唐纳德·特朗普屈服，我想对他们说，不要那样做。你不知道吗？你们是美国的参议员。你知道参议院过去是什么样吗？
The Senate could be that again. It has the power to be that again. Then it had a Lyndon Johnson who understood that and mobilized those powers, you know, and you say this is an important part of American history. Lyndon Johnson, the way he brings Roosevelt's New Deal, electricity, crop rotation, farmers loans, when he brings them to Lyndon Johnson's congressional district among You know a hundred congressional districts if I do Lyndon Johnson, right?
参议院可以再次成为那样。它有能力再次成为那样。那时有一个了解这一点并动员这些权力的林登·约翰逊，你知道，你说这是美国历史的重要组成部分。林登·约翰逊，他如何带来罗斯福的新政、电力、轮作、农民贷款，当他把它们带到林登·约翰逊的国会选区时，在一百个国会选区中，如果我写林登·约翰逊，对吧？
You're gonna understand the reader more about Roosevelt and about the New Deal than is otherwise understood because no one else no other book is doing this really and I had that feeling I have the feeling with the book I'm doing right now, the last volume, okay? You want to say Johnson did these wonderful things, he passed Medicare, education, voting rights, etc. I think I give him full credit. It's magical that he gets these things through. I said, and he had so much more he wanted to do, and he had the power to do it,
你将会比以往任何时候都更了解罗斯福和“新政”，因为没有其他人、没有其他书真正做到这一点。我在写现在这本书——最后一卷时也有这种感觉，好吗？你想说约翰逊做了这些了不起的事情，他通过了医疗保险、教育、投票权法案等等。我认为我给予了他充分的肯定。他能把这些事情办成简直是不可思议。我说过，他还有很多想做的事，而且他有权力去实现，
unless he threw it all away, and he threw it all away. He unleashed the dogs of war. And you want to say one of the things I'm trying to do here, and this book is getting so long again, is to show how a modern industrialized nation makes war on a little rural country, the other side of the world that's not bothering at all, and what are the implications for that and how did this happen? That we had 600,000 men there and millions of people, probably about two million died from the bombing there. How did this all happen? You have to show the reader how this happened and you can't just show it in isolation. You have to anyway
除非他把这一切都挥霍掉，而他确实挥霍掉了。他释放了战争的恶魔。我想说的是，我在这里试图做的事情之一——这本书又变得这么长了——就是展示一个现代工业化国家是如何对地球另一端一个完全没有打扰过它的小型农业国家发动战争的，其影响是什么，以及这一切是如何发生的？我们在那里有60万士兵，数百万人，大概有两百万人死于那里的轰炸。这一切是怎么发生的？你必须向读者展示这一切是如何发生的，你不能孤立地展示它。无论如何，你必须
you understand me, don't you? Yeah, give all the context to that. The decisions he's making in the White House are affecting people thousands of miles away and it sounds like you're saying you have to understand those people and what it does to them. You can't just stay in the Oval Office with Johnson. You've got to go out to see what's actually the same way that you had to see the effect of his work during the New Deal to really understand it. And we can see that in the power broker too in your emphasis on the effects of things, not just on the decision making,
你明白我的意思，对吧？是的，提供所有相关的背景。他在白宫做出的决定影响着数千英里外的人们，听起来你是说你必须了解那些人以及这些决定对他们造成的影响。你不能只待在约翰逊的椭圆形办公室里。你必须走出去看看实际情况，就像你必须看到他在“新政”期间的工作效果才能真正理解它一样。我们在《权力掮客》中也能看到这一点，你强调的是事物的后果，而不仅仅是决策过程，
but on the consequences of those decisions, which sounds like it's a lot of work to do. If I was you, I'd go the easy way out. I don't think I'd put all the information in, but that's why you've written these books and I haven't, I guess. I did, it did bring to mind a question when we were talking about Lyndon Johnson. And I mean, the interesting thing
而是那些决定的后果，这听起来是一项巨大的工作。如果我是你，我会选择走捷径。我不认为我会把所有的信息都放进去，但我想这就是为什么你写了这些书而我没有的原因。确实，当我们谈论林登·约翰逊时，这让我想到了一个问题。我的意思是，有趣的是
about the Lyndon Johnson books is that while you were doing interviews for the second Lyndon Johnson book, a funny thing happened is that people had read the first Lyndon Johnson books is that while you were doing interviews for the second Lyndon Johnson book, a funny thing happened is that people had read the first Lyndon Johnson book. They had come, like they were aware of what you were doing. And you know, and it changes sort of the dynamic of interviewing a little bit.
关于林登·约翰逊的书，当你在为第二本林登·约翰逊的书做采访时，发生了一件有趣的事，那就是人们已经读过了第一本林登·约翰逊的书。他们来了，就像他们知道你在做什么一样。你知道，这在某种程度上改变了采访的动态。
Like they trust you with these secret diaries. They are aware of where you're coming from. And I was wondering if you think you would have, if The Power Broker was published in different parts, would you have gotten different cooperation from your interview subjects? Had they known what you were, the enterprise that you were taking on?
比如他们信任你，把这些秘密日记交给你。他们知道你的立场。我想知道，如果你认为《权力掮客》是分部分出版的，你会从你的采访对象那里得到不同的配合吗？如果他们知道你正在进行的这项事业的话？
Well, let me put it this way. I mean, if they thought the book would have just disappeared like most books disappear, that wouldn't have been the case. I think I was helped, to tell you the truth, by the fact that the first volume of the Johnson, while I got all this criticism from Johnson people, by the time I was doing, let's say the third volume, people did understand that and were more anxious. And they come, by the third book, people were coming to me, you know, I mean, and saying, I want to talk to you about so and so. Yes.
嗯，让我这样说吧。我的意思是，如果他们认为这本书会像大多数书一样消失，那情况就不会是这样了。老实说，我认为我受益于这样一个事实：虽然第一卷约翰逊传受到了约翰逊身边人的所有批评，但当我写到，比如说第三卷时，人们确实理解了这一点，也更渴望（接受采访）。到了第三本书，人们主动来找我，你知道，我的意思是，说：“我想和你谈谈某某人。”是的。
Like, I've got to be a part of this. I'm not going to be left out. You need to know my side of things. Well, yes, that's, you do, now that I'm doing the fifth volume, I hear in people's voices, I don't want to get left out. I hear that a lot. Yeah.
就像，“我必须参与其中。我不能被落下。你需要知道我的看法。”嗯，是的，确实如此。现在我正在写第五卷，我在人们的声音中听到了，“我不想被落下。”我经常听到这句话。是的。
Yeah. Mr. Caro, one of the things that I don't know if you know, but this podcast has been really popular like popular beyond our wildest imaginations. So like yesterday, Time Magazine named it one of the top 10 podcasts of the year. It's just been this amazing ride as really a testament to the enduring power of your work that there's this 50 yearyear-old book, it's very long, it requires a commitment by people to read it, and people have been very committed to reading it
是的。卡罗先生，有一件事我不知道你是否知道，但这个播客非常受欢迎，受欢迎程度超出了我们最疯狂的想象。比如昨天，《时代》周刊将其评为年度十大播客之一。这真是一段奇妙的旅程，确实证明了你作品的持久力量，这是一本50年前的书，它非常长，需要人们投入精力去阅读，而人们一直非常致力于阅读它，
and hearing about it at length and discussing it, and it's just been a blast, and it's been reaching, I think, a new audience. We've had over six million downloads of these episodes, and it's just really been something. Well, that's, of course, a great feeling for a writer, you know, to think that his book has lasted 50 years, you know, and you think, you know,
并详细了解它、讨论它，这真是太棒了，而且我认为它正在触及新的受众。这些剧集下载量已超过六百万次，这真的很了不起。嗯，这对作家来说当然是一种伟大的感觉，你知道，想到他的书已经流传了50年，你知道，你会想，你知道，
I don't know if you went into this on other podcasts, but there's a timeliness because of Donald Trump's ascension to the presidency and the fact that all the normal checks on a president seem to be disappearing, you know? And you say, well, that's exactly the underlying point of the power broker. Unchecked power is a terrible thing. You can talk your way around it all you want, but unchecked power has terrible consequences. And Robert Moses' power for 44 years, think of that 44
我不知道你是否在其他播客中谈过这个问题，但由于唐纳德·特朗普登上总统宝座，以及总统身上所有正常的制衡似乎都在消失，这具有一种及时性，你知道吗？你说，嗯，这正是《权力掮客》的根本观点。不受制约的权力是一件可怕的事情。你可以随心所欲地为它辩解，但不受制约的权力会产生可怕的后果。罗伯特·摩西44年的权力，想想那44
years, was largely, for most of those years, was unchecked in the fields in which he chose to exercise it, which were the fields that shaped the city. And to say, well, wait a minute, someone else is coming along here now. And there's one by one, the courts, the Senate is actually considering going into recess so they don't have to assume one of their responsibilities. Do the advice and consent. You say there's such a parallel between this there's a horror to it But I'll say beyond that it's just a great thing for a writer to feel that his
年，在大多数年份里，在他选择行使权力的领域里，基本上是不受制约的，而这些领域正是塑造城市的地方。所以说，等一下，现在又有人来了。一个接一个，法院，参议院实际上正在考虑休会，这样他们就不必承担他们的责任之一。履行建议和同意权。你说这之间有如此多的相似之处，这很可怕。但我还要说，除此之外，对于一个作家来说，感觉到他的
You know if you learn something about let me put it this way if you think that you've learned something about the nature of political power And you want people to know it. You don't want just one generation to know it. You want a lot of generations to know it. So to think that this new generation is learning it from the power broker. I mean, that couldn't be more heartwarming to me, to be honest with you.
你知道，如果你学到了一些关于政治权力本质的东西，并且你想让人们知道它。你不想只有一代人知道它。你希望很多代人都知道它。所以想到新一代人正在从《权力掮客》中学习它。老实说，这对我来说再暖心不过了。
But whatever has happened with the power broker this year, I'm boastful enough to think that it's something wonderful. I agree. I think it's giving us a greater understanding and the consequence of what's happening right now. It's very important. Okay. Elliot and Roman, it's been very nice meeting you. I hope I meet you again sometime. We hope so too. That'd be wonderful. I would love that, Samson. We hope so, too. That'd be wonderful. I would love that. Take care. That's it. We did it.
但无论今年《权力掮客》发生了什么，我足够自豪地认为这是一件美妙的事情。我同意。我认为它让我们对现在发生的事情及其后果有了更深刻的理解。这非常重要。好的。埃利奥特和罗曼，很高兴见到你们。希望以后有机会再见到你们。我们也希望如此。那太棒了。我会很喜欢的，萨姆森。我们也希望如此。那太棒了。我会很喜欢的。保重。就是这样。我们做到了。
I can't really believe that we did it. We did it, Roman. Can you believe this? I can't. It's really been amazing. It's been an amazing year, for sure. Yeah. We covered the whole book.
我真的不敢相信我们做到了。我们做到了，罗曼。你能相信吗？我不能。这真的很神奇。这绝对是神奇的一年。是的。我们讲完了整本书。
We said at the start of the year,. Yeah, we covered the whole book. We said at the start of the year, we were gonna cover this whole book, and the whole time, I was kind of like, there's no way we're gonna cover this whole book. And then we did it, we covered the whole book. I mean, yeah, we said we would do it, but I just can't get over it.
我们在年初时说……是的，我们讲完了整本书。我们在年初时说我们要讲完这本书，整个过程中，我一直觉得，我们不可能讲完这本书。然后我们做到了，我们讲完了整本书。我的意思是，是的，我们说过我们会做，但我还是无法释怀。
I can't really believe we actually did it. And not only did we do it, it's been just the highlight of my year, spending this time with you, talking about the Power Broker, really engaging with people who are truly engaging with the material and have been enjoying it and been with us for like three and a half hour episodes, which is just crazy to me.
我真的不敢相信我们真的做到了。不仅如此，这还是我今年最大的亮点，和你一起度过这段时间，谈论《权力掮客》，真正与那些真正投入到材料中、一直很享受并陪伴我们度过三四个小时剧集的人们互动，这对我来说简直太疯狂了。
And saying to us more, more, longer, longer. Yeah, exactly, exactly. And the whole team and you know, like Isabelle has been working with us on this and all the group at 9NPI that's been making it happen. It's just been such a blast. Yeah, it's been so much fun. This project has been incredibly fun,
并且对我们说“更多，更多，更长，更长”。是的，没错，没错。还有整个团队，你知道，比如伊莎贝尔一直和我们一起做这件事，还有99PI的所有团队成员，他们让这一切成为现实。这真是太棒了。是的，这太有趣了。这个项目非常有趣，
which when you say to people, I'm gonna do a podcast where every month I cover 100 pages of The Power Broker with Roman, they go, well Roman sounds fun, but I don't know if the whole project sounds fun. But I've looked forward to every recording to making every episode with you I did and I just can't overestimate how meaningful It's been to me to get to do this project with you to have this opportunity to engage so deeply with this book that has
当你告诉人们，“我要做一个播客，每个月我和罗曼一起讲《权力掮客》的100页”，他们会说，“嗯，罗曼听起来很有趣，但我不知道整个项目听起来是否有趣。”但我期待着每一次录音，期待着和你一起制作每一集。我确实期待，我无法高估与你一起做这个项目对我来说有多么重要，能有这个机会如此深入地参与到这本书中，它
Meant so much to me, you know for for more than two decades now And it still means so much to me and this project has made it mean even more to me because I got to share it with you, Roman, and I got to share it with Isabelle and everyone else who worked on the show. And we got to share this with you, the viewers. Sorry, listeners. I forgot. I forgot how to talk this. We got to share it with you, the listeners.
对我来说意义重大，你知道，已经超过二十年了。它对我来说仍然意义重大，而这个项目让它对我来说意义更加重大，因为我有机会和你分享它，罗曼，我有机会和伊莎贝尔以及所有为节目工作的人分享它。我们有机会和你们，观众们分享它。抱歉，听众们。我忘了。我忘了怎么说话了。我们有机会和你们，听众们分享它。
Thank you for joining us. Thank you for making this possible. This is really, I mean, I'll just go on and on about it, but it was just really a dream come true to be connected suddenly with this work that means so much to me and with a writer to have gotten the chance to interact with Mr. Caro in such a regular way is amazing.
感谢你们加入我们。感谢你们让这一切成为可能。这真的，我的意思是，我会一直说下去，但这真的是梦想成真，突然与这部对我意义重大的作品联系在一起，并有机会以如此常规的方式与卡罗先生互动，真是太神奇了。
That's amazing. When he first said yes to coming on the show, I was completely just gobsmacked by the whole idea of it. Like, oh my God, we're actually talking to him. And then we got to interview him three times and once on stage, which has just like been a totally a dream come true. So it's just been so much fun and we're not quite ready to say goodbye just yet.
这太神奇了。当他第一次答应上节目时，我完全被这个想法惊呆了。就像，天哪，我们真的在和他说话。然后我们采访了他三次，还有一次是在舞台上，这简直就是梦想成真。所以这真的太有趣了，我们还没准备好说再见。
There's going to be some bonus episodes. We're going to have a kind of a book club like discussion episode that will record and release look for those dates coming up in January and February and so just hang out on the discord and you'll find out where to be and where to hear that. And if you can't wait to have more Roman and Elliot talking about things in your ears then why not go over to my other podcast the Flophouse? Roman was a guest on the show talking about Francis Ford Coppola's Megalopolis because the Flophouse is a bad movie guest on the show talking about Francis Ford Coppola's Megalopolis,
会有一些奖励剧集。我们将进行一种类似读书俱乐部的讨论剧集，我们会录制并发布，请留意一月和二月的日期，所以只要在Discord上关注，你就会知道在哪里以及在哪里听到它。如果你等不及想听到更多罗曼和埃利奥特在你的耳朵里谈论事情，那么为什么不去听我的另一个播客《Flophouse》呢？罗曼是该节目的嘉宾，谈论弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉的《大都会》，因为《Flophouse》是一个烂片节目，谈论弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉的《大都会》，
because the Flophouse is a bad movie podcast and Megalopolis is a very bad movie. And it was so much fun. It was so great to have you on the show there, Roman, and to have this official crossover where listeners can kind of get to hear what the kind of power broker after show is like. Like, your appearance is kind of like a looser kind of party version of the power broker. That's right. That's right. I mean, that is a mess of a movie that I panned very harshly, but it was super fun to talk about it.
因为《Flophouse》是一个烂片播客，而《大都会》是一部非常烂的电影。这太有趣了。罗曼，你能来参加节目真是太好了，能有这次官方的联动，让听众们能听到《权力掮客》的后续节目是什么样的。就像，你的出现就像是《权力掮客》的一个更轻松的派对版本。没错，没错。我的意思是，那是一部我严厉批评的烂电影，但谈论它超级有趣。
Make sure to get your power broker breakdown merch. That's right. You can have physical things because if the story of Robert Moses tells us anything, it is that physical construction, physical objects are the be all and end all of human achievement. The only things that matter. There's the Robert Moses band t-shirt with the dates of each episode on it. I love that shirt so much. I wear it out in public. No one ever says hi to me and hey, are you Elliot from the podcast? But if you see me wearing it, feel free to do that. Just go ahead and
一定要买你的《权力掮客》周边商品。没错。你可以拥有实物，因为如果罗伯特·摩西的故事告诉了我们什么，那就是物质建设、物质对象是人类成就的全部和终点。唯一重要的事情。有罗伯特·摩西乐队的T恤，上面印着每一集的日期。我太喜欢那件衬衫了。我穿着它在公共场合走。从来没有人跟我打招呼说，“嘿，你是播客里的埃利奥特吗？”但如果你看到我穿着它，请随意这样做。尽管去
say hello, but also buy one for yourself. It's a great shirt. There's the power broker bookmarks because this book is huge You need a bookmark. You're not gonna read it all in one sitting and there is also this great bag This tote bag that will easily fit the power broker or your next big read Whatever book you read next that is of equal or greater size to the power broker. Maybe you're gonna read McCulloch's Truman I don't know. You're gonna need a bag to carry it around. This is the perfect bag for that. They're great gifts for your fellow caro head,
打个招呼，但也给自己买一件。这是一件很棒的衬衫。有《权力掮客》的书签，因为这本书太大了，你需要一个书签。你不可能一次读完。还有这个很棒的包，这个手提袋，可以轻松装下《权力掮客》或你的下一本大部头读物，无论你接下来读什么书，只要它的大小等于或大于《权力掮客》。也许你要读麦卡洛的《杜鲁门》，我不知道。你需要一个包来带着它。这是完美的包。它们是送给你的卡罗迷同伴的绝佳礼物，
or come on, who are we kidding? You want them, just buy them for yourself. You can do that, you're an adult. You read the book, you earned this. You read it, you earned the right to buy things for it. That's true, this is the part where I realized adulthood is kind of like, you're allowed to have cookies in your house at all times. That's kind of the like you're allowed to have cookies in your house at all times
或者，得了吧，我们在骗谁呢？你想要它们，就给自己买吧。你可以这样做，你是成年人。你读了这本书，你赢得了这个。你读了它，你就赢得了为它买东西的权利。没错，这就是我意识到成年生活有点像，你被允许随时在家里放饼干。这就是那种你被允许随时在家里放饼干的感觉。
That's kind of big like yeah, you're allowed to just buy cookies and have them around That was when I realized I was an adult So this is kind of the cookie that you can buy yourself that you can have for yourself year-round You don't need a special occasion. You can just have anyone's permission. We're giving you permission and saying you don't need permission That's right And for all the incredible listeners who have taken this entire journey with us, who have read every page of the book, we have something extra special in the Merch Store, and that is a Power Broker Challenge Coin. It has all these symbols and secret messages, and they'll only mean something to you if you've read the book. But since you're no longer carrying
这有点像，是的，你被允许买饼干并把它们放在身边。这就是我意识到自己是成年人的时候。所以这就像你可以给自己买的饼干，你可以全年享用。你不需要特殊场合。你可以得到任何人的许可。我们给你许可，并说你不需要许可。没错。对于所有和我们一起走过这段完整旅程、读过书中每一页的不可思议的听众，我们在周边商店里有一些特别的东西，那就是《权力掮客》挑战币。它有所有这些符号和秘密信息，只有当你读过这本书时，它们才有意义。但既然你不再随身携带
around this four pound book, you can now carry around this coin as a symbol to your commitment to the power broker. And all of this is available at our store at 99pi.org slash store. But until next time, know this, if you've lived your life the right way, you should be at the end asking yourself, why weren't they grateful? That's exactly the moral of the book. That's exactly it, Roman. And as you have turned to the final verse in Power Broker, I would like to turn to the
这本四磅重的书，你现在可以随身携带这枚硬币，作为你对《权力掮客》承诺的象征。所有这些都可以在我们的商店99pi.org/store买到。但直到下次，请记住这一点，如果你以正确的方式度过了一生，你应该在最后问自己，为什么他们不感恩？这正是这本书的寓意。正是如此，罗曼。正如你翻到了《权力掮客》的最后一节，我想翻到
opening verse of Power Broker Book 1 verse 1, as Sophocles potentially says, One must wait until the evening to see how splendid the day has been. We've reached the evening, Roman. And I think this day was pretty great. It was. Splendid. Splendid is the exact right word. The 99% invisible breakdown of The Power Broker is produced by Isabel Angel, edited by committee. Music by Swan Rial, mixed by Dara Hirsch. And a very special thank you to Paul Bogarts. This is Mr. Caro's publicist. Paul, thank
《权力掮客》第一卷第一节的开头，正如索福克勒斯可能说的那样，“必须等到晚上才能看到这一天是多么灿烂。”我们已经到了晚上，罗曼。我认为这一天非常棒。确实。灿烂。灿烂是完全正确的词。《99%隐形》对《权力掮客》的解析由伊莎贝尔·安吉尔制作，委员会编辑。音乐由斯旺·里亚尔创作，达拉·赫什混音。特别感谢保罗·博加茨。这是卡罗先生的公关人员。保罗，谢谢
you so much for understanding this project from the beginning, helping us get your boss on board and just being a great ally in this whole endeavor. We will always be grateful. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Cathy Tu. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall. Kruik Kolstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California.
你从一开始就理解这个项目，帮助我们让你的老板加入，并成为整个努力中伟大的盟友。我们将永远心存感激。《99%隐形》的执行制片人是凯西·图。我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔。克鲁克·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁贝、杰森·德里昂。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。该系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰上城区。
You can find me and the show on all the usual social media sites. I'm spending a lot more time on Blue Sky right now, which has actually been a very pleasant and enjoyable place. So find us and follow us on Blue Sky. We also have our own Discord server where we have fun discussions about the Power Broker, about architecture, about movies and music and flags, other books you might read if you're into the Power Broker, other podcasts you might listen to if you're into this podcast, all kinds of good stuff. It's where I'm hanging out most of the time these days. You can find a link to that Discord server as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Thank you for all the nice things you've said about the power broker and thank you for helping people understand the power broker. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我和这个节目。我现在在Blue Sky上花的时间更多，那实际上是一个非常愉快和令人享受的地方。所以找到我们并在Blue Sky上关注我们。我们也有自己的Discord服务器，我们在那里进行关于《权力掮客》、建筑、电影、音乐和旗帜的有趣讨论，如果你喜欢《权力掮客》，你可能会读的其他书，如果你喜欢这个播客，你可能会听的其他播客，各种各样的好东西。这是我这些天大部分时间待的地方。你可以在99PI.org找到那个Discord服务器的链接以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目。感谢你们对《权力掮客》所说的所有好话，感谢你们帮助人们理解《权力掮客》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。